Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freakshow.
Und zwar nicht irgendeine Freakshow, sondern die 1, 2, 3, 100.
Juhu. Wir haben es also geschafft, endlich hier mal eine signifikante Dezimalzahl auf den Tisch zu legen.
Und so gehen wir jetzt rein. Und
hier ist der Plan, den ich mir für heute gemacht habe. Ich habe keinen.
Weil Ralf hat gesagt, du machst jetzt mal gar nichts.
Ja, du machst was anderes.
Also ihr habt das mitbekommen, wir haben die letzten Sendungen ja etwas damit gehadert.
Mein Gott, was machen wir bloß zur 300 und so groß die Erwartungshaltung und
irgendwie Live-Show und sowas. Hatte irgendwie keiner so richtig die...
Wer hatte denn Erwartungshaltung?
Ja, also ich finde, man muss ja schon irgendwas machen.
Oder? Okay, du hattest eine Erwartungshaltung.
An dich selbst, an uns.
Ich weiß, du hast diesen Begriff, aber an das deutsche Podcast-Wesen.
Wenn so eine Sendung wie die Freakshow 300 wird, ein bisschen was,
finde ich, kann man da schon mal machen und einen Blick zurückwerfen und was
war denn eigentlich so alles und was hat sich ergeben.
Und dann hatten Roddy und ich so eine Idee und so der Grundgedanke war eigentlich
so, wir schenken Tim eine Sendung.
Der reißt sich hier immer für uns den Arsch auf.
Das sind die Momente, wo ich wirklich Angst klicke. Zu Recht.
Wenn du wüsstest.
Nein, also ernsthaft, Tim hat absolut keine Ahnung, was sich in den nächsten
vier, fünf, sechs Stunden hier eignen wird.
Fairerweise wir auch nicht so genau.
Aber wir werden sehen. Wir haben einen Plan, wir haben eine Struktur,
ob sich das denn alles in Chaos auslöst. Ihr werdet dabei sein und das erleben.
Okay.
Aber erstmal großen Respekt an Tim, dass er uns das hier machen lässt.
Kontrollfreak wäre vielleicht jetzt eine böse Zuschreibung. Du liebst ja auch
durchaus irgendwie die Spontanität des Momentes und dass sich Dinge auch so ereignen können.
Aber einfach mal zu sagen, okay gut, ich lehne mich jetzt mal zurück unter der Dinge, die da kommen.
Das wird schon ein bisschen wehtun, das kann ich natürlich verstehen.
Schauen wir mal, ob das hier Sparta sein wird oder nicht.
Ich habe mir noch überlegt, ob ich noch irgendwie so ein lustiges Soundbyte
noch irgendwie aus 300 rauskriege.
Ja, das ist ja das Setup, also du hast hier deinen eigenen Soundkanal,
du hast deinen eigenen Videokanal.
Genau.
Von daher.
Die Grundüberlegung war in der Tat, dass wir mal ein bisschen chronologisch durchgehen.
Es hieß ja auch früher gar nicht Freakshow, sondern es hieß Mobile Max.
Das waren ja alles noch Zeiten, da waren nämlich auch Roddy nicht da und ich
war noch nicht da und Tim hat das mit anderen Leuten gemacht und so im Nachklapp
nach der letzten Sendung war so der zentrale Satz, den du gesagt hast,
so ja, wäre ja schon schön, auch mal so eine Rückschau zu haben,
aber mit wem soll man das denn machen?
Weil wir waren ja nun mal halt nicht so dabei. Naja, und da dachten wir uns
aber, okay, Probleme, die man lösen kann.
Tim, es hat, glaube ich, gerade an der Tür geklingelt.
Es hat an der Tür geklingelt?
Es hat an der Tür geklingelt.
Bist du dir sicher?
Mhm.
Hallo. Hallo. Hallo. Ich glaube, dass jemand Schmerzen braucht.
So, in der Pre-Show sagte Tim noch, na zum Glück gibt es keinen Überraschungsgast.
Hallo Max, herzlich willkommen.
Hallo Max.
Ich habe gehört, dass jemand Schmerzen braucht. Du meinst, du musst jetzt noch
einen Kanal aufmachen? Wir müssen jetzt leider noch einen Kanal aufmachen, Tim, es tut mir so leid.
Aber ich wusste, eine Freakshow, in der es nicht auch ein bisschen Technik-Gefromel gibt.
Ist ja keine echte Freakshow.
So, da haben wir einen Stuhl.
So, okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt doch meinen kaputten Kanal 3,
den ich gerade rausgeschmissen habe, hier wieder rein montieren.
Da kann überhaupt nichts schief gehen, wenn man so mitten während der Sendung
irgendwie am Setup arbeitet.
Also Reaper sollte das in der Tat können.
Naja, du kennst ja das Problem.
Ach, der dritte.
Ja, genau. Der kaputte dritte Kanal. Äh, wo ist er denn da?
So.
Mal gucken.
Gut, dass ich das Backup am Start habe.
Jetzt hat Max hier sogar...
Oh, Max packt sogar noch Geschenke aus.
Aber jetzt kann ich ja gar nicht irgendwelche romantischen Verklärungen von
damals berichten. Jetzt muss das ja alles stimmen.
Die werden ja direkt korrigiert. Oder zumindest anders gesehen.
Okay, jetzt wird es hier weihnachtlich, Leute.
Genau, ein Stollen wird ausgepackt. Genau, also für euch, die ihr vielleicht
auch damals nicht bei der allerersten Stunde mit dabei waren.
Es gibt eine Seite, ich werfe die mal gleich in den Chat rein.
Ja, jetzt habt ihr das schon vor die Nase gelegt. Achso, du bist nicht an. Moment, das stimmt.
Das wäre...
So, jetzt...
Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Kaum macht man es richtig, funktioniert es auch gleich.
Ja, ich habe gedacht, ich mache hier mal so ein Seasonal Appropriate,
Geburtstagskuchen.
Aus dem Erzgebirge steht auf der Packung.
Aus dem Erzgebirge.
Oh mein.
Tim, weißt du aus dem Kopf, wann denn die allererste Mobile Max Folge war?
1. April 2008.
Das ist auffallend richtig.
Alter.
Genau, richtig. Und wer waren die drei, die da angetreten sind? Das weißt du natürlich.
Na klar, ich habe das mit Max und mit Dennis gemacht, Weil mit Max habe ich
ja vorher, wir waren ja sozusagen Co-Blogger.
Ja.
Und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum das überhaupt so einen obskuren Namen hatte.
Ja. Willst du eine Loggeschichte erzählen?
Naja, das fing ja an. Also ich habe damals auf einmal so ein bisschen viel Freizeit gehabt.
Und das war dann so der Moment, wo
ich irgendwie meine ganzen CCC-Organisationsaufgaben habe fallen lassen.
Und dann war ich irgendwie so ein bisschen, na, was machst du denn jetzt?
und zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich ja schon die anderen Podcasts gemacht aber halt nicht diesen,
Und dann, das war ja noch die Zeit, also, wir gehen jetzt in die Vergangenheit.
Okay, pass mal, ich habe einen Vorschlag.
Wir hören einfach mal rein.
Oh Gott, das wurde mir nicht gesagt.
Ich wollte nur die Story vor dem ersten Podcast erzählen.
Nur damit so das Setting klar ist. Also Podcast musste man noch jedem erklären.
Alle guckten einen komisch an, wenn man das Wort benutzt hat.
noch komischer, wenn man sagt, man macht welche.
Das war dann immer so dieser da gibt es doch sicherlich was von Ratio Farben,
Tim, Blick, den man dann bekommen hat.
Inzwischen wird man wieder komisch angeguckt.
Ja, jetzt aus anderen Gründen. Und naja, wir haben ja eine gemeinsame Vergangenheit
mit Johnny Häusler, den wir ja vor 30 Jahren mal mit Chaos Radio angefangen haben.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war ja Johnny schon big in Japan mit seinem Spreeblick-Blog
und so einer der Frontrunner der deutschen Bloggeritis.
Und wie das so ist, alle waren so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach Business-Modellen
und unter anderem machte man sowas wie Blogs für Firmen, die in irgendeiner
Form im Internet irgendwie präsent sein wollten, aber keine Ahnung hatten.
Unter anderem in dem Fall halt O2.
Die Idee war eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, da kann ich ja vielleicht kurz
rein, weil da bin ich ein bisschen näher dran.
Die wollten eigentlich ein Wiki haben, mit dem man damals das noch Junge online
gehen, per Mobilfunk, mit seinem Computer, dass man das damit machen kann.
Und dafür braucht man so Modem-Skripte.
Und die man dann mit seinem Telefon verbunden hat.
Und der wollte halt, weil für Windows gab es halt immer irgendwelche CD-ROMs
dabei, die der Spyware installiert haben und gleichzeitig noch irgendwie dieses
Modem-Skript dazu gepackt haben. Für Mac gab es sowas immer alles nicht.
Und der wollte, der war selber Mac-Nutzer, ich weiß leider nicht mehr wie er
heißt, wäre praktisch gewesen, das rauszusuchen.
der wollte so ein Wiki aufsetzen, wo man dann die entsprechenden Modem-Skripte
machen und da sollte eine Community
entstehen und gleichzeitig sollte als Frontend dafür dann ein Blog her,
in dem das dann alles so drin, also wo dann auch so News sind und ich musste
dann, hab viel zu lange irgendwelche, immer wieder die gleichen Nokia-Telefone getestet.
Wenn die dann rauskamen. Und du wolltest da mitmachen. Und du hast dann gesagt,
lass den Scheiß doch machen.
Also, naja, ich wollte mitmachen. Ich wollte, ich hatte Johnny gesagt,
wenn du irgendwie einen Job hast mit Internet und so und bloggen.
Ich hätte jetzt Zeit und ich hätte auch gerade irgendwie Bock und dann kam er
irgendwie mit Mobamax an und ich dachte mir dann so, ah okay,
so Apple und Internet, irgendwie bloggen, so warum nicht?
Passt ja.
Und hab das dann auch mit Werwe betrieben für ein paar Monate,
bis ich so alle meine Rans, die ich so im Kopf hatte, irgendwie ausgespuckt
habe und dann ermüdete das Ganze wieder und dann ermüdete auch das Interesse
von O2 und das war so ein bisschen die Frage mit, kann man jetzt noch irgendwas damit machen,
um vielleicht diesen Laden dafür zu gewinnen, dieses Projekt zu verlängern, weil das lief halt aus.
Und dann war mein Vorschlag, lass doch einen Podcast draus machen, ist eh geiler.
Das war eigentlich der Pitch und deswegen sind wir dann halt auch gestartet
unter diesem Namen, weil wir quasi aus dem Blog einen Podcast gemacht haben.
Na, dann hören wir jetzt mal rein in die allererste Minute der allerersten Folge,
Mobile Macs. Mal gucken.
Oder hören viel mehr. Ist ja Audio hier.
Hallo, Max. Na, hallo Zuhörer. Die Begrüßung.
Eigentlich alles wie heute, oder?
Das ist konstante Qualität.
Dieses rein Stolpern in die Sendung und erstmal Soundcheck.
Also dieses Dumm-Dudum, das habe ich ja davor und dahinter montiert.
Das kam ja erst später.
Das kam erst deutlich später mit dem Previous.
War das noch vorm Studio? Ich glaube schon, oder? Das war noch vorm Studio.
Ja, nee, warte mal. Also eine Babystimme mit in den Mund gehört.
Ja, nee, das war vor dem Studio. Da haben wir noch in der Wohnung bei mir gesessen.
Da krähte dann schon ab und zu mal ein Baby, aber nur eins. Oder als das zweite
kam, musste dann das Studio ran.
Wir waren Babys.
Wir auch.
Ja, so war das. Und ich fand das eigentlich von Anfang an eine ganz gute Mischung tatsächlich.
Weil wir hatten eigentlich alle eine Menge zu erzählen für die damaligen Verhältnisse.
Ich habe ja wegen der Mischung, weil Dennis ja, wenn ich richtig gehört habe,
aber heute nicht hier sein kann, habe ich einen Dennis-Simulator gevibe-codet
und habe den jetzt gerade an,
Ralf geschickt, damit er den hier mal einspielen kann.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Dennis-Simulator.
Mal gucken. Ja, das sollte klappen.
Okay, das war der Gag. Das war der ganze Gag.
Es läuft jetzt aber auch noch eine Stunde.
Wer das mal braucht, ich werfe es mal in die Shownotes.
Das müsst ihr aber auch erklären jetzt.
Muss man Witze erklären?
Naja, also das ist ja kein Witz, sondern es ist ja eine...
Ein gespielter Witz.
Nein, es ist ein Meme, was man ja nur kennen kann, wenn man sozusagen an diesem
Kulturkanal ausreichend lange teilgenommen hat.
Und damals im Jahr 2008 und als wir die Mikrofone noch nicht richtig ausrichten
könnten, so wie wir es bis heute nicht können,
war Dennis bekannt dafür, dass er öfters mal ins Mikrofon geatmet hat und dass
er von dann, Vadern wurde das auch genannt.
Genau, Dennis, du Vadern.
Das muss man nicht erklären, siehste, sag ich auch.
Das ist dann aber auch schnell so ein stehender Begriff geworden.
Sag ich bis heute, sag ich bis heute. Das ist der offizielle Begriff dafür im Podcast.
Vadern. Ja, ich glaube, es weiß auch jeder, was gemeint ist,
wenn das so eindeutig ist.
So, dann zünden wir mal die nächste Stufe.
Muss ich jetzt eigentlich immer, ist das der Moment, wo ich eine Kapitelmarke
machen muss? Weiß ich nicht. Weil wenn ich jetzt nicht in Newtroll bin, weiß ich ja auch nicht.
Ja, völlig verstehe ich.
Mach ich hier einfach.
Ich fühl's, Tim.
Ja.
Ja, mach mal. So, was wir nämlich ja seit ein paar Sendungen mal gemacht haben,
sind diese schönen Tierlisten.
Und da dachten Roddy und ich, naja, dann machen wir doch mal eine Tierliste
zur Freakshow und zwar mit so klassischen Freakshow-Themen,
die irgendwo doch markant waren und immer sich wiederholt haben und iteriert
wurden und ähnliches. ist.
Und da haben wir einfach mal auch Max gefragt, so was wären denn so Dinge,
die du mit deiner Zeit in der damals Mobile Max ja verbindest.
Jetzt habe ich ja mal einen Link in die Shownotes geworfen. Kannst du mal,
Beamer sind nur bei mir die Mikrofone übersteuert. Also ich finde mich auch
relativ laut, aber das muss nicht unbedingt was heißen.
Übersteuert würde ich es aber nicht nennen.
Also ich habe gerade draußen ja schon im Stream zugehört und es war schon ein
bisschen lauter, als ich gedacht hätte.
Bisschen. Tim hat gesagt, er hat die Kabel gewechselt. Jetzt mit der Goldlitze.
Genau. Da war jetzt wirklich etwas Altersschwäche in den Kabeln. so.
Deswegen haben die auch so geknistert und gerauscht und offensichtlich hat es
auch manche Headsets etwas leise gemacht.
Das ist natürlich wahr.
Ich habe nochmal die Shownotes von den ersten Sendungen durchgeklickert heute
und ich dachte wir hätten in der ersten Folge direkt von Bitcoin geredet und danach hätte...
Wann haben wir das erste Mal von Bitcoin geredet?
Als es das gab.
Eigentlich gar nicht so früh.
Bitcoin gibt es 2010 2010, 11 war das?
Ich dachte 2009 oder 8 sogar schon.
Aber auf jeden Fall, das erste Mal drüber geredet haben wir 2011.
Also insofern, wenn es das erste 2011 gibt, das wäre natürlich fantastisch.
Also Bitcoin sozusagen jetzt als Technik ist Januar 2009, aber da hatten wir
das noch nicht sofort auf der Kette.
Das hat noch ein bisschen gedauert, aber das bin ich auch sehr froh,
dass wir dieses Thema nicht mehr haben.
Also aus Gründen kann ich euch ziemlich exakt sagen, wann ihr das erste Mal
über Bitcoin geredet habt. Das war nämlich am 31.10.2013.
Nee.
In der Sendung Good Riddance, Freakshow 120.
Nein. Das kann nicht sein.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe vorhin gesucht, das war 2011.
Also wenn ich einfach im Archiv gesucht habe und oben Bitcoin eingegeben habe,
dann war das eine Sendung von 2011.
Und 2000, wann war das hier? 2014?
2013.
2013, da war ich ja schon nicht mehr dabei. Wann war denn hier Mount Gox und so?
Ja, das war später, oder?
Naja, aber das haben wir ja hier schon voll abgefeiert, da hatten wir ja sogar einen Song dazu.
Ein Jingle.
Nee, ein Song.
Oder auch ein Song? Ja, stimmt, auch ein Song.
Wir hatten den großartigen von David, den Mt. Gox-Song.
Mt. Gox ist 2010 gestartet und wann ist es untergegangen?
2014.
Also ich musste hier einige Seiten in der Suche zurückgehen und die erste Sendung,
die ich gefunden habe, war MobileMax 68, 10 Meter Bremsspur vom 29.
Juni 2011, wo in der Beschreibung drin steht, und Dennis stellt sein neues Bitcoin-Imperium vor.
Ah, dann hat das glaube ich einen Grund, dass ich das gerade nicht finde,
aber da kommen wir noch zu.
Warum die Daten hier wieder so unscharf sind. Wollen wir mal gucken.
Ja, aber nicht in der ersten Sendung. Aber ich glaube, was so als Thema für
mich die ganze Zeit durchging, also nicht, dass ich nicht besonders scharf drauf
gewesen wäre, ich finde, man kann
über Dateisysteme vielleicht 20 Stunden reden, aber nicht 120 Stunden.
Also ZFS war dieses immer wiederkehrende Thema. Mit den Gerüchten,
dass es jetzt in macOS reinkommt und dann ist es wieder raus ist und dann war
es aus der Beta raus und dann war es wieder drin und dann gab es aber trotzdem
wieder was über ZFS zu reden.
Ja, es war auch, glaube ich, es gab ein Release von Apple, also ein Source-Code-Release
von Apple von ZFS in einer Variante, die nicht wirklich funktioniert hat.
Also wenn ich die Shownotes richtig verfolge, dann war es sogar mal in einer macOS-Beta drin.
Ja, ja, genau.
Snow Leopard oder irgendwie sowas?
Kann sein.
Und...
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich.
Also damals haben wir jeden iPhone. Wir haben über iPhone OS...
2, 2, 1 haben wir geredet und zwar über mehrere Sendungen lang und sowas.
Damals gab es noch nichts, das war echt in der Vorzeit.
Ja und über Nokia.
Und sollen wir jetzt hier auf dieser Tierlist sozusagen das gleich auf ein Thema machen?
Genau, ZFS haben wir da ja in der Tat schon liegen.
Okay und was ist jetzt die Bewertungsskala?
Genau, darüber müssen wir uns natürlich mindestens zwei Stunden diskutieren.
Also ich hätte da jetzt zwei Ansätze.
Da können wir jetzt gucken, welcher ist sinnvoller. Also der eine Ansatz wäre
so, das Thema an sich, hat das eigentlich noch eine Relevanz,
hat sich das gut entwickelt, ist das im Nachhinein ein Total-Fail,
das wäre aber quasi unabhängig von der Freak-Show.
Die.
Andere Alternative ist….
Was hat es für die Sendung jemals getan?
Was hat es für die Sendung jemals getan? Ganz genau.
Und wir wissen aus vorangegangenen Sendungen, es ist unklug, beides zu vermischen.
Das heißt, wir müssten uns für eine der beiden Interpretationen vermutlich entscheiden.
Aber du bist ja hier jetzt quasi der Bestimmer.
Ich bin jetzt der Bestimmer. Ich mache heute gar nichts.
Was die Frage angeht, würde ich mal sagen, da kannst du jetzt,
was dein Bauchgefühl dir sagt, was mehr...
mehr Charme entwickelt.
Welchen Link hast du denn jetzt eigentlich da geteilt?
Ja, den habe ich schon zurückgezogen und schon den neuen gesetzt.
Das war nämlich der Edit-Link.
Ah, wie praktisch.
Jetzt haben wir den.
Das heißt, alle fangen jetzt gerade an, Themen hinzuzufügen?
Ich hoffe nicht und wenn es probiert.
Ich kann ja heute auch mal kurz was reinwerfen, was mich vorhin sehr,
sehr, sehr, wo ich hart gefühlt habe.
Und zwar in Mobile Max 12 hat Tim von seinem, das erste iPhone hast du ja nicht
gehabt, sondern bist ja dann beim 3G erst eingestiegen. Und dann hast du dir eins geholt.
Und es steht hier in den Shownotes drin, Tim berichtet von seinen iPhone-3G-Erfahrungen.
Und dann einer der Punkte ist, die Autoritation macht Filme gucken im Bett unmöglich.
Und das habe ich bis heute jeden Tag, wenn ich im Bett liege und dann die Autoritation
an ist und dann bleibt dieses Scheißbild einfach nicht so, wie es sein soll
im Querformat, sondern dreht sich immer um. Und ja.
Du musst es auf die andere Seite kippen, dann bleibt es.
Ich finde ja bis heute, Apple könnte da ruhig irgendwann mal einen Button einbauen
und gut ist. Oder so dieses...
Es gab ja mal den Schalter.
Ihre KI nutzen. Einen Schalter? Welchen Schalter?
Den gab es am iPad.
Glaube ich.
Am iPad. Am iPad kann man es ja in jeder Richtung nach wie vor einrasten.
Da kann man es im Querformat, im Hochformat...
Aber wenn du es auf den Kopf machst, dann dreht es sich ja nicht mit.
Ich finde, Apple könnte da irgendwo einen Button für einbauen.
oder irgendein KI-Prozessor, der dann ausrechnet, hey, dieses Bild ist breiter als hoch.
Da kannst du mal sehen, ich hab da schon ein Gefühl für die Punkte,
die wirklich schmerzen.
Ich fühle das hart, bis heute jeden, also außer die YouTube-App,
die macht einfach mal Querformat.
Ja, also ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, wie man das jetzt beurteilen soll.
Also man kann natürlich schon sagen, Themen, was hat das Thema für die Sendung
bedeutet, weil das jetzt unabhängig von der Sendung zu bewerten,
ist natürlich Unsinn, also unabhängig von der Show.
Das wäre tendenziell auch mein Ansatz.
Allerdings finde ich das noch ein bisschen zu wenig Themen.
Die kommen schon noch, da macht der Mann nicht so viele Sorgen. Das wird noch.
Und eine weitere Sache, die mir aufgefallen ist in Mobile Max 40,
die den schönen Namen Das Tablett trägt.
Und da gibt es dann ein Kapitel mit dem Namen Das Tablett. Und das fängt an
ungefähr mit der, du leitest das ein, Tim, mit so, ja, es ist noch nichts bekannt,
es ist noch nicht mal ein Termin angekündigt. Worüber sollen wir denn reden?
40 Minuten das Kapitel,
Ach ja, die Predictions und so.
Damals hast du glaube ich noch Erinnere ich mich richtig, dass du gesagt hast
Gehofft hast, nicht gesagt hast Dass das iPad ein Loch hat, damit man es wie so eine Ja.
Wie so eine Palette halten kann Wie so eine Palette halten kann Das war echt Unsinn Weiß nicht.
So, es werden aus dem Chat schon Themenvorschläge reingeworfen.
Kalender und Outliner aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen.
PimpMyMac ist auch gut.
OmniOutliner.
Ja, PimpMyMac ist in der Tat auch gut. Da suchen wir uns auch schon mal einen für.
Gut.
Gibt sogar ein Logo für. Interessant. Ist, glaube ich, aber nicht von uns.
Buchhaltung.
Buchhaltung. Oh Gott.
Apropos Buchhaltung, ich habe den Stollen von meiner Firmenkreditkarte bezahlt,
damit ich jetzt als Werbungskosten absetzen kann.
Darum muss ich jetzt auch nochmal sagen, mich kann man buchen, 343max.de.
Mein Buchhalter wäre stolz auf mich.
Ich gebe erstmal ein paar Tellerchen aus, damit wir auch den Stollen genießen können.
Essen während dem Podcast.
Ja, genau, das ist auch ein Thema für sich. Ich habe genau vier Teller,
guck, reicht ja gerade so.
Messer kommt gleich. So, wer macht denn jetzt hier den Moderator?
Muss ich das jetzt wieder machen? Ralf, was ist los?
Du hast gesagt, du übernimmst das alles. Du musst auch hier den Flow moderieren.
Weniger assistieren, mehr moderieren.
Ja, sonst sind hier so tote Bereiche auf einmal.
Moment, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall.
Ja, ich will das auf gar keinen Fall.
So sieht das aus.
Okay.
Also.
Max hat ja gerade jetzt eben schon zwei, drei Themen reingeworfen hier.
Da könnten wir durchaus schon mal schauen, okay, wo würde man die jetzt hier platzieren? So.
Hier listen wir jetzt nur in diesem Kapitel oder die ganze Sendung über?
Das wird sich so ein bisschen zeigen.
Okay. Ich sehe schon, es wird schwierig mit den Kapitelmarken.
Möglich. Vielleicht wird es aber auch ganz einfach am Ende.
Vielleicht wird es die erste Kapitelmarkenfreie Sendung.
Nichts Genaues weiß man nicht.
Ich habe ja überlegt, ob ich Glühwein mitbringe, aber dann befürchte,
das könnte ein bisschen ausarten. Aber vielleicht ein bisschen Glühwein?
Soll ich vielleicht den Mount-Gog-Song nochmal einspielen, weil wir es sozusagen
schon angekündigt haben?
Wenn du den parat hast, dann schmeiß mal rein.
Das ist so eine Lafondkasse und irgendwie immer vorbereitet.
Hervorragend.
Selbst wenn man mir sagt, ich soll mich nicht vorbereiten.
Grüße gehen raus an David, 1701.
Der großartige David, der immer so großartige Songs aus dieser Sendung gemacht hat.
Ja, den habe ich versucht zu kontaktieren. Für diese Sendung.
Ist dir aber nicht gelungen?
Ich habe ihn über drei oder vier Kanäle angeschrieben, aber no response.
Keine Ahnung, ob er jetzt irgendwie ein anderes Leben führt.
Nee, also ja, aber.
Mit dieser Welt hier abgeschlossen hat.
Ja, das vielleicht, aber es wäre vielleicht möglich.
Er hat ja zum Samsung-Telefon.
Er ist losgekommen von dem Zeug.
In der Tat war der Gedanke, ob er bereit wäre, nochmal so ein Previous-D so
über 18 Jahre irgendwie zusammenzuschneiden.
Was sicherlich auch ein mittelgroßer Stress geworden wäre. Aber ja,
Ja, hat nicht sollen sein.
Und dann war das dann halt so.
Also, ich habe nochmal was gebaut für diese Sendung.
Das könnten wir jetzt vielleicht jetzt mal auf die Orgel werfen.
Und zwar, damit wir auch faktenbasiert, hier.
Genau. Kann ja mal gucken.
Ob du wirklich so gut vorbereitet bist. Hast du Bumzack-Return noch?
Er hat gesagt, ich soll nichts vorbereiten. Wir machen das schon alles. Kein Problem.
Wir haben das total drauf. Wir sind Profi-Podcast, haben wir es lange genug bei dir gelernt.
Nee, warte mal, da ist er nicht. So, da muss er sein. Achtung und herzlich willkommen bei.
Bum zack return.
Bum zack, bum zack.
Moment. So.
Das ist auch live aus dem Intro von der Sendung. Dieses Wir labern einfach über
irgendwelche Trailer drüber weg. Das hat es also offensichtlich wirklich auch immer gegeben.
Ja, klar. Natürlich gehört ja auch wieder zu. Es ist ja auch bei Learning by Doing.
Und es ist auch immer heiß.
Es wurde immer heiß gegessen, was hier gekocht wurde. Sagen wir es mal so.
Also man hat ja die Technik auch versucht zu zähmen, während sie vor allem so
zappelte und manchmal klappt es gut und manchmal nicht. Hat ja aber auch echte Höhen erreicht.
So, also jetzt habe ich hier auch meine URL am Start.
Ich werfe die mal in den Slack rein.
Dann ruft die doch mal auf, Tim.
Ja.
Erzählen Sie.
Das ist Radiokontent.
Du musst das jetzt akustisch ankündigen. Die Leute sehen das nicht.
Was ihr jetzt alle sehen könntet.
Was ihr jetzt alle nicht seht.
Ja.
Also, ich habe mich mal hingesetzt und habe ein kleines Datendashboard für die Freakshow 300 gebaut.
Wo sich mal so verschiedene Aspekte der Sendung so ein bisschen abbilden und
man sehen kann, wie sich das so über die vielen Jahre hinweg entwickelt hat.
So, das startet erstmal mit so vier Kacheln, 299 Episoden, das ist jetzt wenig überraschend.
67 Genie-Quisitors, das ist also 67 verschiedene Teilnehmende,
die irgendwann mal als Gästinnen oder Hosts oder so am Start waren.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal recht viel.
67, wow.
1578 Themen.
Wie hast du denn das generiert?
Ja.
Wie sind denn Themen, der fährt?
Also jetzt unique oder wiederholend?
Ne, die sind wiederholend. Unique sind es 1200. Damit bin ich aber noch nicht so ganz glücklich.
Wer hat denn das jetzt ausgedrückt? Da hast du doch bestimmt so eine dreckige
AI über die Transakte laufen lassen.
Ja, naja, es ist dann schon ein Python-Script, was das zusammen modelliert hat.
Aber das Python-Skript ist von einer dreckigen AI beauftragt worden, das zu tun.
Aber es war in der Tat gar nicht so einfach, sich darauf festzulegen,
okay, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich ein Thema, was in der Sendung besprochen
wird, weil da bietet unser Podcast halt so verschiedene Ebenen an.
So, wir haben auf der einen Seite die Kapitelmarken, die du aber im Laufe der
Jahre sehr unterschiedlich interpretiert hast.
Es gibt Sendungen mit sage und schreibe 40 Kapiteln,
Weil so jedes Thema nochmal in fünf Unterstrukturen irgendwie runtergebrochen ist.
Das war noch die Zeit, wo die Community die Kapitel gemacht hat.
Ah, okay.
Die Shownotes.
Die Shownoter und so. Okay. So, dann gab es halt etliche, so die ersten 50 Sendungen
haben überhaupt keine Kapitelmarken.
Ja, das wollte ich schon immer nochmal nachholen, aber ich bin noch nicht zugekommen.
Genau, und dann hat sich das so ein bisschen konsolidiert, aber auch in den
Kapitelmarken ist natürlich dann so viel Beifang drin.
Die Shownotes an sich sind natürlich viel zu fuzzy, weil da halt auch dann einfach
wirklich sehr viel irgendwie an Einzellinks und so weiter drin ist.
Das heißt, das, was ich dann hier genommen habe als Entität,
sind diese Kurzbeschreibungstexte zu den Episoden, wo du ab ungefähr 100 relativ
konsistent Schlagworte quasi reingegeben hast in die Sendung.
die werden hier ausgewertet. Und darum kommt man auf die auch relativ geringe
Quote. Das steht dann hier jetzt in der vierten Kachel drin.
5,3 Themen pro Episode. Das wird zum einen runtergezogen durch die ersten ungefähr
100 Sendungen, wo die eben nicht ausgefüllt waren.
Und zum anderen, weil du da halt dann doch sehr stark reduziert hast.
Und der nächste Chart, den ich dann gebaut habe, ist, so wer waren denn eigentlich
die verschiedenen Crews hier in der Sendung?
Das heißt also, wann sind eigentlich welche PodcasterInnen dazugestoßen und
wann haben welche wieder die Sendung verlassen und wie hat sich hier so das
Personaltableau der Sendung?
diese Sendung eigentlich entwickelt. Und da sehen wir hier 2008,
darüber haben wir gerade eben schon gesprochen.
Tim, alle 19 Sendungen dabei. Dennis auch alle 19 dabei.
Max hatte eine Sendung verpasst in dem Jahr. Da war, war er dann mal nur zu zweit.
Kommt also auf 18 Sendungen.
Einmal war Tim auch alleine.
Ja, ja. Da ist keiner gekommen. Und ich saß hier alleine. Und hab die Sendung alleine gemacht.
Und einmal war Tim auch nicht da. Und dann haben wir ohne Tim die Sendung gemacht.
Ich war doch remote dabei.
Warst du remote dabei?
Ich war remote dabei über so ein wackeliges Skype aus dem Urlaubsort.
Also ich war nie nicht da, aber ich war an der Stelle mal nur so wackelig dabei.
Du warst mal in Kanada.
Das auch noch.
Triple Ender hieß die Folge.
Ja, da haben wir irgendwie, oh Gott, das war noch Zeit. Mit Wackel Skype haben
wir das Ganze aus der Ferne gemacht.
Und das war in meiner Erinnerung alles eine extrem eklige Angelegenheit,
was so das Synken der Spuren betrifft.
Du hattest irgendwie erzählt, dass du, du warst sehr verzweifelt,
weil wir hatten extra jeweils unser eigenes Ende aufgenommen,
darum Triple-Ender, weil es halt drei Enden sind.
Und dann alle gleichzeitig geklatscht, damit wir einen Sync haben theoretisch.
Es lief aber dann trotzdem irgendwie alles auseinander.
einander die ganze Zeit und man musste das irgendwie verhackstückeln.
Es war alles ein bisschen schwierig, aber ihr seht schon, also auch unter den
widrigsten Umständen wurde diese Sendung immer wieder zusammengeklöppelt.
Aufs Tableau gepackt.
Ja, und damals auch noch zwei wöchentlich.
Genau, da habe ich auch irgendwo einen Chart gehabt, mit wie viele Sendungen
pro Monat, aber der war irgendwie nicht so ergiebig, den habe ich dann nicht mehr weiter verfolgt.
Aber was wir hier sehen ist, dass zu dem jetzt hier Blau für Tim und Orange
für Dennis und Lila für Max kam dann 2009 der nächste hinzu und das war wer?
Der Ückel.
Der Huckel, genau. und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, Tim, hat es schon wieder an der Tür geklingelt.
Ich habe nur vier Mikrofone.
Ich weiß, das ist der große Unsicherheitsfaktor heute.
Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen. Oh Mann, ey.
Hast du doch einen Teller?
So, jetzt könntest du mal das Gerät rausholen.
Rudi.
Oh Gott, was kommt denn jetzt?
So, du kennst mich, ich habe ein bisschen dieses Problem natürlich vorausgeahnt.
Ich habe überlegt, ob wir irgendwie
mit dem USB, also für die Nicht-Technikerinnen an den Hörgeräten,
Tim hat ja sein Studio-Setup hier deutlich vereinfacht und hat jetzt das Rodecaster
2 Pro, das aber eben nur vier Mikrofoneingänge hat.
Und das hat noch so irgendwie mit Mini-Klinke und USB und sowas.
Mein Gedanke war, dass wir jetzt, ach, die hat es auch nicht mehr.
Das hat nur der Kleine, komischerweise.
Ja, lustig, lustig. Mein Gedanke war, guck mal hier, der Roddy hat ein gutes,
altes, dynamisches Shure SM58 mitgenommen, was sich zwei Leute teilen können.
Da wir ja alle im selben Raum sitzen, braucht ja die fünfte Person nicht zwingend
einen Kopfhörer. Die hört uns ja auch so.
Ja, aber ich brauche ja trotzdem Mikrofoneingaben.
Genau, das heißt, wir schlachten jetzt eins der Headsets und ersetzen es durch ein Handmikro.
Ist nicht cool, aber nun ja.
Es sei denn, du hast eine bessere Idee.
Ich damit huckel da immer um das Mikro prügeln. Willst du mal Hallo sagen übrigens?
Lass mich mal kurz,
verzweifeln.
Du musst nichts organisieren, Tim. Alles ist gemacht.
Ihr könnt mal eine andere Gesprächsthemenkarte aufmachen und ich überlege gerade
mal was. Ich habe vielleicht einen Ansatz. Mal gucken.
Hier, Huckel, nimm mal meinen und ich bastel mal was.
Hallihallo. So hört der Tim sich also. Aha.
Na, wie ist es? Lang nicht mehr gesehen, Roddy und Max.
Guten Tag.
Ich hole mal schnell ein Bierchen.
Das war jetzt mal auf dem Kongress, glaube ich, oder? Irgendwann.
Stimmt, die Sendung, wo du da warst, war ich nicht da.
Ja, korrekt.
War ich in China oder so.
Ich verkrache mich hier eh immer mit Tim und dann darf ich in zwei Jahren nicht kommen.
Was war denn das letzte Verkrachthema? Weißt du es noch?
Apple AI.
Ah, und wie waren die Positionen? Das ist ja ein durchaus aktuell auch noch kontroverses Thema.
Also ich würde sagen...
Max hat recht gehabt.
Keiner von uns wollte das wahrhaben, aber Max hatte recht.
Die Hörer, die sind auch alle da, hallo liebe Hörerinnen.
Genau, die Stimme der Jugend ist wieder eingekehrt.
Ja, nee, ich bin ja, so mit diesem Apple-AI-Thema bin ich auch,
dachte ich mir von Anfang an irgendwie, Apple, das wird irgendwie nix.
und generell mit diesem ganzen LLM-Kram. Da gibt es halt so ein paar Sachen,
die toll sind, aber auch viele Sachen, die nicht toll sind.
Und ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, ob Apple das jetzt einfach so rauspietern lässt
irgendwie und immer weniger auf den Keynotes davon erzählt.
Und dann ist das nur noch so ein...
Naja, was sind Sie davor? Was ich gehört habe, ist, dass sie relativ viel Geld
hingelegt haben, um Aktien zurückzukaufen,
aber nicht wirklich Geld übrig hatten, um jetzt irgendwie Hardware für AI an den Start zu kriegen.
Insofern sieht es nicht danach aus, als würde das in nächster Zeit irgendwie besser werden.
Aber gab es jetzt nicht Gerüchte, dass sie von Google jetzt irgendwie eine eigene
AI sich lizenzieren und die bauen lassen von Google und dann wird die auf Apple-Servern
betrieben? Oder ich weiß nicht genau, wie das war.
Also sie waren lange mit Open AI in Verhandlungen.
Ja.
Und bis vor einem Vierteljahr oder sowas. Und dann habe ich auch gelesen,
sind sie zu Google umgeschwenkt und wollen jetzt mit Gemini...
Kriegen jetzt ein eigenes Gemini.
Wobei man sagen muss, das Gemini 3 ist ja schon auch wirklich ziemlich beeindruckend.
Also das ist... Da hat auch Google echt irgendwie aufgeholt.
Kann Siri damit dann auch Lichter zuverlässig einschalten?
Ja, irgendwie, ich hatte mir ja echt erhofft, ich muss sagen,
auf all meinen Geräten habe ich Apple Intelligence nicht eingeschaltet.
Schon von Anfang an. Ich habe es nicht mal ausprobiert, weil ich mir dachte,
ich will das irgendwie gar nicht. Ich bin mit ChatGPT und Co.
eigentlich auch ganz gut bedient bei Bedarf und irgendwie im Betriebssystem
will ich das einfach nicht haben.
Hat das jemand von euch...
aktiviert und benutzt das regelmäßig, Apple Intelligence.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur Siri mit einem anderen, mit einem,
Mit einer anderen UI, oder?
Also ich kann es nicht aktivieren. Ich habe ein ganz normales EU-iPhone,
nicht auf OS-Tore und sowas gestellt.
Doch, doch, doch, das geht.
Aber auf meinem 14 Pro geht es nicht. Also dann fehlt da wieder Scheicher oder weiß der Geier was.
Ich glaube ab dem 15 Pro. Also ich habe ein 15 Pro, bei mir geht es theoretisch.
Erkennt man daran, dass es diesen wunderbaren, regenbogenfarbigen,
der überhaupt keinen Sinn macht. Der überhaupt keinen Sinn macht.
Die Idee dahinter war ja, dass
es immer kontextbezogen ist und dass dann quasi die AI sich drüberlegt.
Und dann haben sie das gleiche UI da einfach genommen. Ja, okay,
schmeißen wir halt auf die Siri drauf. Jetzt haben wir schon so viel Werbung damit rausgehauen.
Aber hey, Regenbogen.
Okay, also ich sehe gerade, ich habe es eingeschaltet.
Bin aber ein bisschen verwirrt darüber, dass oben in dem Siri-Logo,
in dem Apple-Intelligence-Logo noch ein großes Beta drin steht.
Naja, das wäre gelogen, wenn sie es wegnehmen würden, oder?
Keine Ahnung, was kommt nach Beta? Gamma?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall immer, wenn dieser Dialog kam, das war jetzt vor allen
Dingen bei Betriebssysteminstallationen, den dann schon wie einst mit Siri immer
mit Nein und Überspringen beantwortet.
Also ich glaube, der Siri-Teil, ich kann keine Live-Verbesserung.
Wirklich?
Also nichts. Ich glaube, es ist es einfach nicht. Ich glaube,
sie haben da einfach nichts gemacht. Sie haben wirklich nur Siri ein anderes UI gegeben, literally.
Weil ich würde ja, das, was ich diesen ganzen LLM- und AI-Bubble-Wahnsinn ja
als bleibendes positives Merkmal zuschreiben würde, ist ja das Natural Language Interface.
Dass man einfach so jetzt, so damals wie in Star Trek einfach sagen kann,
hey Computer und du kannst in deinem normalen Sprachfluss, du musst nicht wie
in Diktiersoftware früher, ich möchte jetzt diktieren. Hallo, guten Tag und so weiter.
Sondern man kann einfach drauf loslabern, man kann mittendrin die Sprache wechseln.
Man kann sagen, kannst du mir das mal schnell in Serbisch übersetzen?
Ich hatte letztens einen serbischen Freund da und habe dann mal mit dem gecheckt, wie gut das so...
In seinem Street-Serbisch sozusagen übersetzt und es funktioniert halt.
Und dieser Teil, ich glaube, der wird auch nicht weggehen und der kann auch gerne bleiben.
Und deswegen hatte ich mir gerade da gedacht, da können jetzt Apple mit Siri
richtig punkten, weil das war ja schon seit es Siri gibt immer das größte,
der größte Upturn irgendwie, dass das Ding einfach einen nicht verstanden hat.
Und wirklich bei den simpelsten Sachen, ich kriege ja nicht so oft Puls,
wie andere Teilnehmer an diesem Podcast, aber wenn was nicht geht.
Aber bei Siri, muss ich sagen, da ist mir teilweise auch wirklich schon die
Hutschnur hochgerutscht. Ich dachte, hallo, was ist denn hier los?
Das geht doch nicht irgendwie. Schade, wenn du das ausprobiert hast oder ihr
und sagt, das hat sich nicht verbessert, dann...
Ja, ich glaube, es sind immer noch so, wenn man so Sachen sagt wie stellen den
Wecker auf 15,30. Ich kann keinen Wecker für die Vergangenheit stellen.
Das klappt bei mir ziemlich gut. Also, ich habe schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
so dieser Hass auf Siri steigt nochmal exponentiell, wenn du Kinder hast und
irgendwo in der Küche mit so,
Airplay-Geschichten darauf angewiesen bist und das Kind dann sagt so,
spiel eine Folge der drei Fragezeichen Kids.
Und dann kommt nun wirklich alles, aber halt nicht die drei Fragezeichen Kids. Ich,
Das mal auf die Formel gebracht, so meine Kinder haben dank Siri jedes Grundvertrauen
in Technologie verloren.
Was der eins vielleicht nochmal hilfreich ist, wenn die Zombie-Apokalypse kommt.
Aber die gehen einfach davon aus, dass Technologie nicht funktioniert und strunzendumm
ist, weil Siri halt so ihre Hauptfläche darüber war, wenn es darum geht,
so ich will jetzt einfach nur ein Hörspiel hören, warum darf ich das hier nicht?
Aber ich glaube, ein Teil davon ist auch einfach Music. Apple Music und Suche,
das sind auch zwei Welten, die nicht zusammenkommen.
Ja, mit Deutsch und auf Englisch. Und um sowas kümmert sich bei Apple auch einfach traditionell niemand.
Dass also in Deutschland die Leute trotzdem englische Musik hören wollen und
dann nicht alles irgendwie verdeutscht wird.
Ja, Apple Music und Music insgesamt, das ist auch ein Thema voller Tränen irgendwie gefühlt.
Ich hatte ja immer die Hoffnung, dass Apple Music doch irgendwann nochmal gut wird.
Ich benutze es ja nach wie vor wegen dem Match-Feature, weil man dann eben,
Aufnahmen aus dem Proberaum irgendwie in seine Library zieht und die dann auch
auf dem Telefon streamen kann und so weiter und das halt immer quasi gesynkt wird.
Aber die können so Sachen nicht wie, wenn deine Musik unterschiedliche Bitraten
oder Auflösung hat, also hier Hertz und so weiter, ne, Kilohertz.
Wie heißt das doch nochmal? Frequenzen?
Doch, Frequenz.
Abtastfrequenz.
Abtastfrequenz. Dann schafft es Apple Music als fast einziges Programm,
also es gibt einige, oder ein paar andere, die es auch nicht können,
aber du schaffst es nicht, dann dein Audio-Interface entsprechend umzustellen
und upsampelt oder downsampelt halt einfach und macht den ganzen,
das, womit sie geboren haben, wir haben jetzt auch lossless Audio und so weiter
und Hi-Res Audio macht es halt komplett für den Fuß, weil dann das irgendwie
nicht mit deinem Audio-Interface spricht und es umstellt und dann muss ich halt
FUBA 2000 benutzen auf Mac im 21.
Jahrhundert, um Files abzuspielen, damit es dann doch so rauskommt,
wie ich es eigentlich haben wollte.
Und ja, es ist alles dramatisch. Spotify, Trauerspiel.
Ja, das ist der Grund, warum ich jetzt auch bei Apple Music wieder eigentlich
zurück bin, weil mir dieses ganze Spotify Gebaren irgendwie noch deutlich mehr auf den Keks geht.
Aber die Lyrics.
Oha!
Hallo!
Was auch immer es ist.
Ha!
1, 2, 3 seid ihr noch da.
Das ist die Zukunft, von der ihr mal reden.
Da liegt Olli hier und zuckelt.
Ja, ihr habt jetzt gerade eine neue Firmware aufgeflasht. Sorry.
Ja, Pluribus, Folge 1, oder?
Aber es sieht gut aus die Anzahl an Soundinterfaces, die Tim hier auf den Tisch packt.
Wachsen exponentiell Tim ist nicht toll dass du heute nichts machen.
Musst also ich bin jetzt schon so ein bisschen sauer auf dich Ralf weil du hättest
du mir ich hasse jetzt nicht vorbereitet zu sein weder habe ich genug Stühle
noch habe ich genug Eingänge und jetzt werde ich live und der Kaffee ist auch kalt jetzt wird das,
podcasty as possible. Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ihr müsstet mir einfach live
zuhören, weil ich muss jetzt darüber nachdenken und ihr könnt ja mal mitdenken,
ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Also, das Ziel ist, einen fünften Kanal reinzukriegen. Ich habe jetzt einen
zweiten Rodecaster Pro 2 hier noch für mein rollendes Studio sozusagen, mein Backup.
Da hängt jetzt ein Headset dran. Jetzt versuche ich das irgendwie in den Mix
zu bekommen. Ist aber tricky, weil erstens, ich kann das jetzt ja auch nur über USB-C anschließen.
Kann ich da reinstecken? Was ist der erste Gedanke, der mir kommt? Der euch kommt?
Was es für Probleme geben kann?
Also ich bin immer noch ein bisschen entsetzt, dass du keine Thomann-Standleitung hast hier.
Guck mal, die beiden Geräte heißen exakt gleich auf USB.
Dass sie sich ersetzen.
Die wählen sich mit demselben Namen an. Jetzt weiß ich nicht,
wie das Betriebssystem, also das Betriebssystem wird es wahrscheinlich noch klarkriegen.
Ich kann da natürlich schon mal nicht mehr zwischen den beiden unterscheiden.
Ja, es gibt da kein Fallback. Und das heißt, das weiß ich nicht.
Das werde ich jetzt gleich sehen. Ich wollte jetzt euch nur mental darauf vorbereiten,
dass jetzt gleich hier alles...
Es kann jetzt alles passieren. Es kann sein, die Software hört auf aufzunehmen.
Ja, kann sein. Wäre jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Weil... Dann starten wir sie nochmal.
Wir haben hier eh das Backup hier irgendwie laufen. Was ich jetzt versuche ist,
Ich würde jetzt gerne diesen zweites Mischpult anschließen und dann mit Loopback
sozusagen über USB den hier reinzubringen.
Dann hätte ich quasi eine fünfte Stimme in the mix.
Das gesamte Punkt hier.
Das zweite. Das wäre zu dem Zeitpunkt dann auch auf dem Stream und das wäre dann auch im Recording.
Das Problem ist nur, ich muss dann ja auch noch einen N-1 Kopfhörermix machen.
Nee, das muss ja kein N-1 Kopfhörermix sein.
Ich muss es ja auch wieder zurück. Wie früher.
Also ich stecke jetzt das in diesen Computer rein. Jetzt gucken wir erstmal,
was passiert. Habt ihr irgendwelche Tipps, was passiert?
Tim steht da und wedelt.
Hörer leise machen.
No fun.
So, ich bin noch da.
Also es sieht aus, als ob die Software weiterhin aufnimmt. So.
So, several people are typing.
Ah, und tatsächlich, tatsächlich sind jetzt hier auf dem Mac die Dinger mit
1 und 2 durchnummeriert.
Das ist, okay, Huckel nickt kurz, das ist gut.
Tim's Apple Watch fragt, ob sie einen Notarzt rufen sollen.
Keine Witze, ja, Witze erst am Schluss.
Also, was können wir jetzt machen? Wir können jetzt dafür sorgen,
dass wir diese Source haben.
Das heißt, wir nehmen den Multitrack, den zweiten...
So, jetzt gucken wir mal. Da haben wir jetzt hier auf Kanal 3 haben wir das Ding. Genau.
Und jetzt wollen wir hier einen Monitor haben.
Und dann nehmen wir mal hier den Chat von 1. Das ist der, der eben gerade so
schön Sound gemacht hat.
Weil da die falschen Kanäle draufgegangen sind.
Die sollen da natürlich jetzt nicht hin. Wie lösche ich die jetzt?
Wie löscht man die denn hier?
Doch mal dem Huckel ein Headset, wenn er was zu erzählen hat.
So, hier liegt ein Headset.
Kann man ihn jetzt hören?
Oder tellern, stollen, dann erzählt er nicht.
Wie kann man denn das jetzt hier...
Ich höre ihn noch nicht. Wir können ihn noch nicht hören.
Nein, eins von den anderen Headset.
Das funktioniert jetzt noch nicht.
Also in Lupec irgendwie mit Command-Delete oder so macht man da die Blobs weg,
glaube ich. Oder einfach nur Delete.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon probiert, aber ich kriege die gar nicht selektiert hier irgendwie.
Control-Klick-Zack. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich die überhaupt anlingsen soll.
Wie nehme ich denn? Was machen wir eigentlich hier mit dem fünften Stuhl, den ich nicht habe?
Also mir wurde irgendwas von der Couch erzählt.
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt auch gleich drauf. Aber ich versuche jetzt hier gerade...
Ja, jetzt hört man, weil er jetzt eine Herzeit auf hat.
Weißt du, wie man diese Dinger hier wegkriegt? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ah, die Verbindung.
Ja.
Ich will das anders bauten.
Eigentlich will ich ja nur dich hier... den will ich hier sozusagen da drauf haben.
Ich habe es leider vergessen, ich habe Loopback schon zu lange nicht mehr benutzt,
weil ich jetzt alles in meinem RME-Interface mache und keine...
Wofür braucht man denn Loopback? Was ist das denn überhaupt?
Loopback ist eine Software von Rogue Amoeba, das ist diese Mac-Boote,
die so viel Audio-Kram macht, auch so Sound Source und wie sie alle heißen.
Und Loopback, damit kannst du quasi so virtuelle Devices und virtuelles Routing
machen durch diese ganzen virtuellen Devices.
Und jetzt versuche ich sozusagen das eine Mischpult in das andere reinzuführen
und von dort aber auch wieder einen Mix in das andere rein.
Also ich will sie sozusagen überkreuz verheiraten, aber derzeit kriege ich noch
nicht mal raus, wie ich jetzt hier die Kanäle überhaupt angeschlossen bekomme.
Also ich weiß, wie es die verbinden kann, aber ich weiß nicht,
wie ich die Verbindung wieder lösen kann.
Ja, ich glaube irgendwie, es gab sowas wie Control-Klick oder Alt-Klick oder
irgend sowas, aber wie gesagt, leider habe ich es schon zu lange nicht mehr in den Fingern gehabt.
Alt-Klick.
Auf jeden Fall ist Loopback an sich so eine Software, wo ich schon seit mehreren
macOS-Releases darauf warte, dass Apple irgendwann mal das Audio-Subsystem aufbaut
und das einfach built-in ist, weil die Computer können das schon sehr lange.
Die Hoffnung habe ich schon lange aufgegeben.
Lass mich raten, seit zehn Major-Releases oder sind es eher elf Major-Releases?
Es gibt eine Freak-Show-Sendung, wo wir so nach Feature wünschen,
was denn jetzt noch kommen soll.
Und da habe ich Audio-Subsystem auf jeden Fall erwähnt.
Aber es gibt ja diese Open-Source-Sachen, so Soundflower und Jack-Audio und hast du nicht gesehen.
Und das ist halt so das Einzige, was ohne Warn-Dialoge und sonst was irgendwie
daherkommt. und in der Regel, wenn man es dann einmal geschafft hat,
richtig zu konfigurieren, auch tut.
Aber in solchen Szenarien hatte ich auch schon meine Probleme,
ad hoc das geregelt zu bekommen.
Ich hatte noch überlegt, also man kann ja auch noch per Bluetooth sich da in
das Mischpult reinhängen.
Ich könnte jetzt den Rodecaster 2.2 an mein Notebook stecken mit dem Headset
und dann per Bluetooth...
Ja, ne, weiß ich nicht, ob das geht.
Warte mal, das ist eine Idee, das über einen anderen Rechner zu machen.
Was ist, wenn ich den jetzt an den Rechner mache und dann...
Dann kannst du dich per Bluetooth mit deinem Hauptmischpult verbinden und müsstest
dann eigentlich auch was reinschicken können. Aber ob das dann mit dem N-1...
Das ist nicht bidirektional. Ich habe halt Bluetooth nicht als Ausgabe,
sondern nur als Eingabe, oder?
Ich glaube, die Sendung darf erst aufhören, wenn die Verbindung zusammenbricht.
Ich möchte nochmal darauf hinweisen.
Dass wir ja alle in einem Raum sind.
Könnt ihr bitte, wenn ihr jetzt, jetzt müsst ihr mal folgende Regel beachten,
weil sonst wird es schwierig.
Wenn du jetzt in einem, also wenn ihr, wenn in das Mikrofon,
was benutzt wird, jetzt eine andere Person spricht.
Dann immer den Namen vorneweg sagen.
Nein, dann musst du die Menü-Taste drücken.
Okay. Warum das? Warum?
Weil ich dann einen blauen Marker reinbekomme. Weil wenn ich diese Sendung nicht
mit korrekten Transkripten veröffentlichen kann, wäre ich wahnsinnig.
Aber das macht doch die AI für dich.
Ja, ja, die AI. Scheiß macht die AI für mich.
Ralf hat gesagt, das wird jetzt hier alles überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Jetzt muss ich hier wirklich durch den Audio-Soup warten.
Da ist die Menütaste, auf deinem Teil. Da, nimm sie in die Hand.
da. Immer wenn Sprecherwechsel ist.
Aber wäre es, also ich meine für jetzt erstmal so mit dem Handmikrofon vielleicht nicht doch.
Also Das ändert nichts.
Oder wir finden Themen.
Das Handmikrofon verbessert jetzt gar nicht, das macht es noch schwieriger.
Ich habe ja schon ein Mikrofon, ich muss es nur routen.
Und dazu muss ich jetzt rauskriegen, wie das Ding ist. Click in the editor to highlight it.
Sag mal, wie viele von diesen Soundinterfaces hast du eigentlich noch hier rumliegen?
Jetzt keins mehr.
Ah, okay. Na gut, dann wird es noch ein Problem, glaube ich.
Ah, ich habe es gefunden, wie man es selektiert, aber noch nicht, wie man es löscht.
Ich hätte ansonsten einen kleinen Einspieler, den wir vielleicht hier bringen könnten.
Wobei es, glaube ich, hilfreich wäre, wenn Hook Hill dann auch ein Headset aufhat.
Ja, das hättest du mal vorher sagen sollen.
Dann hätte ich das auch vorbereiten können. Tim, du...
Ja, ja, jetzt red ich mal raus. Ich habe dich gefragt. Das ist ein Scheiß, ey.
To remove a channel per Click on the...
Also Claude behauptet, Direct removal. Select a virtual device that contains
a connection in the source area.
Click on the source you want to disconnect. Press delete or backspace key.
Ja, das steht hier auch in der Help, aber es funktioniert nicht.
Or click the minus button and remove it. Ah, Cable. Route Removal.
Look at the monitor section on the right side of the device.
Gibt es da eine right side of the device?
Das Problem ist, dass dieses Programm sich schon mal ganz anders verhält, als es sagt.
Jetzt habe ich aber zumindest schon mal das mischpult, warte mal.
Äh...
Also ich beschreibe da jetzt mal, was man sieht. Wir sehen jetzt hier, Tim steht.
Ich höre was.
Ah, jetzt hört man was. Jetzt hört man wieder auf dem linken Kanal.
Ja, jetzt muss ich noch denselben Kanal noch auf den anderen machen.
Du kannst es mal aufsetzen.
Ja, ich sitze.
Man hat ein bisschen Latenz, aber man hört es.
So, okay.
Ohren sind vielleicht nicht hoch aufgelöst genug, um diese Latenz wahrzunehmen.
Wieso ruckelt das?
Wie? Was? Wie?
Ich glaube, diese Software spielt das Signal nicht so durch,
wie wir das gerne hätten. Sprich mal.
Ich spreche sehr gerne. Sehr gerne. Ich kann das sagen.
Dass hier ein Kompressor oder sowas zu hart eingestellt ist auf dem Display
oder der Gain nicht hoch genug, dass er da an einem Noise-Gate hängen bleibt.
Das sieht doch eigentlich gut aus. Test eins, zwei, drei.
Das pumpt so komisch, ne?
Und es ist ein Kampffilter-Effekt drauf, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Das läuft in zwei Routen irgendwie.
Wir haben kein Mikro, dass man einfach in die Mitte des Raumes stellt.
Ja, Hallihallo.
Es kommt und geht, ne?
Es kommt und geht.
Ein Kommen und Gehen.
Also für mich hört es sich sehr wunderbar an. Ich weiß nicht,
wie es bei euch in den Ohren ist.
Ein bisschen intens, aber ansonsten ist es okay, außer dass es kommen und geht.
Na, du hörst dich halt selber lokal, aber es ist halt ein Kommen und Gehen und
ich vermute mal, das ist diese Scheißsoftware, die jetzt hier irgendwie.
Mit dem Loop ist leider nicht freien.
Wollen wir nicht einfach hier
alles anzünden und sonst Lagerfeuer setzen und über alte Zeiten reden?
Also ja, für mich nutze nehme ich
dann einfach meinen, baue ich meinen RME-Interface aus und nehme das mit.
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß-Effekt?
Dumm, dumm, dumm, dumm.
Jetzt müssen wir schon filmen was. Jetzt müssen wir wenigstens hier eine Sendung
machen. Wenn dann Tim sich hier rauszieht.
Ja, ja, ihr müsst jetzt in die Sendung machen.
Können wir nicht irgendein Trinkspiel auf die 300 vorschlagen für die Hörer?
Ich mache mal einen L1-Spieler, der sollte jetzt für alle hier.
Achso, du kannst ja gar nicht reden, weil du ja kein Headset hast.
Aber du hörst uns, oder?
Hör euch so.
Achso, okay.
Also es reicht.
Ja, ich wollte ein Gespräch mit dir beginnen, Aber ich glaube,
das ist für die Hörer wenig hilfreich, wenn man deine Antworten nicht hört.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob man deine Antworten hört.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Hörer nicht hören.
Also die Hälfte von der Hörer. Tim, ernsthaft, lass uns doch über das Handmikro machen.
Das ändert nichts an der Situation. Das Handmikrofon muss ich auch erstmal irgendwo anschließen.
Eins der Headsets raus, Handmikro dran, fertig.
Ja, und wir setzen uns nebeneinander hier und kuscheln ein bisschen.
Und Huckel und ich geben das hin und her.
Dann habe ich keine getrennten Kanäle.
Dann haben wir keine getrennten Kanäle.
Ja, das geht, das musst du jetzt ausbaden.
Ich werde jetzt noch einen zweiten Versuch starten.
Und zwar...
Ich höre dich gerade nicht. Du musst ja hier so machen.
Du musst hinter einem Mikrofon sprechen, was irgendwie auch ankommt.
Deins kommt gerade nicht an.
Was war denn deine?
Deins ist gerade nicht erlaubt. Oh, Kinder.
Na gut, dann kann ich.
Gut, habe ich das verdient.
Menütaste, Menütaste.
Menütaste, drück die Menütaste.
So, ja, jetzt bitte.
Was waren denn so deine großen Themen?
Wenn du ein Handmikrofon haben willst, dann kannst du das jetzt so,
guck mal, das ist euer Handmikrofon, das nehmt ihr jetzt mal so in die Hand,
und reicht das hin und her.
So benutzt ihr das jetzt erstmal, bis ich hier eine andere Lösung habe.
Via Podcasting.
Das ist wie so die Influencer, die dann mit so einem kleinen Ansteckmikrofon dastehen.
Weißt du, wie das ist? Das ist wie Leute, die ihr Telefon wie so ein Pizzastück vorm Gesicht halten.
Und den Lautsprecher an.
Meine großen Themen, das habe ich auch überlegt. Ralf meinte auch,
was für Themen und so weiter.
Ich meine, das waren so viele Sendungen, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Es war wie ein Wirbelsturm.
Was wir einfach mal machen können, ist mal in deine allererste Sendung reinhören.
Das erste Mal, dass man Huckels Stimme hört, in der damals auch Mobile Max.
Oder vielleicht auch gar nicht so viel hört.
Setz mal den Kopfhörer auf, damit du es auf jeden Fall selber gut hörst.
Okay.
Das war's schon.
Aber ja, die Previouslys, an die erneut ich mich auch mit großer Freude.
Da waren doch teilweise ganz Coole dabei.
Man muss dazu sagen, ihr hört das, der Arme darf noch nicht mal sein Hallo sagen,
ohne dass ihm sofort irgendwie über die Sprache rübergezogen wird.
Und ich hab dann die nächsten fünf Minuten halt noch weiter gehört von der Sendung.
Das wird nicht besser.
Er kommt wirklich nicht mehr Heute kriegt.
Er nicht mal mehr ein Mikrofon.
Er kommt wirklich nicht zu Wort, der arme Huckelmann erfährt doch überhaupt
nicht, wer er ist, warum er da jetzt ist Alles ein großes Mysterium,
Ich hab ja noch ein paar Ausschnitte Das wird nicht viel besser im Laufe der
Geschichte Aber irgendwann bist du ja doch zu Wort gekommen Jetzt gebe ich dir
mal das Headset wieder Okay.
Muss ich hören nochmal? Kommt noch ein Clip? Achso. Ja, also Audio ist auf jeden Fall auch nach wie vor,
Ein Thema, nicht nur Betriebssysteme, Audio-Features, Audio-Interfaces.
Hier hat ja vorhin jemand gefragt, ich meine zwar, ich hätte das schon mal gesagt,
aber irgendjemand hat auch gefragt, warum dann Spotify doof ist.
Wer das im Jahre 2025 noch nicht selber rausgefunden hat, da muss ich fragen,
unter welchem Stein wohnt denn diese Person?
Weil an Spotify ist ja eigentlich nichts gut.
Abgesehen davon von schlecht Bezahlung und so ein Artist mit inklusive dieser
Regelung, dass jetzt unter 1000 Plays gar nicht mehr ausgezahlt wird,
was jetzt glaube ich noch erhöht werden soll.
Bis hin zu, wenn man jetzt irgendwelche Playlisten spielen lässt,
dass dann irgendwie die Playlisten weitergeführt werden mit irgendwelchen AI-Artists,
die quasi unter Spotifys Herrschaft sind.
Das heißt, die spielen die Tantiemen, die eventuellen an sich selber aus und
ziehen die Artists weiter über den Tisch. Denn natürlich sind ja diese LLMs
auch von den ganzen Artists gespeist oder diese generativen AIs.
Bis hin zu, dass Spotify einfach nicht einen Katalog hat, der Musikliebhabern entgegenkommt.
Das heißt, die haben manchmal Alben, wo einfach Tracks ersetzt werden durch
irgendwelche Live-Aufnahmen oder Bootlegs.
Oder mein persönlicher Pet-Pief, es gibt von David Bowie zum Beispiel das Lied
Cat People, was als Single als auch als Albumversion existiert.
Die Album-Version wird eigentlich von den Fans eher abgelehnt und die Single-Version ist die goldene.
Aber bei Spotify gibt es zwar die David Bowie Singles Collection,
wo dieser Track drauf sein soll, aber in der Singles Collection haben sie sie
aufgefüllt mit den ganzen Album-Versionen und nicht mit den Singles.
Und das ist nur ein Beispiel von ganz vielen, wo dieser Katalog einfach komplett Schrott ist.
Abgesehen davon, mein allergrößter Pet-Pief mit allen Streaming-Diensten ist,
dass man halt immer nur die neuesten Remastered-Versionen von irgendwas bekommt und nicht sagen kann,
ja, guten Tag, ich hätte jetzt gerne ACDC Back in Black in der 80er-Version,
die noch nicht zu Tode komprimiert ist und noch ein bisschen dynamischen Headroom hat.
Das geht halt immer nicht. Man kriegt immer nur die neueste,
remasterte oder gecuttete, was auch immer Version.
Weswegen ich bis heute auch immer noch gebrauchte CDs kaufe.
Und die dann rippe, damit ich genau die Version bekomme, die ich haben will.
Zum Beispiel, oh, letztens.
Ich habe wirklich, letztens bin ich wieder vom Stuhl gefallen,
dass das, also, und das war mehrfacher Hinsicht wild.
Ich habe viel, nee, ich habe nicht viel elektronische Musik.
Und die meiste elektronische Musik in meiner Library ist 10 oder 15 Jahre alt.
Oder mittlerweile wahrscheinlich 20. Und da war ein Album, was ich seit jeher
zum Coden gerne höre, das heißt Vector Lovers und das heißt,
das Album heißt auch Vector Lovers, also Artist mit Self-Titled Album.
Und ich muss diese MP3s irgendwann im CCCB von irgend so einem Server mir mal kopiert haben.
Und letztens habe ich so einer Freundin geschrieben, hier du sag mal,
ich glaube, kennst du das? Ich glaube, das würde dir gefallen,
hab ihr das mal geschickt, ne?
Und sie meinte, ja krass, da habe ich auch vor 20 Jahren irgendwie zugezeichnet.
Und dann wollte, habe ich festgestellt, diese MP3 sind total räudig und ich
wollte mir jetzt mal die ordentliche Version besorgen und stellte fest,
okay, die Albumversion, die ich habe, ist das Pre-Release, wo der Typ das noch
selber auf CD-ROMs gebrannt hat und selber Labels draufgeklebt hat.
Das hat zwar schon Label-Code, ist aber noch komplett DIY und die ganzen Releases
danach haben eine komplett andere Tracklist.
Das heißt, derjenige oder diejenige Person, die das im CCCB auf den Server geschmissen
hat, hatte auch genau diese Version.
So und jetzt bist du halt 2025, guckst du so,
keine der Streaming-Dienste hat natürlich diese Version, sondern nur eine der
letzten Releases mit komplett anderer Tracklist und der einzige Weg da ranzukommen,
ja, ich musste auf Discogs gehen und mir für 30 Euro von irgendjemand diese
noch ungeöffnete Pristine-Pre-Release-Version von 1999 oder so kommen lassen,
rippen und jetzt habe ich sie halt in lossless. weil das können die ganzen Streaming-Dienste nicht.
Aber ist nicht auch der Spotify-CEO einfach ein Arschloch?
Ja, ja, ja.
Es gab irgendwie so einen schönen Interview-Ausschnitt von ihm,
wo er irgendwie auf der Bühne gefragt wird, warum er denn die Musiker so schlecht bezahlt.
Und seine Antwort ist im Wesentlichen, naja, wer Geld verdienen will,
sollte eh keine Musik machen.
Also es ist wirklich, wenn ihr auf YouTube sucht, 10 Reasons to Leave Spotify,
das kam, glaube ich, vor einem Monat oder so raus. Und da werden eigentlich
alle Gründe auch nochmal ein bisschen wahrscheinlich kohärenter ausformuliert als von mir.
Aber so die grundsätzlichen Probleme beim Streaming und warum ich immer noch
auf Files stehe, sind halt bei allen Streaming-Services kacke.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man Musikliebhaber ist und gute Qualität und einen guten
Katalog will, ist Cobus tatsächlich gerade so eigentlich der beste Kompromiss.
Aber wer die Convenience von Apple Music und iTunes Match, die da reingebacken
wurde, nicht missen möchte, dann ist halt Apple Music leider immer noch der...
Und was war iTunes Match gleich?
Du kannst halt selber einfach lalalala in Wave aufnehmen, packst es in eine,
Library rein, auf dem Computer und dann kannst du es halt, egal wo du bist,
auf der Welt von deinem iPhone auch streamen.
Also es synkt das sozusagen in die Cloud und ja.
Und das benutze ich halt, weil ich mit der Hobbyband auch immer noch alle Proberaum-Sessions
aufnehme und wenn dann halt was cooles dabei ist, schmeiße ich es halt in Apple
Music rein und hab es dann auch überall.
Und das funktioniert halt auch genau für dieses Vector Lovers Release zum Beispiel,
was nicht in dem Katalog ist.
Hab ich selber gerippt, ist dann halt auch auf allen Devices streambar.
Und kannst du halt auch runterladen auf dem Telefon oder im Flugzeug oder sonst
wo hören, wo es kein Internet gibt.
Eine Funktion, die ich wahrscheinlich nie brauchen würde, aber die sehr cool klingt.
Ja, hat auch, glaube ich, sonst kein anderer Streaming-Service.
oder Musikdienstleister.
Aber das, was jetzt so auf Musik zutrifft, trifft ja auch auf Filme zu.
Witzigerweise ist ja jetzt wieder The Pirate Bay in aller Munde.
Ach, Quatsch. Was ist das denn?
Weißt du, wirklich...
Eine Sache, die ich wirklich an diesem Internet und diesem 21.
Jahrhundert liebe, ist, dass ThePirateBay.org einfach immer noch online ist
und immer noch liefert. Nach all den Jahren, nach all den Trials and Tribulations.
Das ist so der Spelz in der Brandung des Internets irgendwie.
Wenn du mal was brauchst, ist die Pirate Bay für dich da.
In der Bucht.
In der Bucht, ja. Ja, und das ist ja wirklich so, bis da als Netflix rauskam
und dann plötzlich alles auf einem Dienst war, ja geil, 10 Dollar im Monat oder
Euro im Monat hast du alles da am Start.
Und jetzt mit dieser absoluten Fragmentierung und Shitshow von den Videostreaming-Services
geht es bei Pirate Bay wieder ab.
Tja, zu viele Streaming-Services ist halt nicht gut.
Wenn du irgendwie 10 oder so abonnieren musst, um alles gucken zu können.
Und da muss man tatsächlich auch mal für Apple, und das ist ja wirklich in Internetsachen
sehr selten, dass man Apple mal ein Lob aussprechen muss.
Aber ich finde, die haben in den letzten paar Jahren echt ordentlich Content geliefert.
Also die TV-Shows, die so in aller Munde sind, sind alle auf Apple TV irgendwie
gefühlt. Also zumindest der Großteil.
Das stimmt. Das ist eine erstaunlich hohe Trefferquote. an, wirklich. Guckt jemand Pluribus?
Nicht spoilern, ich bin erst bei vier oder so.
Sehr, sehr sehenswert. Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr sehenswert.
Foundation liebe ich noch, wobei ich da die letzte Folge noch nicht gesehen habe.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Es sind echt ein paar gute Sachen dabei.
Ja, hier Severance war ja auch auf Apple TV.
Und ist eine andere Sendung, die die habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen, aber The Silo oder so?
Silo, ja. Ich weiß nicht, also Silo fängt gut an, wird dann schlechter und wird
dann wieder besser, aber es ist so ein bisschen...
Up and down. Aber auch, kann man definitiv auch angucken.
Also die machen auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade so das, was die anderen irgendwie
nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegen. HBO und so, das ist ja alles nichts mehr.
Und jetzt gibt es ja diese...
Die sind jetzt auch von Netflix aufgekauft worden.
Ja, und jetzt gibt es ja diesen Warner Brothers, Paramount, sonst was.
Hey, Kack da. Also wirklich alles ganz schlimm. Insofern, da hat Apple mal ein
bisschen Lob verdient. Willst du auch was sagen?
Ja, aber sie sind auch nur ein weiterer Streaming-Dienst, der Content anbietet,
für den man noch ein Abo braucht. Also bloß, wenn man das Abo zufälligerweise hat.
Du musst unbedingt die Menü-Taste drücken.
Jetzt nicht über Tim lustig machen. Sieht gerade nicht so aus,
als ob er es gebrauchen könnte.
Pluribus kann man in der Tat noch mal ein bisschen anpreisen.
Also ich bin auch erst bei Folge 4.
Das heißt also jetzt bitte wirklich nichts spoilern. Aber es ist ja von dem
quasi Mastermind of Breaking Bad und Better Call Saul and It Shows.
Also die Art und Weise, wie dort wieder ein Szenario durchdekliniert wird und
so in den Kopf der Leute reingekrochen, wird.
Das hat schon, das hat mich schon sehr geflasht, die ersten Folgen bisher.
Wenn sie da jetzt nicht alles gegen die Wand fahren, wird das glaube ich eine sehr, sehr tolle Serie.
Wie der ganze Erzählstil, wie am Anfang, also ich spoilere jetzt wirklich nicht,
das sind die ersten fünf Minuten der Serie, wie ein Signal wird empfangen,
die Wissenschaftler sind alle ganz giddy und die können sich die ganz kaum noch...
Also aus dem Weltraum.
Von Aliens. Und so halt nicht so irgendwie, wir stehen vor dem Präsidenten der
Vereinigten Staaten und machen mit dem, sondern halt irgendwelche Wissenschaftler,
die sich einen abfreuen, dass die anderen auch keine besseren Antworten haben als sie und so.
Das ist wirklich so toll gemacht, so ein erstaunlich ruhiger,
schneller Show-Don't-Tell-Erzählstil.
Das ist mir an so vielen Stellen aufgefallen.
Es ist eine Geste dabei, auch sehr am Anfang, auch jetzt nicht spoilern,
wo sich zwei die Hand geben und diesem einen Hand geben, sieht man so,
die sind ein Paar, man sieht deren Beziehungen, man sieht alles in diesen 0,2-Sekunden-Handgeste.
Fantastische Serie und ich habe bisher jede Folge gesehen und bisher bin ich
nicht enttäuscht worden.
Und ich hoffe, es bleibt dabei.
Du bist ja für mich. Meine größte Sorge bei der Serie ist eigentlich,
dass es mit so einem Klischee das Individuum versus das Kollektiv auf Lösungen kommt.
Und ich hoffe, sie haben irgendeinen cleveren Twist da drin,
der es nicht ganz super predictable macht. Aber wir schauen mal.
Also es ist auf zwei Seasons angelegt.
Auf zwei? Okay.
Also wohl auch auf genau zwei. Das hat der Showrunner schon rausgehauen.
Das heißt, was auch immer am Ende von Season 1 passiert, das ist noch nicht
das Ende der Geschichte an der Stelle.
Es sind auch nicht mehr viele Folgen in dieser Season.
Ja, aber ja, das war auf jeden Fall...
Ja, und jetzt kommt auch dieser Formel-1-Film. Der soll ja auch wohl ganz gut...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das taugt.
Ich habe gedacht, gucke ich mir mit einem Kind an. Mit dem kann er bestimmt gut gucken.
Oh oh, ich glaube, jetzt werden hier die harten Geschütze rausgefahren.
Tim, wie wäre es denn mit einfach irgendwen rausschmeißen hier?
Ich habe Ralf schon gesagt, also ich bin noch nicht böse, wenn ich 22.30 Uhr hier wieder abhaufe.
Wir werden ja alle nicht jünger.
Ich kann ja mal einen kurzen Zwischenstand geben. Ja, also mein Plan hätte funktioniert,
nur diese scheiß Loopback-Software macht halt irgendwelche komischen Audio-Aussetzer. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Ich werde das jetzt hier nochmal mit meinem Laptop probieren.
Dann müsste ich allerdings deine Audio-Verbindung killen dann. Ralf.
Das ist akzeptabel.
Dann musst du bei Bluetooth einspielen.
Und ich werde dann jede Minute, während ich diese Sendung schneide,
werde ich dich verflüchten.
Ach, wie in den alten Zeiten.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, also ich hatte es ja bei meinem letzten Comeback oder Stell dich ein auch schon gesagt.
Also ich habe ja auch den Rodecaster Pro 2, 2 Pro wie auch immer,
den ich vor allen Dingen für dieses Bild in N-1 quasi sehr gerne habe.
Allerdings gibt es auch einige Dinge, die ich daran nicht so mag.
Sie haben zwar die interne Latenz mittlerweile so weit runtergekriegt,
dass es mich nicht mehr stört, mich selber zu hören, aber das war am Anfang
zum Beispiel ziemlich ätzend.
Es hat auch so, ich hatte auch schon so, was waren das? Irgendwelche so Grounding und Hum-Issues.
Ah ja, genau, hatte ich vielleicht auch damals erzählt, aber ich habe halt die
Tasten von dem Ding immer gedimmt nach einer Zeit, damit es nicht so mich anschallert
mit den ganzen bunten Buttons von der Seite.
und irgendwie hatte ich immer so ein Surren im Kopfhörer und ich so, Alter, was ist das?
Und ich habe alle Kabel getauscht und nochmal schön nur das Ding an eine Steckdose,
bliblablub, ging nicht weg.
Und dann irgendwann, wirklich nach Wochen des Debunks und Kabeltauschens,
gucke ich so gerade in die Richtung
und sehe, wie alle Buttons dimmen und plötzlich fängt dieses Summen an.
Und ich dachte mir, nein, ihr habt nicht ein PWM da eingebaut,
was in den Audiokanal reinstreut.
Und das war es dann. Dann habe ich den Dimmer ausgeschaltet und seitdem habe
ich keinen Summen mehr in den Ohren, wo ich aber auch dachte.
Proa steht da drauf nicht, Behringer oder hast du nicht gesehen irgendwie.
Ja, deswegen...
Das ist auch meine Freude an dem Gerät so mit Einschränkungen, sagen wir mal.
Es löst zwar einige Probleme ganz gut, aber ein paar Sachen hätte auch besser sein können.
Sehr lustig. Ich glaube, ich war in der Sendung dabei, als das das erste Mal
eingesetzt worden ist, wie es der Zufall so wollte. Und damals war das Lob noch
sehr groß. Also nicht von dir, aber von Tim.
Ja es tut ja auch im Wesentlichen tut es, es hat halt so ein paar Dinge,
wo ich beim Pro-Suffix einfach ein bisschen mehr erwartet hätte, sagen wir mal so,
und ja letztes Mal meinte ich ja auch
dass eigentlich jetzt wo ich diese RME-Interfaces benutze und das damit,
mein ganzes Audio-Routing mache,
dass das jetzt doch nochmal eine andere Qualitätsstufe irgendwie ist ähm,
Und ein bisschen mehr Spaß macht. Aber ich habe den Roadcaster auch noch nicht
weggeschmissen, weil es halt mit dem USB auch sehr convenient ist.
Und ich habe so einen USB-Switcher, weil ich ja auch noch einen Gaming-PC habe.
Und da benutze ich das dann auch, weil das auch sehr praktisch ist,
wenn man mit anderen Leuten zusammen Computerspiele spielt.
Das Game-Audio, also N-1 ist da auch relevant, weil dann manchmal im Game-Audio
das nicht richtig separiert wird.
Und dann haben die im Discord plötzlich Game-Audio mit drin,
was du halt nicht willst.
Und mit dem Rotcaster ist das halt auch total stressfrei.
Kleiner Test, kleiner Test, kleiner Test.
Man hört dich doppelt.
Ja, das ist jetzt, weil ich hier zwei Mikrofone gleichzeitig einspreche.
Aber Ralf, oder vielleicht, Tockel, nimmst du mal das hier.
Das wird jetzt noch keinen Kopfhörer-Sound haben, aber du hast zumindest dein eigenes Mikrofon.
Ja, okay. Ich höre mich ja auch schon mal.
Aber das ist auch noch mit. Aber euch höre ich nicht.
Da muss ich dann so machen.
Du hörst uns nicht?
Nee.
Ah, okay.
Da loop noch was. Wieso loop da was?
Ah, da loop noch was.
Wäre aber zu ertragen.
Das ist nicht zu ertragen. Ach so, weil ich hier den falschen... Okay, warte mal.
Aber mit dem Podcasten muss man ja sagen, ich bin ja... Das ist ja wie mit einem
Kaffee machen so ein bisschen. Entweder man bleibt beim Filterkaffee oder man
ist automatisch 20.000 Euro los, oder? Das ist ein.
Bisschen was dazwischen gibt es schon noch.
Aber nicht viel. Ja, kommt drauf an. Also wenn man halt mit vier Leuten podcasten
will, ist es auf jeden Fall nochmal anders als mit zweien.
Ich meine, mit Letty mache ich ja hier diesen kleinen Glitterbrains-Podcast
und das machen wir ja nur über Studiolink.
Und Letty hat sich dann natürlich schon auch nochmal ein ordentliches Mikron
so besorgt. aber im Wesentlichen ist es eigentlich mit einfachsten Mitteln zu wuppen.
Das stimmt Remote ist inzwischen fast leichter als in person habe ich manchmal
das Gefühl während Corona habe ich ja einige Sachen dann gemacht mit,
Studio Link hatten wir irgendwann mal massive Probleme, das ist mitten in der
Sendung ausgefallen, dass danach jedes Vertrauen weg war so ein bisschen und
das auch zu umständlich war dann, aber da gibt es ja so tatsächlich ganz gute Web-Tools,
die dann auch gleich die Videoaufnahme machen und so dieses ganze Zeug kostet
alles ein Schweinegeld.
Nee, es gibt doch hier, es heißt nicht mehr OBS Ninja, aber der neue Name davon,
also ein Typ, der bei OBS irgendwie ganz viel gebaut hat,
der hat quasi so einen Studio-Link für Video-Calls und so weiter gemacht, also Video und Audio.
VDO Ninja?
Genau, so heißt das. Und da kannst du dir richtig abgefahrene Setups über das
Web zusammenklicken und das ist relativ flexibel, auch mit dem Audio und Audio
Interfaces und was wohin kommt.
Und damit habe ich auch schon tatsächlich gepodcastet mit Video-Feed gleich mit drin.
Also wer das noch nicht kennt, der, wie heißt das jetzt?
V-D-O. Video.
V-D-O. Das ist wirklich eins der geilsten Web-Tools, was ich so kenne dazu und
das ist, glaube ich, ohne Bezahlen.
Das ist 100% free. No downloads. No personal data collection.
Jetzt hucke ich auf den Trip.
Oh, jetzt habe ich sogar eine schöne Bierkiste. Aber dann klingt es ja zu doppelt.
Ich hoffe, du kannst dankbar sein, dass du überhaupt was kriegst.
Ich fordere jetzt einen kleinen Zwischenapplaus ein.
Oh, Tim, es hat an der Tür geklärt.
Das ist nicht so. Du machst dich wahnsinnig.
Was für ein Timing.
Habt ihr den Moment abgewartet?
Nein.
Tim, es tut mir so leid.
Die Zerstörung des Tim-Prit-Loves.
Das wäre doch jetzt der passende Episodentitel.
Tim, du kennst den Hobbit, oder? Ich hab das im Moment abgewartet.
Dann müssen wir das auch im Moment spielen.
Dann müssen wir das anders machen.
Pass mal auf, dann machen wir... Gibst du mir mal das Headset da links unten?
Hättet ihr nur was gesagt? Ja, ja.
Ich spulte eingängig, wie es die Ärztin kommt.
Wieso haben jetzt alle mehr Eingänge und Ausgänge als Tim?
Ihr müsst jetzt mal da hin.
Ich hole schon mal noch eine Bierkäste. Nee, wir machen das jetzt einfach.
Da mit dem Sofa.
So schnell wird man von der Stimme der Jugend zum alten Herrn.
Nach ein paar Jahren passiert das ganz alleine.
Wie ich immer sage, man wird eigentlich sein ganzes Leben lang junger Mann genannt.
Das ist bloß wo die ironische Brechung auf welchem Teil des Vault ist.
Bring your own mic. Das ist aber echt.
Ja,
mit vielen Zellern habe ich gehört.
Gibt es noch was zu trinken?
Willst du stollen?
Stollen haben wir noch.
Er hat ja gesagt.
Die Hörer meinten ja, ich wäre akustisch auf dem Trip. Ist das immer noch so?
Mach mal das Mikro dichter dran.
Hallihallo.
Ah, viel besser.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir es richtig,
weil jetzt ist der Raumklang versus Headphone-Klang viel ausgeglichener.
Ich sammle immer bei Huckel mit
rein. Guten Abend. Ja, es bringt deine Transkriptikation durcheinander.
Hier muss mal weitergereicht werden. Der Stollen muss durchgereicht werden.
Es geht erstmal nur um Pimp my mic.
So, warte mal, jetzt muss ich noch den Freund hier noch mit drauflegen.
Während du da knobelst, würde ich gerne noch euer Thema von vorhin kurz anreißen.
Siri ist echt für den Arsch mit dieser Geschichte. Oh Mann ey.
Auf dem Weg hierher, ich bin mit dem Auto gekommen, dachte ich,
ich höre mal noch irgendwie einen Podcast, kriege einen Anruf und dann spielt es nicht weiter.
Dann habe ich versucht Siri dazu zu überreden, den Podcast weiter zu spielen.
Auf der nativen Apple Podcast Software.
Siri meinte aber, nee, dazu müsste ich mich erst bei Spotify anmelden. und so.
Dann hast du so, äh, what? Dann bekam ich eine E-Mail,
Ich glaube, jetzt sind wir nicht gerade nicht mehr. Hat Siri mir eine E-Mail
vorgelesen vom Mai oder so?
Eben ging es doch noch.
Ja, es geht auch wieder.
Achso, Entschuldigung, ich habe die falsche Taste gedrückt. Letzte musst du noch mal sagen.
Nee, ich sage nix normal. Ich bin so alt, ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern,
was ich eben gesagt habe.
Warum hören wir dich so leise?
Ich höre Clemens ganz wunderbar.
Ja, du, du bist ja auch im selben Mischpult, aber warum hören wir euch?
Die sind beide leise, ja.
So leise, warte mal.
Das macht alles das Auphonik dann wieder heile.
Wie viele Inputs sind da noch frei? Ich guck nur an.
Nach meiner Rechnung noch zwei.
Wieso?
Ah, da geht noch was.
Ihr habt ja den Hobbit gelesen und gesehen, wie viele Zwerge das waren.
Wann kommt Sauron?
Ich hab das Zeichen draußen an der Tür, das war doch so, komm hier rein,
hier gibt's Stollen, oder?
Okay, also ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt hier überhaupt noch alles funktioniert,
aber besser klingelt es jetzt nicht hin. Wenn es noch klingelt, es noch mal?
Es wird noch einmal klingelt.
Es wird noch einmal klingelt. Okay, eine Zeit habe ich noch.
Siehst du. Du machst das ganz wunderbar.
Applaus, Applaus, Applaus.
Das hätte so schön geholfen.
Aber du verstehst auch, wenn ich gesagt hatte, stell mal ein Mischpult mit acht
Eingängen hin, das hätte dann auch nicht denselben Effekt gehabt.
Du kommst ein bisschen von den Zeiten, wo du alleine gepodcastet hast, oder?
Hast du gerade acht gesagt?
Ich muss mal auch mein Fenster gleich aufmachen.
Damit wir hier nicht gleich alle unterm Tisch liegen.
Ja, das können wir auch machen. Jetzt müssen wir nochmal überlegen,
habe ich noch ein achtes Kabel?
Du machst jetzt das kleinste Fenster auf.
Was du für das anrufst.
Bis vor ein paar Minuten sagen, das hat durchaus auch Längen,
deine Bastelei. Wenn du mal kurz,
als konstruktive Kritik in den Raum werfen darfst.
Der arme Tim.
Aber eben war es, auch Huckel in der Tat laut hat.
Da habe ich ja auch noch in deinem Zeitpunkt gesprochen.
Max, das ist auch alles ein bisschen über. So, was ich aber auf jeden Fall schon
mal machen kann, ist einen kleinen Clemens-Einspieler reinbringen.
Per Bluetooth jetzt?
Warte mal, da musst du aber erstmal dieses...
Ach Gott, jetzt bin ich natürlich nicht mehr hier dran.
Jetzt muss per Bluetooth hier rein.
Ach, wunderbar. Ich liebe diese Sendung, Tipp.
Oh, ich weiß sie jetzt schon.
Es hätte so schön sein können.
Es hätte alles so schön sein können. alles so vorbereitet und tralala.
Die ist aber sehr retro, wie ich finde.
Ja, es ist ein Test.
Aber Ralf, für die Schalte brauche
ich doch auch noch meine drei Devices dran. Wie machen wir das denn?
Bluetooth. So. Okay, Bluetooth.
Seid froh, dass Dennis keine Zeit hat.
Also wir sehen jetzt hier die Systemeinstellung.
So, jetzt müsstest du mal in Längen schon erwähnen.
Bitte.
In Pairing.
Und sonst keiner, bitte.
Bluetooth. Pairing, ja, Geräte in der Nähe. Suchen, suchen, suchen. Rodicaster Pro 2.
Den nimmst du. Dann musst du jetzt noch.
Da war eine Zahl und sie war sofort wieder weg.
Okay, und jetzt müsstest du gepairt sein. Und jetzt müsstest du Dinge spielen können.
Es ist ja eigentlich auch ein Skandal, dass die 300. Sendung nicht eine Live-Sendung
ist. Ein schöner Uranier oder so.
Das ist eine Live-Sendung.
Einmal mit Profis.
Achtung, gucken wir mal, ob was kommt.
Ich finde das auch skandalösig, stimmt jeder.
Wie auch immer, hier ist Mobile Max Nummer 96, die Post-iPhone.
Genau, ums iPhone 5.
Wir haben leider den Anfang nicht gehört.
War das direkt nach der Live-Übertragung oder irgendwie sowas?
Das war direkt nach einer Keynote.
Aber die ist ja gar nicht so spät.
Das iPhone, ich glaube es war einen Tag später. Achso, das war nicht wirklich
live, sondern war ein Tag drauf. Aber es setzt sich wieder fort.
Wer ist Clemens? Was macht denn der Sendung? Warum ist er jetzt hier?
Das weiß ich bis heute nicht. In einem anderen Podcast.
Mehrfach sogar bei ihm.
Davor ich jetzt in die Sendung kam, habe ich ja schon mit ihm Karl CRE gemacht.
Man muss einfach CRE als Vorbereitung hören.
Das stimmt.
Verstehe.
Ich war auch irgendwann mal ganz, glaube ich, ganz fürchterlich eigentlich,
also nicht erkältet, aber ich war auf jeden Fall nicht fit und habe über damals
das ganz neue Git gesprochen,
was ich retrospektiv auch gerne nochmal überschreiben würde.
Einfach weil ich so platt war an dem Tag und weiß nicht, ob das so gut war.
Aber dadurch hätten die geneigten Meta-Ebenen-Hörerinnen das Huckelchen auch kennen können.
Also was mich auf jeden Fall ist die ganzen Sendungen durchgegangen, was mich erstaunt hat.
Clemens, ich hatte irgendwie so bei mir abgespeichert, dass du total spät dazugekommen
bist zur Freakshow und dann so ab und zu sporadisch mal da warst und wenig Zeit
und dann warst sie irgendwann auch wieder weg.
Damals habe ich ja noch in Berlin gewohnt.
Und das ist alles falsch. Also ich habe ja hier gerade eben schon gesagt,
ein bisschen Datenvisualisierung mal gemacht hier von der Freakshow und du warst
jede einzelne Sendung da.
Und zwar in den Jahren 2013, 2014, 2015, 2016, 2017 glaube ich auch.
Das heißt also du warst hier der konstanteste Gast überhaupt.
Das war auch mal weg ein bisschen. Oder dann war da eine Sommerpause oder so. Kann sein.
Aber damals habe ich hier noch um die Ecke gewohnt. Von daher war das nicht so ein Problem.
Und dann kam Corona und dann kam Tims Ansage, wir machen nicht remote,
weil das ist ja unstylisch.
Oder irgendwie so, es gab diese, Entschuldigung, es gab diese Ansage vorher,
es gab diese Ansage vor Corona, dass wir nicht remote machen.
Und hin und her und dann hat es mich ja aufs Land verschlagen.
Und dann war das halt eben ein bisschen schwieriger. Ich bin auch jetzt heute
wieder aus dem schönen Norden von Brandenburg hier angereist, fast aus Meckpom.
Genau, den Corona-Klick, den sieht man natürlich sehr deutlich hier in der Statistik.
Ich habe hier eine der Statistiken, das ist einfach ganz schnöde Episoden pro
Jahr und da sieht man so die ersten Jahre, das waren so 19, 20 Sendungen,
dann ging es mal ein bisschen höher, 22 Sendungen,
24 Sendungen pro Jahr und dann gab es so einen leichten Abfall,
so Richtung 2018 und dann kommen halt irgendwie 2019 nur noch 10 Sendungen,
nee 2019 sind es noch 17 Sendungen.
2020, wo dann also Corona dann schon durchgeschlagen ist, gab es noch zehn Sendungen,
2021, 20, sieben Sendungen und dann im Jahr drauf wirklich keine einzige.
Und dann haben wir ja 2023 wieder angefangen.
Ja, also ich meine, zu Corona muss man glaube ich nicht viel sagen.
Das hat ja wirklich nahezu alle Communities zerschlagen.
Und eins kann ich dir sagen, also Freakshow online in so einem Zoom,
also das kannst du einfach vergessen.
Das war jetzt auch nicht als Kritik von mir.
Ich habe das schon verstanden.
Aber das war halt die Begründung dafür, warum das so ein bisschen zerbruselt ist.
Ja, ich wollte das einfach auch mal ein bisschen erklären, weil wir ja jetzt
hier gerade so ein bisschen Geschichte des Podcasts,
aufarbeiten und ja, und deswegen war dann halt auch irgendwann so der Beschluss mit,
es muss jetzt erstmal wieder die Energie muss jetzt erstmal wieder kommen und
es muss eine Idee auch geben, wie man sich aufstellen möchte,
weil ich meine 2008 bis heute,
Das sind jetzt auch schon fast 20 Jahre. Ist ja ein bisschen was passiert in der Zwischenzeit.
Unser Verhältnis zu Technik ist anders geworden, unser Verhältnis zum Internet ist anders geworden.
Gerade jetzt, wo das irgendwie alles so katastrophal, dystopisch wird und man
sich auch für die eine oder andere Position fast schämen muss.
und von daher denke ich, ist halt auch erforderlich, dass man sich auch anders
positioniert, also dass man auch sozusagen einen anderen Kommentar geht,
weil früher war das ja so dieses,
oh geil, Computer, super Internet, alles toll, hier Memes, Spaß haben,
irgendwie rumdaddeln, was kann schon passieren?
So, und jetzt ist so.
Weltauflösung, irgendwie die Tech-Industrie ist der globale,
libertäre Faschismus, der irgendwie mit Krypto-Currency irgendwie uns aller
Systeme beraubt und irgendwie uns den Boden unter den Füßen wegzieht.
Und da muss man dann schon irgendwie auch mal, ja, weiß ich nicht,
mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und gucken, wie man das überhaupt noch kommentiert.
Deswegen sind ein paar, was du gerade sagst, das sind so ein paar meiner technischen Themen.
Ralf hatte ja gesagt, ich sollte mich mal ein bisschen vorbereiten,
mal gucken, was ich so damals beugesteuert habe.
Vorbereiten, so wichtig.
Ich bin ja, ja, ja, so wichtig, wie wir gemerkt haben. Merken, wie wir merken.
Ja, aus dem CRE bin ich nachher gekommen, weil du irgendwann mal wissen wolltest,
wie das Internet so außerhalb deiner Wohnung funktioniert und damals haben wir
ja noch geschwärmt, haben wir ja noch so, ja man könnte ja,
wenn man wollte und dann gab es irgendwann so technische Sprünge,
wo sozusagen mal endlich mal ordentliche Bitraten irgendwie aus,
aber dann war das immer noch so teuer oder so, weil ich bin seit Jahren mit 5G Flatrate unterwegs.
benutze schon gar kein WLAN mehr irgendwo, außer vielleicht bei mir zu Hause,
aber wenn ich irgendwie mal unterwegs bin in irgendwelchen Hotels,
das fasse ich echt nicht an.
Ich lasse einfach mein Telefon, mein Dings. Das Einzige, was mich immer noch
ärgert, habe ich damals auch schon 50, 30 Mal in der Sendung gesagt,
Apple, ihr Penner, ihr habt jetzt eine eigene Abteilung, die Mobilfunkchips macht.
Könnt ihr die bitte endlich mal in den Mac einbauen? Diese Tethering-Nummer ist echt für den Fuß.
Nächstes oder übernächstes Jahr heißt es.
Hallo?
Aber es ist nicht alles schlecht. Ich habe jetzt endlich V6 zu Hause nach.
Ja, aber V6 ist auch wieder so ein Ding.
Inzwischen sind wir auch wieder so weit, dass V6 wieder keiner braucht.
Keiner braucht stimmt nicht, aber die Leute, die damals haben sich ja versprochen
davon, oh ja, dann kann ich ja endlich jedes meiner Internet-of-Shit-Dinger,
die ich zu Hause in meinem Netz zu stecken habe, auch aus China erreichen.
Und inzwischen ist das ja auch alle passé. Selbst der Heimbastler,
der nerdigste Heimbastler hat irgendwo eine Cloud und selbst wenn er sich selber
klickt bei Hetzner auf einer VM für 5 Euro im Monat oder sowas.
Das heißt, diese ganze Nummer, ich muss direkt meine Geräte von draußen erreichen,
hat auch jetzt dank Shodan und Involvement von chinesischen und anderen State
Actors auch irgendwie so ein bisschen an Spaß verloren.
Inzwischen geht es doch eher in die andere Richtung.
Ich will jetzt auf gar keinen Fall hier gegen V6. Ich bin gerade dabei,
so ein Stadtwerkebetreiber war vorsichtig davon zu überzeugen,
das doch mal anzuknippen.
Aber die, sagen wir mal so, der ganze Hype, der da mal hinter war oder sowas,
ist jetzt auch einfach da.
Also insbesondere so für Telekom-Kunden. Wir haben uns ja damals schon gefreut,
dass oft als Telekom gerade mal so die ersten Bits per DSL schoss,
floss da schon V6 raus, würde ich mal fast sagen.
Und inzwischen gehabt es auch im Mobilfunk, selbst im Roaming und so.
Solche Sachen, das sind eigentlich alles im Laufe der Jahre,
es ist einfach weggegangen.
Und durch diese Flatrates auch und die Tarife, ich will jetzt nochmal ein bisschen
weiter wegfahren, nächstes Jahr,
Und da gibt es einfach diesen tollen Telekom-Mechanismus, nimm nochmal dein
Zeugs mit, was du zu Hause hast für 50 oder 100 Euro.
Und wenn du einen Monat irgendwo unterwegs bist, dann klicke ich mir das einfach.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe keinen Bock mehr in Flughäfen rumzurennen und dann nach SIM-Karten zu suchen.
Also ich klicke mir das einfach vorne weg, das funktioniert tadellos.
Ich war letztes Jahr in Kanada, das war schön, das hat einfach da funktioniert.
Ja und wie gesagt, die Tarife sind inzwischen okay.
Es gibt immer noch Leute, die meinen, ja, können wir immer noch mal 5 Euro irgendwo
sparen, aber was kann man sich heutzutage leisten?
Und das funktioniert auch einfach. Das heißt also, diese ganze Thematik mit,
oh, wie können wir jetzt an diesem Internetanschluss noch was schauen oder wie
kriege ich jetzt noch einen Internetanschluss oder sowas, ist eben auch gerade,
aufgrund dieser Geschichten echt passé.
Ich habe den Röllig mal wieder gehört und das war wirklich jetzt nach langer
Zeit, da hat mir jemand stolz erzählt, der betreibt so einen Pferdehof da in McPom irgendwo.
Und zwar richtig in the middle of fucking nowhere, so richtig im Nowhere.
Der hat sich jetzt ein Starlink geklickt.
Aber auch das geht.
Auch da kommt V4, V6 mit hunderten von Megabits raus ein Starlink.
Ach, Starlink.
Und das heißt, dieses Thema mit wir werden alle sterben, wenn wir jetzt nicht
alle irgendwie eine Glasfaser haben, aus der mindestens 10 Gigabits sprudeln,
das ist irgendwie auch rum.
Deswegen weiß ich nicht, an dieser Stelle kann ich jetzt einfach nicht mehr
so viel dazu sagen. Damals war es noch kaputt. Mich hat es ein bisschen gewundert,
dass du das jetzt nicht gespielt hast.
Stimmt natürlich.
Aber damals war es in der Tat kaputt. Es ist auch immer noch politisch kaputt,
aber die Leute, die da die Actors sind, die werden auch immer leiser.
Also insbesondere, ich habe ja damals auch viel auf die Telekom rumgeschimpft,
ich bin ja seit vielen Jahren selber Telekomkunde und ich muss mit denen in
anderen Bereichen immer mal wieder gerne kooperieren, muss gerne,
weil die technisch einfach gut sind, muss man mal so sagen.
Die funktionieren gut, die kooperieren, die sponsern auch immer viel.
Also jedes Mal, wenn der CCC irgendwo mal ein halbes Zelt hinstellt,
ist gleich die Telekom da und bietet da Bits an, aber nicht nur beim CCC,
sondern auch bei anderen. da kann man echt nichts gegen sagen.
Es ist halt immer noch deren Politik und deren Marketingabteilung,
die so ein bisschen so...
Und jetzt den Clemens-Schrimpe-Hot-Take zu Voodoo-Phone und ihrem Announcement
jetzt nicht mehr zu pieren mit...
Über Frankfurt?
Ja.
Ich piere noch mit Vodafone. Vielleicht solltet ihr gleich mal reingucken, ob das noch der Fall ist.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Das sind diese politischen Spielchen, die X-O-Miner.
Gib dir mal ein bisschen Hintergrund, was das jetzt meint.
Ich habe da ein schönes Gleichnis. Das von der Telekom wird wahrscheinlich von
den anderen dasselbe sein.
Ich führe mal dazu an, am Anfang, warum die da eigentlich so rumstehen können.
Und ein bisschen kann man das auf der menschlichen Ebene ja verstehen.
Die ganzen Provider, die hier so rumhängen und dann wirklich anfangen,
Wege aufzubuddeln für teuer Geld oder wie Sendemasten aufstellen und dafür tierisch
Geld investieren und machen und tun,
Die bauen denn da so ein Netz hin und kriegen von den Nutzern dafür auch noch Geld.
Ja, ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel, aber sie kriegen da irgendwie so ein Geld dafür.
Aber diese Rolle reicht ihnen nicht. Die sitzen halt da in Bonn oder in Düsseldorf
oder in München und starren auf die Googles dieser Welt, auf die Facebooks dieser Welt,
auf die Amazons dieser Welt, wie die sich dumm und dämlich verdienen über das Netz, was sie da bauen.
und das fickt die natürlich wahnsinnig an.
Nur das Problem, was sie haben ist,
Ihre Leistung ist schon bezahlt von den Endkunden.
Ich habe da mal vor 30 Sendungen.
Habe ich mal dieses Beispiel gebracht mit dem Bahnticket.
Du kaufst dir ein Bahnticket von Berlin nach München, setzt dich in den Zug, fährst los.
Und während der Zug so in Nürnberg einrollt und da stehen bleibt,
ruft jemand von der Bahn in München an und sagt, hallo, wir haben hier einen
Zug voller Leute für euch, die wollt ihr doch bestimmt haben aus Tourismusgründen
und so weiter. Wäre doch schade, wenn der jetzt hier stehen bleiben würde.
Wie wäre denn, wenn ihr uns nochmal ein bisschen Geld dafür gebt,
dass wir euch die Passagiere aus dem Nürnberg bringen.
Kann man machen, aber ich als Passagier sage, im Moment, ich habe da das Ticket
schon bis München bezahlt.
Wieso wollt ihr da nochmal extra Geld machen?
Warum stehe ich jetzt hier auf dem Abstellgleis, bis sich München entschieden
hat, euch dafür noch Geld zu geben, mich nach da hin zu bringen für das Ticket,
weil ich ja schon bezahlt habe.
So ähnlich verhält es sich halt mit so manchen Providern, die halt eben.
Endkundenanschlüsse, wir nennen das Eyeball-Anschlüsse, weil da sitzen halt
die Leute, die sozusagen das Internet begucken wollen und sie konsumieren und die.
Ja, dann rennen die halt eben hin und sagen, ey aber Google wäre doch toll oder
Apple oder Microsoft wäre doch toll, wenn ihr uns dafür auch nochmal ein Geld geben würdet.
Und weil sie diese Strategie drauf haben, hakelt es mit dem Peering so ein bisschen.
Peering heißt, dass sich Internetanbieter miteinander verbinden.
Und zwar entweder direkt früher oder was schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren Usus
ist, über so Austauschpunkte. ganz berühmt, bekannt, hat jeder Hörer dieser
Sendung schon mal gehört, das ist DZX in Frankfurt zum Beispiel oder nicht nur in Frankfurt.
Aber wir haben in Berlin auch einen BZX und so weiter und fort.
Und dieser Mini-ISP, für den ich da immer noch ein bisschen Beratung mache,
wir machen den Großteil unseres Traffics darüber, weil wir uns mit allen anderen,
die auch Sachen anzubieten haben, also wir sind ja auch größtenteils ein iBall-Provider,
also die anderen, die dann was anzubieten haben, wie so ein Apple oder so ein
Netflix, die sind auch an diesem Peering-Point.
Und da kriegt man halt einfach innerhalb eines Gebäudes über so einen Switch,
so einen großen verteilten Switch mit so ein paar Terabits, kriegt man halt
alles, was man da so haben will.
Wer da nicht an diesen Peering Points sitzt, ist zum Beispiel die Telekom.
Die Telekom sagt, wir haben hier ein paar Millionen Eyeballs,
wenn du was von uns willst, na dann komm doch her zu uns.
Kufst dir einen Anschluss von uns, lieber Netflix oder lieber Apple oder wie
auch immer, kufst dir einen Anschluss bei uns für ein paar hunderttausend Euro
im Monat und dann darfst du da unsere User mit bespielen.
Und ja, Vodafone hatte ich jetzt noch gar nicht gehört. Die wollen sich jetzt
auch zurückziehen vom Public Peering oder was?
Ja, genau.
Ja, okay. Fühlt sich wieder einer zu groß. I don't know. I don't care.
Ich bin ein Eyeball Provider. Die sind ein Eyeball Provider. Corona ist vorbei.
Tim fruckelt jetzt immer noch seit 10 Minuten. Ich frage mich,
was fruckelt der da? Aber ich glaube, er hat jetzt was.
Wer macht da noch ein Systemupdate nebenbei?
Das sieht aus wie YouTube. Die relevanten Memes hier, Alter.
Auch wieder David, ne?
Schade, dass du die nicht erreicht hast.
Das ist nicht gedrossen.
Ja, die Nummer ist übrigens ruhig. Das ist einfach kaputt.
Das sind einfach...
Das ist einfach kaputt.
Okay, Sven, dann bitte in den Tag.
50 Kilometer in der Stunde. Und plötzlich fährt dieses Auto 175 Meter in.
Ja, technisch gesehen dreht der
Mutter noch und vielleicht bewegt der sich noch. Das ist einfach kaputt.
Aber dafür braucht kein Auto 375 Meter in der Stunde zu überwinden.
Das ist einfach funktional kaputt.
Braucht kein DS-Anschluss für 384 Kilowitzen. Kann ich mal bei Mobilfunk machen,
sondern mit einer Morse-Taste.
Das ist einfach kaputt.
Digitale Querschnittslebung.
Ja.
Das ist einfach kaputt. 384 Kilowitzen kriegst du so um Wibern,
hast du Schnürsenkel drüber. Da brauchst du kein Glas für.
Ja, das steht alle mögliche im Dokument. Da stehen noch Worte drin wie Drossel. Es ist,
einfach kaputt? Kaputt? Oh yeah! Oh yeah! Oh yeah!
Bäm.
Fantastisch.
Da muss man übrigens dazu sagen, der Song hat geholfen. Von der Drossel habe
ich in der Kommunikation von Unternehmen lange nichts mehr gehört.
Das gibt es einfach nicht mehr. Doch, im Mobilfunk gibt es ja immer noch die
Leute, die noch Volumenkontingente haben.
Wenn das abgelaufen ist, dann wird es auch richtig auf kaputt gedrosselt.
Da passt der Song.
Das wäre doch mal was Schönes für AI. jedes Mal, wenn man so rot anläuft vor
Wut wegen irgendwas, dann sofort irgendein Song wird rausgeneriert.
Aber im ICE ist es doch auch immer noch kaputt.
Ist es?
Ich benutze es nie.
Dieses Dashboard hier habe ich im ICE gestern gecodet, aber es war wieder ein
irrer Schmerz oder coden lassen.
Das war also wieder sehr grinsend. Also diese Strecke Göttingen-Berlin fahre
ich halt so ab und an, weil komme ich ja ursprünglich her und da hast du einfach
dieses tiefe Tal der Tränen so von 200 Kilometer, wo einfach nix ist.
Ich war letzte Woche in Düsseldorf und da konnte ich die ganze Zeit eine SSH-Verbindung
zum Server aufrechterhalten. Das hat fantastisch funktioniert.
Also teilweise geht das echt gut. Über 5G.
Auch ohne Mosh.
Ohne Mosh, ja.
Damals gab es ja noch extra diese Mosh für Bahnfahrer. Das ist jetzt ja diese
Mobile Shell. Das hätte man eigentlich auch Busch nennen können.
Banshell. Aber der Name war schon belegt.
Ja, nee, aber das ist eigentlich, eigentlich bin ich da auch ganz zufrieden mit dem Ding.
Inzwischen, ich will jetzt auch nicht als Telekom verstehe, mich hier brandmarken,
aber ich habe da inzwischen auch Kontakt und auch Leute, die mir so Storys erzählen
oder sowas, wo du dann auch nicht sagen kannst, ja mein Gott,
dann soll es halt nicht sein.
Also so der Klassiker ist, das hatte ich glaube ich früher schon mal erzählt,
aber das höre ich immer noch so ein, zwei Mal im Jahr.
Dass irgendwelche Provider, Telekom oder nicht, ist ja egal,
irgendwo einen Mast hinstellen in irgendeinem Ort.
Das passiert bei uns da oben in Meckbom, Nordbrandenburg sehr häufig, gerade immer noch.
Und das braucht aber eine Weile. Wie in Deutschland wird ja nicht aus einem
Guss gemacht von einer Firma, sondern es gibt eine Firma, die sperrt erstmal ab zwei Jahre vorher.
und dann geht die pleite, dann muss jemand anders die Absperrung wegräumen und
eine neue hinbauen und die Straße umleiten für Dinge, die gar nicht passieren.
Also der Klassiker, der Deutsche.
Und dann gibt es irgendwann eine Firma, die stellt dann da so ein Mast hin.
Ein Mast.
Da ist noch keine Elektronik dran, weil es ist ja auch noch gar kein Strom da,
woher hätte man nicht wissen sollen, dass wenn man dann eine Basisstation hinbaut,
man auch noch Strom braucht.
Trotzdem kriegen die Leute schon Kopfschmerzen?
Genau. Trotzdem kriegen die Leute... Ernsthaft. Ernsthaft. Ich kenne da so jemanden,
der so Planungen macht bei so einem Netzbetreiber und dann kriegt der irgendwelche Anrufe.
Ja, wir haben hier Beschwerde von irgendeinem Bürgermeister.
Die Leute beschweren sich, dass die da Kopfschmerzen kriegen,
seit unser Master steht.
Und er guckt in seinen Plan und sagt, der hat jetzt einfach nur eine Metallgrippe,
was da steht. Da ist nix dran.
Oder dann gibt es so andere Splings zum Beispiel, dass irgendwelche Gemeinden
verlangen, weil irgendein Code, irgendein deutscher Installationscode oder sowas
von 1874 sagt, man hat ein Kabel, völlig 60 cm tief einzubuddeln.
und dann gibt es aber Gegenden, da ist Buddeln mit 60 cm nicht so leicht,
weil es halt eben Stein unten drunter und dann sagen manche dieser Provider
ja immer, ich will da eigentlich nur eine Glasfaser langlegen, das,
ja, ich möchte die schon, dass die nicht jeder gleich den Stein von der Straße
wegkickt, mit wegfetzt, aber
60 Zentimeter ernsthaft bei dem Felsuntergrund da und die dann so, ja.
Sagt der Provider, ja, dann warte mal noch ein bisschen auf deinen Mobilfunk.
So kam also dann Clemens in die Serie. So kam dann Clemens in die Serie.
Aber passierte das, was zu erwarten war. Ja, passierte das.
Aber war das jetzt nicht unser Internetminister, der neulich gesagt hat, dass man doch auch bei,
Glasfaser, also weil ja die Leute nicht freiwillig, also nicht in den Maßen
von DSL auf Glasfaser umsteigen, indem man sich das erhofft hat,
dass man doch die Technologieoffenheit lassen sollte und einfach beides parallel
weiter lassen laufen sollte.
Deutschland ist einfach so im Arsch. Also ich meine, es ist einfach auf allen Ebenen.
Also ich kann das auch verstehen in gewisser Art und Weise. Ich habe ja immer
von diesem schwedischen Modell geschwärmt, Das ist vielleicht jetzt auch nicht
in jedem Auto und so, aber die haben halt eben so ein Open-Modell.
Was wir immer noch haben, ist, dass das denn einen gibt, der da buddelt.
Einen, der da Glasfaser legt und einen, der dann Mondpreise aufruft für schlechten Service.
Solange das am Spiel ist, kann ich auch die Leute verstehen,
die einfach sagen, wieso mein Instagram geht noch.
Das geht seit Jahren. Warum soll ich mir jetzt hier für ein paar tausend Euro
Glasfaseranschluss legen lassen? Ich sehe gar nicht ein.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Szenarien. Zum Beispiel bei mir im Haus sind
die Wohnungen alle von individuellen Eigentümern.
Und dann kam halt erst Vodafone, Telekom, 1&1 und die alle so,
ja hier Glasfaser unterschreiben sie hier.
Und was dann aber eigentlich passiert ist, dass sie hoffen, dass alle beim selben
Provider unterschreiben und wenn nicht, dann kriegst du,
wenn du nicht aufpasst, von der Telekom, also ich bin bei Vodafone,
weil Kabel ist in meinem Kiez leider das Beste, was man haben kann.
Und dann habe ich bei Telekom gesagt, ja, ja, komm, gib mir mal Glas.
Und dann kam die so, ja, dann kündigen wir jetzt deinen Vodafone-Vertrag und
geben dir so lange DSL, bis dann das Glas, bis alle im Haus sich quasi dafür
entschieden haben, damit sich das für uns lohnt, den Anschluss zu machen und
die Faser durchs Haus zu legen.
Und dann, so eine Szenarien gibt es halt auch.
Und deswegen wird bei mir im Haus wahrscheinlich auch in den nächsten zehn Jahren
keine Glasfaser ankommen, obwohl eigentlich alle wollen.
Aber keiner kann sich einigen auf den Provider, der es dann erst mal machen soll.
Das ist gerade, weil das eben so gebunden ist. Wenn halt einen buddelst,
der sich nur ums Glas kümmert und sich die Provider dann da einmieten,
dann gäbe es dieses Gekloppe nicht.
Wie gesagt, in Deutschland sieht es nicht. Was ich allerdings zum Beispiel sehe,
ist, wie gesagt, ich wohne ja da ganz an der Grenze von Nordbronnburg zu Meckpom.
Das heißt, der nächste Landkreis ist MST oder Autokennzeichnungen MST,
Mecklenburg-Strelitz. Der größte Landkreis Deutschlands übrigens.
Wie mir erst vor ein paar Monaten mal aufgefallen ist.
Biggest or the greatest?
Da gibt es dann so Stadtwerke zum Beispiel, die Stadtwerke Neustrelitz und die
haben auch Landableger mit anderen Stadtwerken dort gemacht.
Da gibt es wirklich echt auf den kleinsten Käffern am letzten Bauernhof hinten
Glasfaser und auch AON, also kein PON, also auch mit schönen symmetrischen Bandbreiten
und so weiter und so fort. Leider nur von den Stadtwerken.
da müsste man jetzt mal kurz über V6 oder sowas reden, aber das so vom Prinzip
geht und die haben auch vernünftige Preise und so.
Und die haben halt einfach mal, und das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen,
die Orte, wo Stadtwerke am Start sind, das hat übrigens geklingelt, Tim.
Aber guck, es war das.
Soll ich ein Headset reichen?
Dann hast du es überstanden.
Wo Stadtwerke buddeln und Glas mitverlegeln, das funktioniert eigentlich immer
ganz gut, was ich so in den letzten Jahren gesehen habe.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch ein Berlin-Glasfaser inzwischen. von der Telekom.
Fünf Euro billiger, als es vorher war. Immerhin ein bisschen.
Das war echt beeindruckend. Also sie sind gekommen, haben das installiert,
hat 20 Minuten gedauert, haben das Modem umgesteckt und dann hatte ich Glasfaser.
Letty! Kontrolletti!
Das muss ich mal...
Montagmorgen.
Ja, vor allem, weil ich so selten in Berlin bin. Das hat mich echt erschrocken.
Lass dich herzen.
Ich will auch mal herzen. Auch mit Herzen.
Ich kann auch auf die Kiste hier. Stell das doch wieder hoch und ich nehme die
Kiste und Letty kriegt hier den.
Das einfach dahin. Ich setze mich hier drauf und Letty kann auf den Schönen wieder die Krise.
Ja, das...
Genau, ich rutsche mal noch ein bisschen zur Seite mit meinem Gerassel hier.
So, so. Es gibt wohl auch noch Stollen, das kannst du bei mir noch mitnaschen.
Obwohl Ach Tim, ich hab noch Leute von der Straße eingeladen.
Übrigens, während Tim jetzt bastelt, wir noch ganz schnell ein Thema mal auf
den Tisch schmeißen, weil ich es auch so schön kontrovers finde und mit V6 zu tun hat.
Wen von euch sagt das IPv6 mostly was?
Clemens, wir haben jetzt gerade einen neuen Gast in die Sendung einbekommen.
Ja, ich weiß, aber Tim bastelt noch.
Wir haben noch gemerkt.
Dass Tradition ist, dass sie nicht zum Wort kommen.
Nein, das würde ich auch mein Headset geben.
Aber Tim bastelt ja noch.
So, also, schauen wir mal wieder ein bisschen in die Historie der Sendung hier.
Wir befinden uns jetzt also im Jahr 2016.
Ziemlich krass. Das heißt also, die Brüche in der Crew waren...
Und Max hat die Freakshow verlassen. Das hieß nochmal bei Max, oder?
Das hieß nochmal bei Max.
Gerade so.
Das war 2012, war dein letztes Jahr. 2013 kam dann Clemens dazu.
Und dann im Jahr 2016 kam die Letty dazu. Aber ohne, dass irgendwer gegangen wäre.
Das heißt, das war wieder eine Zeit, wo wir dann wirklich eins,
zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Crewmitglieder hatten.
Genau, aber du hast vorhin erwähnt, dass Clemens bei allen Sendungen dabei ist.
Nein, jetzt nicht.
Bei sehr vielen auf jeden Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall darfst du in dieses Headset sprechen.
Ohne die Menü-Taste.
Wie hat denn da jetzt die Menü-Taste nicht gedrückt?
Ah, jetzt höre ich wenigstens Letty. Das ist für euch vielleicht nicht.
Ihr seid ja von der Sache. Hucke höre ich auch.
Wir machen hier so eine kleine eigene Frickshow.
Kannst du uns doch die...
Kurze Frage noch. Das Intro ist ja inzwischen in Stereo. Wir sind immer noch in Mono.
Ich muss jetzt mal in Mono.
Es ist 2025.
Wir sind nur in Mono.
Hallo Tim. Bitte willkommen, kein Herz, Kasper.
Bringt dir Stereo in Podcasts tatsächlich was?
Nö, aber ich darf zum Beispiel erstmal haben ein Stück mit weg sein.
Ich sitze hier noch immer.
Ja.
Ich höre sie auch. Man muss das einfach nur irgendwie mal auf dein Zentraldinkler überspielen.
Hört mich das Internet nicht.
Ah, warte mal, ich weiß warum. Sekunde, ich muss hier noch, ich muss dich noch,
ich muss dich noch. Entschuldigung.
Ihr müsst euch jetzt vorstellen, dass Tim auch einfach so in Kabeln so eingesponnen
hier durch den Raum springt.
Er hat den C64 aus dem Keller geholt, um ihn mit einzubinden.
Für sein Alter nicht schlecht.
Ruhe, Ruhe, Ruhe. Letty?
Hallo, Tim.
Hurra. Geile Stimme.
Wann war das letzte Mal jemand so froh, deine Stimme zu hören?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, hallo. Hallo, Tim. Haben wir jetzt alle oder kommt noch einer?
Jetzt, Tim.
Übrigens bin ich nicht Sauron, falls es hier... Ja, Marvin.
Oh, Dennis hat auf meine Nachricht reagiert von neulich.
Noch nicht? Nein.
Nein, aber ich springe in den Schicksals.
So, hören wir doch mal. Ich müsste, glaube ich, immer noch drauf sein mit meinem MacBook.
Hören wir doch mal genau über Bluetooth in die erste Folge rein.
Genau, und eine besondere Freude ist es uns.
Dass wir auch noch einen Gast dazu bekommen haben. Ich bin einfach wild von
der Straße geklappt. Unerhört. Ich bin gerade.
Vorbeigelaufen am Fenster. Wir haben gesagt, hier, komm mal gleich rein.
So läuft das. Ja, so ist das. So machen wir das immer eigentlich.
Muss man noch dein Mikro so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich höher, höher auch vielleicht.
Ja, du das geht nicht, das darf nur ich. Oh, besser? Oh, ja, ja. Hallo. Hallo.
Naja, also...
Schlechte Idee. Schnell auf die andere Straße.
Nein, sie haben mich gesehen.
Du kannst sie ja auch nicht weg, ne? Nee, das ist ungünstig.
Wir brauchen einen Hintereingang.
Naja, gut. Ich denke, weder du noch alle anderen werden es bereuen,
dass du hier bist. Das werden wir sehen.
Ja, ein bisschen müssen wir dich schon vorstellen, Letty. Du warst ja noch nicht
da. Nee, ich war noch nicht da.
Was möchtet ihr denn wissen? Naja, also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, du bist, äh, Nerd?
Aber das war, man muss es fürs Wort bekommen, das war bisher die beste Einführung.
Ich bin zu Wort gekommen, ja, niemand hat reingeredet.
Das war so eine Screw mit Beats.
Ich hab mir das auch in der Tat nochmal angehört heute, weil ich gesehen hatte,
du hattest reingepackt, welche Sendung wir als erstes drin waren.
Was möchtest du für Tim?
Also Tim, auch wenn du es gerade nicht in Eindruck machst, wir hatten ein internes
Planungspad, auf dem der ganze Masterplan dieser Sendung ausgeformt Alles bis auf Audio-Kanäle.
Wobei?
Plätze.
Jedenfalls, ich habe euch ja häufig ja schon hier irgendwie in der Meta-Ebene
überrascht, als ich irgendwie vorbeigeschneit kam und Tim immer,
ach komm, mach doch mal mit.
Ich hatte immer irgendwie, ja weiß nicht, ich habe mich da lange gesträubt und
an dem Tag habe ich aber, ich glaube, meinen Job gekündigt und mir war alles scheißegal.
Das hört man nicht.
Nee, ne? Das war ein guter excuse, um,
Einfach mal dabei zu sein.
Hören wir uns noch über die Lautsprecher gerade? Ah ja.
Huckel, den die Kohl dich da dran an.
Deutlich.
Ja, ja, ja. Okay, okay.
Ist das bei mir jetzt okay?
Bei dir ist es okay.
Bei mir ist es gut.
Huckel ist noch nachlässig.
Ja, ich bin hier mit der DJ-Kopfhörer-Haltung. DJ Huckel ist irgendwie...
Ja, ich weiß.
Das ist unoptimal. Hätte ja jemand mal Bescheid sagen können.
Hätte ja was einfallen lassen.
Ja. Jetzt haben wir es aber.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Die große Freakshow-Familie. Bis auf Dennis, der nicht...
Ich kann ein bisschen wädern.
Dennis Gedenk wädern.
Ja, also nochmal fürs Protokoll.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir es nicht versucht hätten. Ja, fehlt hier,
aber Dinge, Leben und so weiter.
Wir müssen jetzt mit dem arbeiten, was wir haben und es ist ja nicht so wenig,
was hier so rumsitzt. mittlerweile.
Für Tim ist es so viele Leute.
Also ich sehe da noch einen Anschluss.
Sag das nicht.
So, was erarbeiten wir uns denn jetzt? Jetzt, wo wir alle beisammen sind?
Also, wo wir alle beisammen sind. Wäre der Gedanke, dass wir vielleicht mal
einen gemeinsamen Blick werfen so auf die Themen, die wir denn hier so… Wir haben.
Glaube ich, noch nie zusammen gesungen.
Also, Clemens.
Wir tanzen sich übrigens kritisch mit diesen ganzen Kabeln hier.
Aber ich muss sagen, wenn mich jemand fragt noch zu Freakshow,
was jetzt nicht mehr so oft vorkommt, aber irgendwie kommt es ab und zu mal
nochmal vor und dann es darum geht, was war denn, worum geht es denn da,
was werden da für Themen gesprochen?
eine Folge, die mir immer noch in Erinnerung bleibt, in freudiger Erinnerung,
muss ich sagen, ist, wo es in der ersten halben Stunde der Sendung um,
Tango und Finish-Tango und Disco oder was auch immer irgendwie so ging und du aus,
also keiner von uns wusste, dass jetzt hier ein 30-minütiger Vortrag zum Thema
Tanzen kommt, aber wir waren alle dabei und das ist mir bisher,
bis heute in Erinnerung geblieben.
Und das ist auch das, was mich heute immer noch am meisten beschäftigt,
mehr als dieser ganze Internetquatsch.
Aber es ist eher Swing, ne?
Nö, wir sind da oben ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt auf dem Land.
Ich glaube, das fängt an, weil ich...
Das muss auch. Weil die, keine dieser Szenen, vielleicht außer der Tanga-Ontino-Szene,
kriegt eine kritische Masse zusammen. Ich nenne es immer kritische Masse.
Das heißt, du musst so viele Leute haben, die da immer kommen,
dass du auch mal ein Weihnachtsferien überstehst, ohne dass hinterher deine Szene weg ist.
Und das ist halt mit den Swing-Leuten, ist das immer so gerade an der Grenze.
Aber ich glaube, das fing an. Ich habe das, glaube ich, eingeleitet,
weil ich irgendwie so ein Video zu Finish Tango oder so gesehen hatte und dann.
War das so die Einsprungsmarke, wo eine ganz neue Seite von Clemens.
Der… Ja, wie gesagt, betreibe ich auch immer noch sehr intensiv da oben.
Eigentlich, das würde ich jetzt viel machen. Der Computerquatsch ist eh für den Fuß.
Ich hatte dich unterbrochen, Letty.
Genau, also das heißt, ihr tanzt dann jede Woche auch in der Tag?
Ja, aber viel. Und zwar so für den Spaß.
Also jetzt nicht so, ja, in Deutschland würde man meinen, wir hätten da längst
wieder zwei Vereine gegründet. Noch einen dritten Organisations-GmbH dazu.
Aber, nee, aber das ist halt so.
It's funny cause it's true.
Deswegen habe ich auch so, vorhin gesagt, hätte ich Mikrofone und Zeugs mitgebracht,
ich habe halt so ein mobiles Setup, womit wir auch richtig auf der Wiese spielen
können, das machen wir auch.
Oder im Stadtpark zum Beispiel in Neustrelitz, jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr im Dezember, aber sonst.
Also heute war es relativ frühlingshaft.
Heute war es sehr mit, hätte ich das gewusst.
Was Huckel gerade sagt, das würde ich nochmal unterstreichen.
Ich fand, die Freakshow, als auch ich selber noch lange nicht dabei war,
die hat immer dann vor allen Dingen gestrahlt, wenn es nicht so um diese klassischen
Technikthemen entgegen, sondern wenn irgendeiner von euch mit Leidenschaft am Thema am Start war.
Aber ich finde, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum also erstmal ist das einer
der Gründe, warum ich wollte, dass diese No Freak Show heißt und zweitens ist es ja nicht ein Computer,
Podcast, sondern es ist ja ein Nerd Podcast und Nerd Podcast heißt,
es geht um Themen, die Nerds interessieren.
Aber das sind ja nicht nur Computer, sondern Nerds haben ja einfach eine generelle
andere Herangehensweise an Technik.
Messerschleifen, Textilbearbeitung, Telekom erpressen, Tanzen,
was weiß ich, Motorradfahren etc.
Weil es ist einfach eine andere Sichtweise auf die Dinge und auf die Welt.
Das ist übrigens bei mir auch immer noch so, wenn ich auf einen Kongress gehe,
alle Jubeljahre mal, oder aufs Camp, wo ich eigentlich versiedelt mal bin,
ich gehe zu die Kaffeeleute und zu die Leute, die kochen.
Dass da auch ein paar Leute rumsitzen, die irgendwie einen Rechner haben,
ist schön, aber das ist irgendwie lame.
Also ich finde es viel spannender, diese sozialen Aspekte und eben,
was man heutzutage alles nerden kann.
Also was mich insbesondere daran interessiert ist, dass viele der Themen sind
ja welche, die waren früher der Industrie vorbehalten.
Aus diesen oder jenen Gründen. Diese Maker-Szene, wo Leute jetzt Sachen machen
vom selbstproduzierten Video, was aussieht, als hätte Hollywood gedreht,
bis wie gesagt hin zu, I don't know, Sticken, Weben, hast du nicht gesehen.
Holzbearbeitung finde ich so geil.
Holzbearbeitung, genau.
Irgendwelche Templates am 3D-Drucker für den Rauter geschrieben werden. Das ist so geil.
Ja, das finde ich total toll.
Wir können ja mal einen Blick darauf werfen, was sind die harten Zahlen sagen.
Ob wir diesen Themen genug Raum eingeräumt haben.
Wenn ihr jetzt hier das Dashboard aufhabt, dann habt ihr hier oben eine Navigation
und geht doch da mal auf Themen animiert.
Also man kann sich auch die Charts vorher angucken, wo auch schon so die Themen
in den Sendungen drin sind.
Aber das ist alles irgendwie sehr kleinteilig und finde ich ist nicht wirklich
aussagekräftig, weil dann da halt irgendwie so 1200 Themen drin sind.
Was meinst du jetzt mit Dashboard und Themen animiert? Ach, da oben.
Genau, Themen animiert. Also, was habe ich jetzt da gemacht oder machen lassen?
Ich hatte am Anfang schon gesagt, 1200 unique Themen in der Freakshow,
die habe ich erstmal klassisch clustern lassen.
Also, fügt die mal zusammen in Oberthemen. So, und dann wird eben irgendwie
das iPhone 5 ist dann dasselbe wie das iPhone 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
wird dann halt irgendwie weiter zusammen aggregiert in Apple-Hardware.
Da ist natürlich eine Menge drin, aber es hilft halt irgendwie,
da wir doch echt wirklich viele
Themen hatten, das Ganze irgendwie ein bisschen handhabbar zu machen.
Bei mir ist jetzt gerade Kryptowährung und Blockchain fast ganz oben.
Genau, was ich jetzt hier gemacht habe, Meta und Instagram und so weiter,
alles böse, aber wo ich wirklich ständig irgendwie minutenlang drin versinke,
sind diese Animationen,
wo irgendwelche Dinge über einen Zeitverlauf sich in Balken,
in Balken betteln, wer jetzt gerade...
Dieses tollen YouTube-Kanal, der irgendwie Operating Systems oder Bands oder
sonst irgendwas über so Zeit, das finde ich auch mal ganz gut.
So, und sowas habe ich jetzt mal für die Freakshow gebaut.
Oha!
Bauen lassen.
Bauen lassen, genau. Genau, also eigentlich hängt hinter diesen...
Von deiner chinesisch-lokal installierten AI.
Eigentlich ist dieses ganze Dashboard hier quasi der Datenvisualisierungsebene
Und nachher ist ein Plotty.js hinterlegt, so eins der Standard-Frameworks.
Aber für das, was ich jetzt hier haben wollte, hat das nicht gereicht.
Da habe ich gesagt, so schreibt das mal selber.
Und wie es halt irgendwie im Jahr 2025 so ist in 20 Sekunden,
war einfach mal die perfekte Implementierung da.
So, Tim, jetzt drück doch mal auf den Play-Button von Kategorien über die Zeit.
Und wir versuchen mal, also erstmal, wir sehen einen Zeitslider.
Der fängt an bei der ersten Sendung, wo überhaupt...
Warte mal, meinst du das hier?
Ja, genau.
Kommt da ein Audio?
Nee, da kommt kein Audio. Ach so, das heißt.
Wir sehen dann wieder was.
Genau, wir beschreiben es. Das heißt, geh mal vielleicht nicht auf den Play-Button,
sondern auf den Skip-Button daneben. Also quasi den einen Vorspring-Button.
Wir sehen denn, was ist denn diese Mono?
Wir sehen im Moment erstmal einen leeren Chart. So, und jetzt sehen wir,
dass also die Sendung springt jetzt ein weiter auf Folge 113.
Das ist die erste Folge, wo wir quasi in den Metadaten überhaupt so ein Thema
drin haben und dort ging es nur um Apple Software und Betriebssysteme.
Sagt der Aggregationsalgorithmus. Das war irgendeine Keynote oder sowas.
26. Januar, Entschuldigung, Juni bis wahrscheinlich WWDC? Ja.
Möglich.
Und Folge 113 von mir.
Und 2013 hatten wir noch Träume.
Oh ja.
Und zwar keine Albträume.
Zum Beispiel Mobilfunk-Support in meinem Mac.
So, das heißt also, wir haben jetzt nur einen Balken und der ist irgendwie lila
und der heißt Apple Software und Betriebssysteme und der kommt in einer Sendung vor.
Das ist das, was wir jetzt sehen. Und wenn du jetzt eine Sendung weiterspringst,
sind wir bei Folge 114 und da sehen wir, da hattest du Apple Hardware in die
Beschreibung reingetippt.
Das wird mit Sicherheit in dieser Sendung um viel anderes gegangen sein,
aber am Anfang musstest du dich noch etwas eingerooven, Tim,
was dieses Instrument anging.
Also ich habe reingehört, ich habe noch versucht, rauszudistieren,
die erste Folge, wo du zum ersten Mal mit Kapitelmarken experimentierst.
Das ist auch sehr schön, weil du noch so eine totale Unsicherheit transportierst
dabei. Und du hattest irgendwie im Vorfeld rumgefragt, wer das eigentlich will
und wer das nicht will und ob man das in einem separaten RSS-Feed drin haben
will oder alles gleichzeitig und so.
Du warst dir voll unsicher. Dann denkt man irgendwie so, okay,
zehn Jahre weiter, erzählst du irgendwie Marco Arment, der Junge,
komm mal klar, hier, ist das Einzige, was hilft.
Don't doubt the Germans.
Aber man könnte ja die ganz ich.
In England auf einer Konferenz.
Ja, wir haben halt irgendwie mal klein angefangen.
Was warst du?
Ich habe damals, also das war, muss die Zeit gewesen sein, war ich in England
auf einer Konferenz für Mac und iOS.
Ja.
Und dann, keine Ahnung, wir standen da in so einer Gruppe zu sechs,
sieben Leute und dann fing Marco Arment irgendwie so an zu ranten.
Ja, da, die Deutschen und hier und die Kapitelmarken und so.
Und dann holt der Luft und dann meinte ich nur so, ja, ich bin einer von denen.
Aber könnte man jetzt nicht die alten Folgen, die hättest du doch alle nochmal
durch eine LLM schicken können, um sie zu verschownoten nachträglich.
Also ich sehe in der Tat dieses Dashboard hier als den Beginn einer wunderbaren
Kooperation von Tim und mir, dass wir da vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen Grund reinbringen.
Weil ich habe in der Tat, als ich das gebaut habe, schon etliche Ideen gehabt.
Aber springen wir mal eine Sendung weiter, dann werden wir ja sehen,
jetzt kommt Gesellschaft und Politik dazu, auch scheinbar nur in einer Folge.
Wie gesagt, am Anfang ist das alles noch ein bisschen ruckelig,
aber je weiter man jetzt nach vorne klickt, kannst du das mal einfach,
es kommt noch Netzwerk und Internet hinzu.
Das fand ich interessant, künstliche Intelligenz, schon hier im September 2013.
Also das war noch deutlich vor neuronale Netze und ähnlichem und war schon früh Thema.
Ging es da um den Film oder?
Ging es da um Siri?
Gab es da schon Siri vielleicht oder so? Das ist ja Jahr 5 des iPhone.
Ich gucke gerade mal, wann ist das?
Oder Jahr 6?
Folge 117.
Echt?
So, du hast übrigens unten auch einen Episodenguide. Das heißt,
wenn du mal oben jetzt auf Episoden klickst, mach vielleicht das Fenster mal ein bisschen breiter.
Du kannst auch selber klicken. Ich meine, ich habe ja hier deinen Bildschirm,
habe ich ja hier auch noch. Also ich muss mich jetzt nicht so fernsteuern.
Ja gut, dann...
Tim lässt klicken.
Hey Siri, wie lange gibt es dich?
So, wir sind bei Folge 117.
Und wenn man oben in der Menüzahl auf Episoden klickt, hat man hier das komplette Episoden,
Archiv und da können wir quasi jetzt einfach hier mit einer Echtzeit-Drilldown-Suche
mal sagen, 117, zeig mir das mal an und dann sehen wir vom Ballmer Dance bis
zum Disco Fox alles dabei.
Das könnte die gewesen sein.
Disco Fox ist aber so ein Abgrund.
Wie heißt der? Ixi Kaxi?
Ixi Kaxi.
Was könnte denn jetzt hier von Solme KI sein? Von den Themen.
Weiter kann ich nicht.
Also ich muss sagen, das Thema Machine Learning und künstliche Intelligenz in der Folge, was war das?
117.
Müsste die 117 gewesen sein.
Machine Learning? Da gab es ja diesen Begriff damals noch gar nicht.
Ich finde da nix. Apple Keynote, Nachrichten aus dem Apple Land,
Android-Kennung. Doch, doch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir darüber gewählt haben als Machine Learning.
Vielleicht wollte sich die künstliche Intelligenz nochmal ins Gespräch bringen.
Ich habe da den Link gepostet.
Also ich würde schon sagen, wie auch Letty gerade schon anmerkt,
also Machine Learning gibt es schon ziemlich lange.
Es war halt alles noch im Vergleich zu jetzt ein bisschen Kinder-
Geburtstag.
Geburtstag, aber ging es schon los. Also da haben auf jeden Fall Leute sich
schon durch Daten gegraben.
Ich würde auch meinen.
Also wir hatten das in der Uni, wo unser Machine Learning, was war das denn?
Der war nicht Machine Learning Prof, aber der meinte irgendwie auch,
ja, es wird halt angewendet, um die Blitzerfotos auszuwerten.
Weil er irgendwie meinte, ja, die hätten das glaube ich für Blitzerfotos auch
benutzt, um die Nummernschöbel rauszufinden.
Er war sehr pikiert darüber, als er dann selber mal den Bußgeldbescheid bekam.
Wann sind da deine Datenquellen jetzt?
Habe ich ja am Anfang gesagt. Also die Datenquelle jetzt für diese Kategorien
Aggregierung sind die Untertitel der Sendung.
Die Untertitel?
Genau.
Also aus Bäumer Dance und Disco Fox hast du sozusagen Machine Learning abgeleitet?
Der Fall ist nicht so da.
Check's out. Diese Sendung, diese spezifische Sendung hat tatsächlich Kapitelmarken.
Und da kannst du genau sehen, worum es ging.
Ja, die werden noch, also das wird die nächste Entwicklungsstufe,
die Kapitelmarken mit reinzunehmen. Wie gesagt, die sind aber auch teilweise
sehr unterschiedlich von dir interpretiert, aber das lässt sich alles lösen.
Da ist auf jeden Fall kein Machine-Ming dabei.
Also das ist, seit gestern gibt es dieses Dashboard. Ja, ja, jetzt geht es mal raus.
Ich habe etliche Stichpunkte gemacht und die waren gut, weil die nächste beispielsweise,
ich bin jetzt mal bei Folge 120, da kommt zum ersten Mal Krypto und Blockchain hinzu und das stimmt.
Das heißt also, wenn wir jetzt unten mal in die 120 reingehen,
dann sehen wir, dass das mit Bitcoin-Hause stattfindet.
Was ist das?
Eine O's ist, wenn es den Aktien gut geht.
Okay, du siehst, ich bin nicht so ein Finanz...
Im Gegensatz zu einer Beiß.
Ich dachte, das heißt Bull Market.
Es gibt da auch so englische Bärenmarktes, aber die OS ist sozusagen das,
was man als bullisch bezeichnet heutzutage und eine BES ist,
was man Bärenmarkten bezeichnet, die französische.
Ich habe jetzt mal in die Echtzeitsuche der Episoden Bitcoin eingegeben und sehen wir jetzt die 120.
Es hat die erste Folge 2013 und dann gibt es aber noch 32 andere Episoden.
Ich musste mir sehr viele Folgen vorher über Bitcoin anhören. Tut mir leid.
Und das sind jetzt nur die, wo es halt in deinem Beschreibungsfeld drin steht.
Wenn man jetzt noch die Kapitelmarken mit reinnimmt oder die Shownotes, mögen es noch mehr sein.
Also das war definitiv ein breites Thema.
Das klingende zu wenig.
Ja, und damals war das ja auch irgendwie auch alles noch aufregend und wild.
Irgendwie interessant, weil es eben so komplex und so aus dem Nichts ist und
ja auch so ein komplett neues Thema für das Internet, so mit dem Geld und so.
Ja, und ich würde auch sagen,
Und abgesehen von allen validen Kritikpunkten, das ist immer noch,
finde ich, eins der interessantesten Real-Life-Experiments, was immer noch läuft,
weil das der absolut größtmögliche Honeypot für Attacken und Malicious Activity ist.
und es kaputt zu hacken oder aufzubrechen oder irgendwie zu dupen,
wie auch immer, ist eigentlich so mit der Market Capitalization,
wie gesagt, der größte Honeypot möglich,
den man sich so vorstellen kann und es ist einfach immer noch nicht kaputt gehackt
und immer noch am Laufen und ja, beliebter denn je könnte man sagen,
ob es jetzt gut ist oder schlecht ist, das sei dahingestellt,
aber ich fände es immer noch eine der spannendsten oder nicht spannend,
Aber irgendwie die faszinierendsten technischen Aspekte, die da so in diesem
Internet immer noch rumwabert.
Sorry, aber da gehe ich überhaupt nicht mit. Also technisch ist das Ding ja
nun wirklich schon lange auserzählt. Da passiert ja nichts.
Ja, aber es hält.
Aber die soziale Komponente ist tatsächlich sehr faszinierend.
Du meinst die asoziale Komponente.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Also das ist halt keine soziale Komponente und die kann halt so oder so.
Ich finde, das ist nach wie vor einfach irgendwie verrückt, dass es das immer
noch gibt und dass das immer noch läuft und dass da Leute immer noch trusten
und der Marktpreis nach oben geht und das einfach.
Die trusten nicht, die risken.
Ja, wie auch immer. Also irgendwie, es gibt.
Es gibt ja ganz viele unterschiedliche Leute mit unterschiedlichem Wissensstand.
Es gibt Leute, also ja, keine Ahnung, die wahrscheinlich von Bitcoin einfach
nichts eigentlich technisch verstehen, sondern nur so ähnlich wie Leute sagen,
ja, Gold ist sichere Anlage.
Und dann gibt es genug Leute, die sagen, ah ja, der Bitcoin-Preis und da, da, da, da.
Keine Ahnung, die einfach so mitlaufen und diesem ganzen Wahnsinn Futter bieten.
Aber das, das einfach, wie lange gibt es Bitcoin jetzt?
Naja, seit 20, was hat man geguckt? 2009.
Ich fände es krass, dass es immer noch da ist.
Ja, dass es immer noch nicht verboten ist.
Was ich am krassesten finde, dass es immer noch neues Kapital da ist,
was es abzugreifen gibt. Also immer noch Trottel, die noch Geld haben.
Um das da reinzuschmeißen.
Aber ich habe letztens ein längliches Video von diesem griechischen ehemaligen
Finanz-Varofakis, der so,
so ein 20-Minuten-Video darüber gemacht hat, wie Schulden und,
also dass die ganze Welt eigentlich dreimal mehr Schulden hat als das gesamte
Bruttosozialprodukt der Welt und wie dieses ganze,
dieses Schulden auf Schulden und Schulden verkaufen und in Schulden investieren
und so, wie das alles so funktioniert und das ist nicht weniger wahnsinnig eigentlich als Bitcoin,
wenn man es, so wird es eigentlich nur ein anderes Medium am Ende dafür,
für denselben Wahnsinn, aber...
Übrigens, kleiner Reality-Check, laut Kapitelmarken haben wir in dieser Sendung,
die du gerade angesprochen hast, nur 13 Minuten über Bitcoin geredet,
aber dafür über eine Stunde über macOS 10,
10, 9 Mavericks.
Das stimmt, da sollte die Länge der Themen definitiv mit eingehen.
Wenn die Kapitelmarken stimmen.
Kapitelmarken sind derzeit nicht drin im Datensatz, ist einfach so.
Ich finde, diese automatische Themenauswertung auch jetzt, wo ich weiß,
wie sie geschehen ist, gar nicht so spannend.
Also zum Beispiel, jetzt wo wir gerade hier so ein bisschen reminiszieren,
ich finde zum Beispiel, wo du gerade Mavericks sagst, die Folge,
wo wir glaube ich eine halbe Stunde über Snow Leopard Loblieder gesungen haben
und uns irgendwie in verschiedensten Folgen später noch gewünscht haben,
dass es mal wieder einen Snow Leopard Release gibt.
Wenn das nicht irgendwo ganz oben in der Tierliste drin ist,
da wäre ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehr enttäuscht.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in der Tierliste.
Es gab ja noch Mountain Lion, aber ich glaube, das ist das letzte Bugfix-Release gewesen.
Und das OS 27 soll jetzt genau so ein Release werden.
Was?
Ja, dringstödig. Er sagt die Gerüchteküche.
Solange mir diese scheiß runden Ecken wegkommen. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, letzte Woche erst darauf geupdatet und war direkt so, äh.
Wie kriegst du die Kotze wieder aus der Tastatur?
Zuckerberg hat uns doch gerade den Gefallen getan und hat den Typen,
der das verbrochen hat, bei Apple rausgekauft.
Ah, danke.
Und da war tatsächlich, ich lese ja nicht mehr Daring Fireball regelmäßig aber
durch irgendwelche Mastodon-Posts, ich weiß nicht, war es sogar Ralf oder so?
Nee, irgendjemand hat es gepostet. Ach nee, ich glaube einer von den Tapbots-Leuten,
meinte irgendwie, ja sieht so aus, als wären jetzt nicht alle böse,
dass der Typ Apple verlässt und hat dann so auf so einen Daring Fireball-Artikel
verlinkt, wo der John Gruber auch,
dazwischen den Weinglättern gelesen hat.
Der Nachfolger ist ausgebildeter UX-Designer. Man hört und staunt.
Aber ich glaube, da hatte der Gruber auch irgendwie was gesagt,
da muss man erst mal abwarten, ob der jetzt wirklich viel besser ist.
Aber zumindest scheint er in der Firma beliebter zu sein, als der Typ,
der jetzt weggekauft wurde.
Ich fand es halt ganz interessant. Ich habe kurz vorher, ich glaube einen Monat
vorher, einen Vortrag gehört, andere Sparte, aber aus der Gaming-Branche zu
UI und UX und wie man da an UIs rangeht, damit das halt in sich stimmig ist.
Und dann habe ich dieses Verbrechen an der Menschlichkeit betrachten müssen
und dachte mir so, können wir bitte ein bisschen mehr...
Einmal mit Profis, bitte.
Kannst du deinen Funktional kaputt nochmal anbauen?
Du hast es gehöre.
Ähnlich.
Also das heißt, ich update jetzt meinen Mac nicht. Guter Hinweis.
Ja, das ist, ich sag mal so, man gewöhnt sich an alles.
Und ich muss jetzt nicht jeden Tag, wenn ich den Rechner anlocke,
irgendwie gleich den Brechreiz bekämpfen.
Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, wer da was geraucht hat und warum und wie das sein kann, dass das,
approved wurde.
Also den Eckenradius, so neu kompilierte Apps haben einen größeren Radius an
den Fensterecken als alte Apps, sodass man dann, wenn man auch eine App im Fullscreen-Modus
hat, immer noch so das Fenster von dem anderen.
Das ist, das geht nicht mit meiner, mit meinem ADHS zusammen.
Also es ist, das ist...
Ja, und das wieder zu reparieren auch. Das wird ja dann umgekehrt genau das Chaos.
Ich benutze ja, mein Lieblings-Postgras-Client ist ja nach wie vor Postico.
und Postico hat so einen Update-Mechanismus, den man gar nicht mitkriegt.
Das macht es einfach so im Hintergrund, dann startest du die App wieder und dann neue Features.
Da, als dieses Update kam mit den runden Ecken, das habe ich leider sehr deutlich
gespürt und dachte mir, nein, die letzte Bastion der sinnvollen UI.
Also diese runden Tabs auch im Safari, als ich das gesehen habe.
Also wirklich, wirklich Apple.
Ich muss sagen, es ist mir immer wieder gerade ein inneres Blumenpflücken,
wenn ich meinen Thunderbird aufmache. Also so hässlich, wie er vielleicht für einige ist.
Du benutzt immer noch Thunderbird. Holy shit, okay.
Oh, Littie. Was denn?
Im Übrigen muss ich kurz mal anmerken. Ich hatte, wie gesagt,
die Folge, die erste, wo ich drin war, gehört.
Und ich hatte da noch einen Blackberry-Passport.
Oh ja.
Und ich musste nämlich neulich gerade wieder über die eingebaute Software-Tastatur
fluchen, als ich geschrieben habe.
Und dachte mir so, was wünsche ich mir mein Blackberry zurück.
Ja, fand ich ganz witzig.
Aber Blackberry Passport hatte auch schon keine physische Tastatur, oder? Doch, doch.
Das hatte die physische Tastatur und die war noch sensitiv, sodass du scrollen
konntest damit. Also wirklich großartig.
Okay, ich habe hier in der Zwischenzeit mal ein paar Folgen nach vorne wieder
gescrollt, hier in dieser Themenanimation.
Wir sind jetzt im März 2014 und wir sind relativ deutlich, okay,
das ist jetzt hier das Clemens-Zeitalter.
Netzwerk und Internet führt noch von den Themen her.
Sag deine KI-Auswertung von Untertiteln.
Die Tanzen zu KI gemacht hat.
Aber ihr könnt ja mal eure Lieblingssendung, also du hast ja jetzt schon angefangen, Ruckel.
Eine, die mir auf jeden Fall in Erinnerung geblieben ist.
Die Campsendung auf dem letzten, wo ich war, ich weiß nicht welches das war, 2019.
Wo auch Max mit dabei war.
Da haben wir auch mal wieder alle zusammen mit Trommel.
Die da waren auf dem Camp.
War das die mit dem Staubsauger?
Nee, aber Tim hatte einen ähnlichen Zusammenbruch wie heute,
weil er auch von nichts wusste.
Das ist immer das Gleiche, ja.
Weißt du, da überrascht man ihn. Man denkt, man würde ihm das gerade sagen.
Das Klemen auf mich zugekommen hat, hat mich reingeschummelt.
Es sind wieder zu wenig Mikrofone und so weiter. Das ist immer das Gleiche.
Ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, Tim, dass da nicht drauf gekommen bist. Entweder, also nee.
Wo drauf gekommen bin?
Spätestens nachdem Max durch die Tür ist.
Der einfach... Irgendwann ist halt alles vorbei.
Also ich finde auch, Tim, zumindest im Studio sollte man wirklich acht Kanäle haben.
Das du ich, also auch wenn man die nur fünf Prozent der Gesamtstudiozeit vielleicht
jemals braucht, aber irgendwie, also das finde ich.
Kannst du genug Kanäle haben?
Also acht ist schon, finde ich, ein Minimum.
Aber das Setup funktioniert ja jetzt gut, was du hier hast.
Das müssen wir ja mal sagen. Das geht so.
Nee, ich höre euch zum Beispiel immer noch, das Hören zwischen den Gruppen geht nicht.
Das liegt aber ein bisschen auch einfach mal an der Distanz im Raum,
die wir hier haben. Das heißt also, wir sitzen jetzt schon so weit auseinander hier in der Meta-Eden.
Die Strömlinge brauchen das ja.
Wir kommen ja auch da oben aus den Lautsprechern raus.
Das hörst du jetzt gar nicht, aber das ist überhaupt der Missing Link,
weil ich jetzt keine Chance habe, dieses Signal von uns wiederum da reinzubringen.
Wir haben ja Audioübertragung über die Luft.
Übrigens, weil ich hier jemand sehe, der im Chat den fehlkauf.bizling postet,
sehr großen Dank wir haben da auch was in Planung also spätestens zum nächsten Camp,
wird es da glaube ich nochmal was Schönes geben wir haben da,
da laufen schon Gespräche in der Führungsetage von fehlkauf.bizling.
Aber das.
Nur am Rande.
Gibt es denn jetzt ein, müsste demnächst schon mal wieder ein Camp um die Ecke
kommen, ne? Jetzt noch zwei Jahre oder drei Jahre?
Irgendwie so weit, keine Ahnung.
23 war das letzte, oder?
23 kann sein, ja. Beim letzten war ich tatsächlich nicht, aber unklar.
Ja, eins vor Corona und dann direkt als Corona vorbei war dann das nächste.
Das haben die abgesprochen, jede Wette.
Ja, mit Corona verhandelt, wie die Politik ja immer wollte. Da muss man doch
einfach nur ein bisschen flexibel sein.
Also zum Thema Lieblingsfolgen. Es ist,
also ich glaube, als Tim, Tim hat das mehrfach gehabt, aber der initiale mehrminütige,
Kalenderrand ist schon legendär.
Ne?
Ist einfach eine Legende.
Stimmt, wo sind da Thema Kalender hier?
Dieses Thema endlos durch den Kalender scrollen, das ist mir auf jeden Fall
auch Aber es ist gekommen.
Es ist gekommen. Ich hab's nicht für Möglichkeiten.
Darauf möchte ich auch mal drauf hinweisen. Ich mein, das ist so ein Meme geworden,
aber ich habe recht gehabt und sie haben es eingesehen.
Mehr muss ich dazu nicht sagen.
Dass nach Montag, Dienstag kommt? Ich weiß, ja, über die Monatsgrenzen hinweg.
Man ist so naheliegend.
Das war einer der Gründe, warum ich damals BusyCal gekauft habe.
Seitdem nie wieder benutzt, aber fand ich damals toll.
Oder Fantastical hatte ich.
Oh ja, genau.
Aber das, also wir waren ja da, das war kein unberechtigter Rand.
Du bist vielleicht, also vielleicht vom Effort-Level war das auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen mehr, als man vielleicht für Kalender sonst erwartet hätte,
aber es war berechtigt und wir sind dir alle sehr dankbar,
dass du Apple dazu bewegt hast, was zu ändern.
Aber könnte das nicht Grundhinder dieses Podcast sein, dass es vom Effort-Level
vielleicht ein bisschen geändert war?
Ja, aber es nützt was. Ich sag nur, funktional kaputt.
Jetzt haben wir keine Draufsänder.
Achso, ja genau, jetzt haben wir hier nämlich die manuelle Tierliste und,
Ich kann nicht alles lesen, aber meine Augen sind zwar noch ganz gut,
aber das ist auch auf die Distanz noch zu klein.
Ich sehe aber ein ZFS-Logo und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das das geilste Thema in der Sendung war,
aber ich muss sagen, ZFS nach all den Jahren ist immer noch mein persönlicher
Fallsystemstein in der Brandung.
Und zu dieser Tierlist, wir haben die aufgesetzt, also erstens finde ich,
die Themen sind noch ein bisschen diffus, weil WLAN und KI, also KI schon,
aber WLAN ist kein Thema.
WLAN ist ein Zustand, aber kein Thema.
Da hat sich ja was getan.
Da fehlen also jetzt Themen, sozusagen. Kalender hatten wir jetzt schon,
was wollte ich gerade sagen.
Outliner wurde noch vorgeschlagen aus dem Chat.
Achso, ja. Wir hatten uns vorhin darauf geeinigt, dass die Tierlist soll sozusagen
die Bedeutung des Themas für die Sendung ausdrücken.
Das ist sozusagen der Spin.
Mir ist noch eins eingefallen.
Oder für die Show eigentlich eher, nicht die einzelne Sendung.
Für die Freakshow, für die gesamte...
Für ganz Fundamentlevel. Wie lange wir den Tim versucht haben zu überreden,
endlich mal diesen Reaper auszuprobieren.
Und wie der sich wie so eine Katze vorm Wasch mit dem Türrahmen gespreizt hat.
Was hast du davor benutzt? Ableton? Oder was war das?
Ableton-Land.
Was nur zwei Stunden aufnehmen konnte. Und dann, also die Sendung,
wo dann endlich mal der Reaper zum Einsatz kam.
Das war auch so ein richtiger Halleluja-Moment. Für die Hörerinnen vielleicht
nicht so, aber können wir rausfinden, wann diese Umstellung war? Gibt das deine...
Auswertung her.
Nach drei oder so Ableton Runs war es dann soweit.
Das hast du ja mit Ultraschall gemacht und das war um meine ersten Auftritte in der Freakshow rum.
Achso, wir haben das erst gemacht, als es Ultraschall gab.
Ja, warte mal.
Ist es so spät erst?
Ich kann das relativ leicht rausfinden, indem ich einfach in mein Recording-Archiv
gehe, wann ich irgendwie angefangen habe. da.
Also ich hätte jetzt vermutet 2014.
Aber ja, es gab eine Prä-Ripa-Slash-Ultraschall-Zeit und die war steinig.
Also meine erste Freakshow war die 127, Number of the Dennis,
27.02.2014 und da habe ich erstmalig hier Ultraschall und Reaper vorgestellt.
Also Reaper hattest du schon viel früher.
Ich habe das ja von zwei Seiten. Max, eigentlich habe ich es von dir. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wie ich da drauf gekommen bin.
Du hast mir das damals rüber geworfen, guckst dir mal an und das hat dann ja
verfangen bei mir. Und in der Sendung war es dann, wie gesagt, Februar 2014.
Und das müsste auch so ungefähr die Zeit gewesen sein, Tim, wo du umgestellt
hast. Vielleicht einen Monat vorher oder so.
Aber ich bilde mir ein, dass ich da schon noch dabei war, als Tim sich umgestellt
hat. Und 2014 war ich definitiv nicht mehr dabei.
Da warst du nicht mehr dabei.
Also die 127 habe ich, glaube ich, noch mit Ableton aufgenommen.
Und die 128 nicht, habe ich mit Reaper aufgenommen.
Dann trage ich mich.
Ah, okay.
Dann war ich wirklich spät dabei.
Wann war 128?
2028.
2014 ist hier die 127.
Also die 128 ist 13.3. 2014.
Über elf Jahre jetzt schon.
Da steht es aber nicht in der Themenliste drin.
Ja, das war ja auch technisch.
Gut, das war aber nur so eine kleine Anmerkung, da müssen wir jetzt nicht zu
lange drin baden in dem Thema, aber das war auf jeden Fall auch noch so ein
Highlight, wo, also da dachte ich, wir kommen da nie hin.
The future is now.
Ja, ja, das war wirklich so ein...
Ja, was war dann noch diese skurrilen, irgendwie nach zwei Stunden,
weil irgendwie hat die Aufnahme gestoppt, ne, bei Ableton Live.
Ja, es war ja auch nie eine Software, die für Aufnahme wirklich konzipiert wurde,
das muss man fairerweise dem Ableton dazu sagen, aber...
So in dieser Live-Loop-Szene ist Ableton Live glaube ich immer noch das Ding.
Also da gucke ich auch immer ganz gerne Videos, wo Leute auf einem Billo-Midi-Keyboard
irgendwelche 80er-Songs nachbauen.
Da muss man jetzt auch mal Fürsprache leisten.
Also ich habe meinen allerersten Podcast bereits mit Ableton Live gemacht.
Also damit habe ich wirklich angefangen und es gibt meines Wissens auch bis
heute keine Software, die du schneller aufsetzen kannst.
Also das ist einfach dieses Konzept mit diesen zwei Screens und du tappst da
hin und her und das ganze Setup wie ein Mixer und zack, zack,
zack, zack, zack, das geht alles.
Ratze, fatze, das hat performt, das irgendwie ist auch nicht abgestürzt oder so.
Also das war schon, ich meine, die anderen haben, ich weiß nicht,
es gibt heute noch Leute, die arbeiten mit Audacity.
Oh Gott, oh, aber stopp.
Halt, hold your horses. Hast du dieses Video gesehen zu dem Audacity, was weiß ich, 2.0?
Jetzt nach 30 Jahren machen wir mal ein schönes User-Interface.
Ja, aber hast du das Video angeguckt?
Ich hab's ein bisschen angeguckt.
Glaube ich. Weil der ist wirklich geil. Also ich habe Audacity auch schon mal
benutzt und ich habe das, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es jetzt gerade auf dem Rechner
habe, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich glaube, ich habe keinen Anwendungsfall dafür gerade,
aber dieses Video so aus UI, UX Sicht war ganz, ganz, ganz großes Kino,
fand ich und ich freue mich, dass Audacity jetzt auch nach wie vielen Dekaden
auch immer so die Next Generation mal einläutet.
Fand ich gut, das Video, hat mir sehr gefallen.
Aber das gibt es noch nicht, die Software, ne?
Ich glaube, es gibt Early.
Hier Nightly Builds oder so.
Da reden wir mal drüber, wenn das tatsächlich funktioniert. Und außerdem User
Interface ist ja nur das eine.
Also ich meine, das, was sie da derzeit User Interface nehmen.
Aber er erklärt halt auch, warum bestimmte Quirks da drin sind und warum ihr
Spaghetti-Code, den sie halt früher da so immer drauf gestapelt,
noch einen Stapel drauf auf die kalten Spaghetti,
warum die Dinge so sind, wie sie sind und was sie tun, um das jetzt zu ändern.
Also auch das Refactoring davon.
Also es war so aus Software-Engineering-Sicht, fand ich das wirklich ein sehr cooles Video.
Ich glaube, die Geschichte hinter dem Video ist ja auch, dass als die ersten
Alpha-Versionen davon geleakt sind, also als die Leute die runtergeladen haben,
gab es einen gigantischen Aufschrei,
dass jetzt aus Audacity eine Digital Audio Workstation werden solle und dass
das ja überhaupt nicht dem entspricht.
sondern sind halt alle durchgedreht und das war so ein bisschen auch,
um die Leute zu beruhigen, hey, ihr könnt noch euren alten Workflow haben,
wenn ihr unbedingt wollt.
Keine Ahnung, warum man das soll, keine Ahnung, es gibt bestimmt sinnvolle Anwendungsfälle dafür.
Ich glaube, also ja, das Video lohnt sich wirklich in mehrerer Hinsicht zu gucken.
Wenn man in Audacity irgendwie investiert ist aus irgendeinem Grund,
dafür ist es hilfreich, um zu verstehen, ja, das wird jetzt nicht irgendwie
eine Digital Audio Workstation wie andere große Vergleichsprodukte.
und eben, wie gesagt, wer so User-Interface-Design und auch so Refactoring von
alten Codebases und so eine einfach ganz nüchterne, sachliche Analyse,
was haben wir für Scheiße vorher gebaut und wie wollen wir es jetzt gerade ziehen und so,
es war einfach richtig gut, richtig gut gemacht.
Also ich würde das in die Shownotes packen und jeder, der irgendwas mit Software
Engineering zu tun hat und sich vielleicht auch mit User Interfaces beschäftigt,
kann sich das ruhig mal angucken und überlegen, ob man über sein eigenes Projekt
oder die Software, an der man gerade arbeitet,
auch so sortierte und wohldurchdachte Gedanken hat.
So, jetzt können wir ja mal hier gucken. Oh, das ist einfach diese In-Shitification. Alter.
Kann man noch irgendwas irgendwie benutzen in diesem Internet,
ohne dass es einen gleich nervt wie Sau?
Tim, auch du musst sagen, worüber du sprichst.
Ja, ich spreche jetzt über das hier.
Achso.
Tim will den Newsletter nicht abonnieren.
So, warte mal, warum spielt das nicht richtig ab. Achso, weil ich das jetzt
hier auch noch, siehst du mal, man muss ja vorbereitet sein.
Und wir lauschen jetzt einfach mal hier dem Original-Lied zu diesem ganzen Thema.
Und danach hat es so lange gedauert, dich von Reaper zu überzeugen?
Na, es war halt Windows-Software.
Ich meine, hast du mal Reaper ohne Ultraschall aufgemacht?
Ja, ja, ich habe das jahrelang benutzt.
Ich benutze das nach wie vor ohne Ultraschall.
Ich bewundere das.
Ich konnte mehr als drei Stunden aufnehmen.
Entschuldigung, das geht einfach
nicht. Ja, also ich meine, das ist einfach... Es ist keine Schönheit.
Aber...
Das ist keine Schöne, das ist eine Beleidigung fürs Auge. Arbeit ganz grau.
Aber es hat keine runden Ecken.
Aber kurz, bevor wir da noch weitergehen, nochmal, das hatte ich ja irgendwie
auch überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Schirm, dass David diese ganzen Dinger da gemacht hat.
Also für den brauchen wir auf jeden, haben wir den schon hier nochmal gelobhudelt und bedankt?
Ralf hat versucht, den zu kontaktieren. Also Ralf hat ihn nicht erreicht.
Also ich habe drei Kanäle versucht, ihn zu halten. Ich weiß nicht,
ob er nicht will oder nicht konnte du das einfach nicht gelesen hast. Keine Ahnung.
Ich hatte Zeit, wenn du das hörst. Meld dich bei uns.
Nee, aber erst immer Danke. Da waren schon richtige Knaller dabei. Auf jeden Fall.
Gibt es eigentlich auch Freakshow das Live-Album?
Das machen wir jetzt gerade. Das wird hier live recordet.
Bist du mir ganz sicher? Deine komischen Nadel, da zucken wir gar nicht mehr
auf deinem Bildschirm da.
Was?
Doch, doch, da zuckt doch alles noch.
Das zuckt hier alles noch. die kleine Zahl da hoch zählt, das ist alles supi.
So.
Moderation.
Also ich kann ja hier als Thema nochmal reinschmeißen, was meine ersten Jahre...
Tim, hast du die Tür gerade gehört?
Ruhe.
Was die ersten Jahre hier geprägt hat, war ja Twitter. Also so dieses,
wir sind ja quasi mit Twitter hier eingestiegen und waren dann sehr abhängig davon.
Also wir, Tim und ich, Dennis überhaupt nicht.
Aber das war schon eine aufregende Zeit am Anfang. Und auch da,
oh mein Gott, was ist daraus geworden?
Also wie düster kann die Welt werden?
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin ein bisschen froh, dass das so kam,
weil ich habe wahnsinnig viel Lebenszeit drin investiert.
Das Lesen und selber auch Zeugs und tausende von Posten schreiben.
Und dann fing ja irgendwie an mit, ja nee, und dein Chatbot-Client ist jetzt
irgendwie kack und demnächst und kaputt.
Und dann ging das aus und dann ging es bei mir einfach nicht mehr.
Und dann alle Leute meinten, gehst du einfach zu Mastodon. Aber das habe ich einfach nicht gemacht.
Und nach den ersten Tagen, Wochen des Entzugs von so Zeugs fiel mir dann auf,
boah, hast du Lebensqualität gewonnen.
Mehr Zeit zum Tanzen.
Genau, nicht bloß dazu, sondern auch zu anderen Dingen, anderen schönen Dingen.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt echt ganz froh, dass unter meinem Tabboard weggestorben
ist. Sage ich jetzt mal so.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich habe dieses, naja, dann gehe ich jetzt auf Mastodon
und dann war ich da eine Weile und irgendwann ist mir aufgefallen,
oh, du hast das vier Wochen schon nicht mehr aufgemacht.
Und dann weitere vier Wochen später, oh, du hast es schon wieder vier Wochen
nicht aufgemacht und jetzt ist irgendwie...
Ich benutze Mastodon fast.
Ist halt aufgestorben.
Nein, nicht ganz so schlimm.
So Blue Sky habe ich irgendwie nie ein Draht gefunden, keine Ahnung wieso.
Und das ist jetzt einfach alles weg.
Und das ist auch gut so.
Ich nutze Mastodon und ich nutze es auch relativ gerne, aber es ist sehr angenehm,
dass es eine Software ist, die einen nicht probiert, da reinzuziehen,
sondern dieses, was ihr schon sagt, man kann es zumachen und kann es einfach
vergessen und kann es für ein paar Tage nicht aufmachen und es ist okay und
man wird nicht mit irgendwelchen Push-Notifications oder sowas wieder reingezogen.
Das ist sehr, sehr angenehm, das stimmt.
Ich hätte ja ein Thema, eine Frage, die mich tatsächlich sogar,
also jetzt interessiert sogar, die vielleicht nichts mit der Tierlist und vergangenen
Themen zu tun hat, haben wir dafür überhaupt,
es gibt es, kann ich da kurz mal reingreden, weil wir gerade bei so alternativen
Kommunikationsmedien sind,
weil jetzt ja auch hier immer wieder diese Chatkontrolle frisch aufgewärmt wird
und angedroht wird und so weiter und dann wieder doch nicht und so weiter.
Da habe ich mich ja umgeschaut, was denn wäre, wenn die dann kämen und Signal
und Threema und so sich zurückziehen.
Und habe ja, alle Wege führen nach Rom, nein, alle Wege führen zu E-Mail,
mich sehr in Delta-Chat konzeptionell verliebt.
Hand hoch hier in der Runde, wer hat denn schon mal ein Delta-Chat installiert?
Was ist das?
Delta-Chat ist der beste Kryptomessenger, den du dir vorstellen kannst,
denn er basiert auf E-Mail.
und den guten Teilen von OpenPGP, also alles bekannte, abgehangene Standards
und du hast halt einen Messenger, eine Messenger-App wie alle anderen Messenger
und du kannst einen Mail-Server nehmen, der einigermaßen vernünftig TLS spricht.
Und der kommuniziert über Mail-Server und macht Instant-Messaging mit Mail-Server
in End-zu-End verschlüsselt auf basierenden Standards.
Alle Wege führen zurück zu E-Mail und ich finde es total großartig,
weil es ist halt ein Messenger, ein Krypto-Messenger, der federated sozusagen ist.
Und ich bin ja sowieso großer Fan von E-Mail, weil es irgendwie das älteste...
Nein, Lettis ist keine Audio-Störung, ich knurre wirklich.
Ich versuche herauszufinden, ob es ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Knurren ist.
Noch ein bisschen in der Nachdenklichkeit-Phase.
Wenn ich neben ihm sitze, wirst du ruhig die Frage ausstellen.
Ich habe ja mal einen IMAP-Sauer geschrieben und jetzt überlege ich gerade,
wie der sich da fühlen würde, wenn man das mit ihm machen würde.
Das Ding ist, alles was SMTP, IMAP, das ist alles so, solange du da den Standard sprichst, alles gut.
Das Einzige, was dein Mail-Provider oder dein Mail-Server können muss,
ist vernünftig TLS sprechen, um dieses End-zu-End und Perfect-Dingsbums zu machen.
Aber genau, das hat man ja als korrekter Mail-Server-Betreiber natürlich.
Aber es geht halt auch auf Gmail oder auf sonst was.
Also du musst ja nicht einen extra Mail-Account oder einen Mail-Server aufsetzen
oder sonst was, sondern solange dein Mail-Provider ordentlich Krypto spricht,
macht dann Delta-Chat den Rest und ich muss ich finde das so geil,
dass es einfach auf E-Mail implementiert ist.
Aber keiner von euch hat bisher Delta-Chat ausprobiert, installiert.
Ich hänge immer noch an der Frage, was denn die guten Teile von KnupiG sind, aber gut.
Naja, den Teil, wo du dich nicht um deinen Keyring kümmern musst und also weißt du, dieses Ganze,
was Signal und Threema sozusagen völlig weg abstrahiert haben bei dem End-to-End-Verschlüssel
mit dem Key-Handling und du installierst ja den kleinen, du machst einen frischen
Key, hast einen QR-Code, kannst den scannen,
kannst gegenseitig die Keys verifizieren, wenn du es als ultra wichtig willst,
ultrasicher willst, wichtig vielleicht auch.
das ist in Delta-Chat genauso abstrahiert, also die Convenience ist quasi auf
demselben Level nur, dass das Transportmedium federated und,
bekannte Standards sind und nicht irgendwie proprietäre Protokolle von irgendwelchen
Firmen, die am Ende auf Amazon oder auf Cloudflare hosten und dann down sind,
wenn da gerade mal wieder jemand die DNS-Config verkackt hat.
Ja, aber das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Mail-Provider habe,
der immer noch auf dieses unsägliche Graylisting steht, dann habe ich jetzt
plötzlich einen Chat-Client, der so im 20-Minuten-Takt Nachrichten austauscht oder so, ja?
Naja, wenn du dein Graylisting richtig konfiguriert hast, dann passiert das
ja höchstens bei der ersten Mail.
Aber wie ist denn da die Latenz dann wirklich? Also ist das dann chatty,
was da rauskommt? Weil das finde ich ja schon...
Also es ist halt...
Sagen wir mal so, es ist überrascht, also auf meinem Mail-Server und mit den
Leuten, mit denen ich so bisher das ausprobiert habe,
ist es ausreichend schnell, weil selbst bei Signal habe ich das teilweise so,
dass ich manchmal auf einer Uhr kriege ich die Push-Notification und gucke ich
in den Client, da ist aber noch gar keine Nachricht da.
Dann dauert das so ein paar Sekunden, dann kommt die da auch an.
Also sagen wir mal so, es ist nicht schlechter als iMessage oder andere Messenger,
wenn es darum geht zu synchronisieren. Also es ist halt wie iMap.
Sobald die Message in deiner Inbox ist, hast du die auf allen Clients halt auch da.
Hast du so einen kleinen Indikator, der andere tippt gerade was?
Das finde ich auch mal ganz hilfreich.
Das weiß ich gerade. Wenn du jedes Mal dafür eine Nachricht erzeugst.
Meine ganz andere Frage, wenn du sagst Chatkontrolle und so weiter.
Und die Macher sind sich sicher, dass sie dann nicht unter dieses Gesetz fallen?
Das Ding ist, also was ich dann noch dazu sagen würde, zum Thema Chatkontrolle,
wenn du so krass wichtig sensitive Sachen zu besprechen hast,
mach es eh nicht mit dem Computer.
Dann fahr mit dem Paddelboot auf dem See oder geh in einen Waldspaziergang machen.
Aber das muss deine persönliche Obsektoren irgendwie und dein persönliches Paranoia-Level
dann vielleicht auch nochmal moderieren.
Aber wenn es nur darum geht, ich will jetzt einen Messenger haben,
der nicht von allen Leuten, die da im Internet kurz mal zuhören,
mitgelesen werden kann, fände ich es auf jeden Fall eine witzige Idee,
die auch im Zweifel funktioniert.
Und weil du dann halt eben, wenn du zum Beispiel deinen eigenen Messenger machst,
dann würdest du ja nicht theoretisch unter diese Chat-Kontrolle Provider-Dings bauen.
Du musst die Fireworks nicht in den Client einbauen, das ist ja die Idee.
Du kannst ja selber einen Client bauen, weil das halt gar kein proprietäres
Protokoll ist, sondern nur IMAP, SNTP und OpenPGP.
Und ich kann es euch wirklich nur empfehlen, selbst wenn ihr euch das nicht
installiert und nicht benutzt, aber die FAQ auf der Delta-Chat-Seite,
wo sie wirklich jede Frage, die ihr jetzt habt im Kopf...
Haben die da beantwortet? Ziemlich sicher, weil bisher war es so,
dass wenn mich Leute gefragt haben, ja, aber was ist das und wie ist das?
Gehe in die FAQ, diese Frage steht da schon und wird da umfänglich beantwortet.
Read the fucking matter.
Oder FAQ in dem Fall, ja. Okay, gut, damit ist meine Frage beantwortet.
Niemand hat die Frage beantwortet.
Ich kann aber kurz noch mal einen passenden Rant draufschmeißen.
Ich hab neulich nach Jahren mal wieder mein iPhone gewechselt und aus irgendwelchen
Gründen hab ich da ein Signal-Client drauf.
Ich hasse dieses Programm, weil es einfach nur ein Signal ist.
Signal, okay.
Ich hasse dieses Programm, weil es halt einfach unsäglich nervt mit seinem Datenschutz und hier.
Und hast du da den Key und dein Kumpel hat einen neuen Key und bitte und verifiziere, aber egal.
Aber das ist doch alles drei Dimensionen einfach als Streamer oder Matrix.
Der Witz ist, der Scheiße funktioniert nicht. Ich musste irgendwie vier Anläufe
machen, um den Single-Client rüber zu kriegen, um meine Chats und meine Kontakte zu halten.
Bei der Migration des Handys, okay.
Dafür, dass jeder sagt, benutze Single, benutze Single, das ist der Geize-Client.
Ich denke immer, ja, aber habt ihr niemals neue Telefon, oder hat jemand mal
diese Migration ausprobiert?
Clemens, das ist so.
Clemens, das funktioniert so.
Das erste Mal, wenn man Telefon wechselt, loost man seine History und beim zweiten
Mal erinnert man sich da dran und macht vorher den... Darum geht's nicht.
Das hat ja diese Migrationsfunktion und die gibt's nicht erst seit zwei.
Die gibt's schon länger.
Nein, es gibt seit zwei Wochen die Backup-Funktion.
Backup-Funktion? Ich hab mein Telefon von vor, vor zwei Wochen gewechselt.
Aber ich sag nur, das war ein Schmerz ohne Ende.
Es dauert Stunden, diese Übertragung zwischen den beiden Telefonen.
Stunden, obwohl ich gar nicht so viele Chats und Dinger da drin habe.
Und bei 99% bleibt da stehen, um dir dann nochmal zu sagen, das war's jetzt leider.
Und wenn du dann Glück hast, kriegst du noch ein zweites Mal angestoßen,
sonst ist einfach alles weg.
Und ganz ehrlich, dafür, dass alle Welt schreit, benutze Signal, denke ich, Leute, why?
Das ist halt der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, der nicht WhatsApp ist.
Nee, der wäre Telegram.
Mein kleines Mal ist immer noch Telegram, weil er einfach funktioniert.
Aber Telegram ist beim Wechsel auch übel, wenn ein anderer...
Mein Messenger ist besser als deiner.
Naja, genau.
Und es ist halt dieses alte Spannungsfeld von Convenience und Security.
Das muss ich euch eigentlich sagen.
Wenn ich Security haben will, dann fein. Aber solange ich keine Revolution ans
hätte, möchte ich gerne Telefon wechseln können.
Warst du, machst du es nicht?
Keine Revolution ans hätte. Nee, ich hab mich angestellt, aber war voll.
Achso.
So, weitere Lieblingsfolgen. Wer hat noch was oder Themen?
Ich würde ein Schmerzthema von Tim mal anbringen.
Noch eins?
Er hat schon so viel gelitten heute. da kommt es auf einen mehr nicht an.
Ich sage nur Buchhaltung.
Schmerzthema? Wieso das Schmerzthema?
Das war mal schmerzhaft.
Aber für uns.
Ich kenne jemanden, der das sogar gut findet.
Das kann ja sein, aber jeder hat so seinen Kink und man soll ja auch keinen
Kinkschänzen betreiben.
Aber ich erinnere mich da wirklich an stundenlang und ich habe noch ein Foto
irgendwo von dir, wo du dann auch noch zusätzlich darüber rantest,
dass du Post geschickt bekommst und du sie einscannen musst.
Darf ich mal zum Thema Buchhaltung was sagen? Tim hat mir bei der Buchhaltung
sehr, sehr geholfen und mir das Leben gerettet und ich werde ihm ewig dankbar sein.
Und ich bin danach nach Hause gegangen und habe das meiner Frau erzählt und
die hat dann irgendwie so, ja und...
Will er jetzt Geld dafür oder sowas? Nee, das macht ihm Spaß.
Und dann...
Da ist ihm misstrauisch geworden.
Sie konnte es nicht glauben.
Und ein paar Tage später haben wir ihn in einem Park getroffen,
zufälligerweise. Und er kommt auf mich zu mit freudestrahlendem Gesicht.
Und hast du schon deine Steuererklärung gemacht?
Und dann ging wir dann irgendwann weiter.
Zu zweit. Und sie so, das macht mir wirklich Spaß. Als ob sie einen Mörder gesehen hätte.
Es ist auch wirklich erschreckend, wenn man Tim dann trifft so um den 1. Januar herum.
Das ist wirklich erschreckend.
Machst du es immer noch selbst? Komm, jetzt. Hosen runter.
Was?
Machst du es immer noch selbst?
Na klar. Als ob Tim da jemanden ranlassen würde. Ich lasse mal eine Buchhaltung ran. Wie wahnsinnig.
Also Tims Buchhaltung ist fantastisch,
falls ihr euch jemals selbstständig macht. Nutzt die Gelegenheit.
Ich habe bisher auch nichts Schlechtes gehört.
Also ich bin ja definitiv Team Letty. Das ist einer der wenigen Momente,
wo ich wirklich froh war, dass es gute Kapitel machen.
Ich muss sagen, mich hat das auch nie so interessiert,
aber ich habe vorletzten Kongress oder letzten Kongress gab es einen Talk zu
Dokumentmanagementsysteme und da wurde Paperless gefeatured und seitdem bin
ich auch auf jeden Fall sehr viel,
digital an meinem Bürokratie-Management und Papierkram und so weiter.
Es gibt ja in diesem komplexen Feld, man muss im Wesentlichen drei Dinge,
unterscheiden.
Ich glaube, ich muss weg.
Das eine ist die Digitalisierung der eigenen Vorgänge.
Da könnt ihr mir jetzt mal nicht erzählen, dass das für euch kein Thema ist oder sein sollte.
Also alles sozusagen zu digitalisieren und nicht auf Papier durch die Gegend
zu führen und irgendwie mit einem Blick sämtliche Belege suchen zu können,
ist definitiv, glaube ich,
unstrittig in dieser Runde. Ein absolut interessanter Punkt.
Weitestgehend, ja.
Genau. Dann gibt es noch den anderen Bereich, das ist der, den alle hassen und
das auch aus gutem Grund.
Das ist nämlich die Interaktion mit dem Staat. Mit seinen übermäßigen,
komplexen Steuergesetzen, undurchsichtigen Verordnungen, Durchführungsverordnungen
und so weiter, dem Gebaren des Finanzamts und dann halt, was irgendwie Nerds
generell nicht so mögen, so Termine,
Deadlines, Drohungen und so weiter.
Und das ist natürlich scheiße, gehört aber eher so in diesen Bereich Widerstand.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Revolution.
Naja, ich meine, wenn du, guck mal, wenn ihr ein schönes Leben führen wollt.
Ich führe eins, Ja.
Du möchtest ja aber auch dabei bleiben. Also du möchtest ja sozusagen,
dass dieser Zustand auch anhält.
Aber immer wenn sozusagen das Steuerthema kommt, dann gehst du auch schon so
ein bisschen und schrumpfst so zwei Zentimeter von jeder Seite so ein bisschen nach innen.
Eigentlich nicht, aber okay.
Das kommt auch immer mal wieder zwischendurch, wenn man so ein bisschen die Dinge schleifen lässt.
Aber ich verstehe das halt sozusagen als Hacker-Disziplin.
Also da hast du so ein System, das will dir irgendwie sagen,
wie du dich zu verhalten hast und es hat irgendwie eine komplizierte API und keiner versteht das.
und sich das aber so ein bisschen zu erarbeiten und damit auch so ein bisschen
den Schauer davon zu nehmen, die Bedrohung rauszunehmen, das ist so der zweite
von diesen drei Aspekten.
Und dann gibt es in der Mitte noch den eigentlichen Buchhaltungsaspekt.
Und Buchhaltung selber, also jetzt wirklich nur die eigentliche Buchhaltung,
doppelte Buchführung, Kontenrahmen und so weiter, das ist schon geil,
weil es ist einfach eine super einfache...
Für die Hörerinnen, Body schlägt die Arme über den Kopf zusammen.
Ja, ich meine, es ist eine Informatikanwendung, die 400, 500 Jahre alt ist. Die ist gut abgehangen.
Also das ist wirklich, das haben die Italiener sich mal einfallen lassen,
dann haben sie hier so die Fugger und so weiter auch so richtig durchgezogen
und das ist eine Kulturtechnik, die kann man erlernen,
die ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne schwierig und vor allem deshalb so erfolgreich, weil sie in...
in sich, in ihrer Struktur einfach ist, simpel ist.
Du willst also sagen, doppelte Buchführung ist quasi wie Töpfern oder Brotbacken oder Basic-Lernen.
Kultur, Althergebrachtes. Kultur einschalten, genau.
Immaterielles Kulturerbe.
Was hat uns Venedig gebracht?
Ich hoffe, ich zitiere Tim richtig. Er hat mir damals erzählt auch,
dass er hin und wieder mal von Steuerberatern irgendwas kriegt und dann hat
er den für mich sehr denkwürdigen Satz gesagt.
Den ich niemals aus Tims Mund vermutet hatte.
Ja, und dann gucke ich mir das an und denke mir, das ist aber nicht schön gebucht.
Das ist scheiße, was die machen.
Wurdest du schon mal vom Finanzamt gelobt für deine...
Oh, noch besser. Gehasst.
Weil du zu gut bist.
Weil sie nichts gefunden haben.
Achso, hattest du Steuerberater?
Weil ich auf alles eine Antwort hatte, weil ich ihnen irgendwie so,
ja, aber jetzt schicken sie mir aber das doch mal, das doch mal, kein Problem.
Und dann habe ich immer so 300 Seiten ausgedruckt und dann war dann immer Ruhe.
Immer wenn sie denken, so jetzt haben sie mich, so ja, aber die Reisekostenabrechnung,
Herr Pritzler, die Reisekostenabrechnung, ja.
kriegen sie ihre Reisekostenabrechnung. Und das ist eine Reisekostenabrechnung,
die hat sich gewaschen. Da steht wirklich alles drin.
Und damit hebelst du es halt auch irgendwie aus. Und um es irgendwie so zu machen,
muss man eigentlich nur so ein bisschen Routine haben und man muss halt wissen,
womit man es zu tun hat. Aber das ist dann eigentlich auch alles.
Also für mich ist es so ein bisschen wie Programmieren lernen.
Das ist einfach eine Kulturtechnik.
Und die ist ganz praktisch, weil sie ja eigentlich alle betrifft.
Es wird natürlich jetzt schwierig durch die Entschertification Und vor allem
durch neue Gesetze, die immer wieder verschärft werden.
Also wenn du so jetzt eine GmbH hast oder so, dann hast du fast gar keine Chance mehr.
Also musst du eigentlich einen Steuerberater nehmen, weil die Sache zu kompliziert wird einfach.
Auch so Lohn wird dann einfach schnell unübersichtlich, da kann man auch sehr viel falsch machen.
Man muss sich sehr reinarbeiten, aber vor allem kommen jetzt immer so vorgeschriebene Digitalformate,
da musst du APIs benutzen und dann ist immer die einzige Software,
die du nehmen kannst, ist am Ende dann irgendwie DATEV und dann musst du da
quasi Großauftragsoftware einkaufen und für tausende Euro mieten und da bist
du natürlich dann irgendwie raus.
Also die Zeit von so deiner eigenen Buchhaltungssoftware auf dem Computer könnte
irgendwann vorbei sein, aber jetzt geht's gerade noch.
Aber ich würde hinter einem Satz, den du gerade gesagt hast,
dann doch mal ein Fragezeichen setzen. Dieses so, es geht halt alle was an oder es betrifft halt alle.
So, ich bin halt einfach mal angestellt, habe im öffentlichen Dienst und in
meinem Leben findet Buchhaltung nicht statt.
Ja, nee, Moment, stopp. Nee, da gehe ich nicht mit.
Ich würde nämlich zum Beispiel, also ich bin der, ich habe schon mehrfach den
Gedanken gehabt, dass es eigentlich ein Skandal ist, dass man das nicht in der
Schule lernt, Und mit diesem ganzen Staat-Interface umzugehen und Finanzamt
und Steuern und Buchhaltung und so.
Ich fände, das wäre auf jeden Fall in der Schule total hilfreich,
weil so viele Leute sich damit null beschäftigen und dann irgendwann in irgendeine
Scheiß-Situation reinlaufen, weil sie sich halt nicht gekümmert haben,
weil sie es nicht besser wussten.
Und das ist was, was jeden angeht. Und selbst wenn du nur angestellt bist,
wenn du nicht eine Steuererklärung machst, verschenkst du halt Geld.
Aber meinst du, Ralf redet von Buchhaltung? und du redest von solchen Steuern.
Genau, das ist was anderes. Aber auch da, wenn du halt nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen den In- und Out
Put-Flow oder wie auch immer man das nennen will, so im Blick hast oder irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Ich finde schon, dass es einen Wert hat, sich damit mal zumindest oberflächlich
wenigstens beschäftigt zu haben und zumindest zu dem Punkt zu kommen,
wo man selber eine, wie sagt man,
eine Entscheidung, eine informierte Entscheidung treffen kann,
ob man sich damit beschäftigen will oder nicht.
Ich muss da kurz einhaken. Ich habe das in der Schule gelernt.
Oder ich sage mal, man hat versucht, es mir in der Schule beizubringen.
Ich habe es nicht wirklich gelernt, aber es war mal Stoff.
Es gibt Schulen, also in bestimmten Schulformen, die jetzt vielleicht nicht
unbedingt das Gymnasium sind. War Gymnasium.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Wirtschaftsabitur kann man ja machen.
Ja, aber du hast es eher in anderen Schulformen.
Ich musste die Lektionen alle hart im Leben selber lernen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube zu dem Zeitpunkt interessiert einen das auch zu
wenig. Das ist ja generell das Problem mit Schule.
Es müsste einfach nur, weiß ich nicht, einen anderen kulturellen Nimbus haben.
Dazu wollte ich beitragen.
Also Leute, man kann Spaß haben, bezahlen.
Ich muss Tim da ja auch recht geben, weil ich habe auch so ein paar Sachen in
den Finanzthemen, wo ich sage, also wenn man sich mal ein bisschen so reinliest,
wo einfach interessante Konzepte dabei sind. Also Tim ist ja selbstständig,
ich bin selbstständig, vielleicht von unseren Hörerinnen auch.
Ich weiß nicht, da kommt man so, Clemens guckt schon so, als hätte ich einen
schlechten Kink, aber vielleicht ist es ein schlechter Kink.
Aber es gibt dann so Momente, wo man sich denkt, das ist gut.
Wie zum Beispiel?
Also an dem Punkt komme ich nicht. Aber früher war ich selbstständig und habe
mich dann in die Festanstellung begehen.
Und der Hauptgrund dafür war, dass ich meine Finanzen nicht auf den Griff gekriegt habe.
Und diese Freiheit aufzugeben als Selbstständiger, die doch eine große Freiheit
ist, klar, ein höheres Risiko, hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile,
aber für mich war die Festanstellung eigentlich nie so richtig geil.
Und jetzt in der Situation zu sein, dass ich meine Finanzen im Griff habe,
und das ist halt ein Cost of Doing Business. ist.
Ich mache das halt brav jeden Tag, meine Buchhaltung fünf Minuten lang und dann
habe ich es hinter mir und ich habe das eine Zeit lang, also als ich angefangen
habe, habe ich mich auch mit Tim darüber unterhalten und er wollte mir sofort die Buchhaltung.
Ich habe, nee, ich hole mir einen Steuerberater. Das ist mal alles gut.
Und dann zahle ich denen dann irgendwie 200 Euro im Monat, damit ich denen eine
Tabelle rüberschicke, die sie mir dann scheiße formatiert wieder zurückschicken und mit wirklich,
massenhaft Fehlern drin und nichts erklärt wird.
Das ist eine Aura.
Es tut mir auch echt leicht.
Dass ich das Thema angesprochen habe.
Thema Steuerberaterin. Ich habe eine Steuerberaterin. Die hat das auch irgendwie
die letzten Jahre. Du bist angestellt.
Du hast aber auch gar keine Probleme.
Wir haben jetzt nur eine sehr einfache Situation. Trotzdem ist uns unsere Lebenszeit
zu knapp und zu wertvoll mit irgendwie zwei Kindern, jadda jadda,
das noch alles irgendwie nebenbei selber zu machen.
Ich versuche es seit sage und schreibe eineinhalb Monaten,
ihr die Dokumente von unserer Steuererklärung überhaupt zur Verfügung zu stellen.
So, ich habe die also auf meine Nextcloud hingeladen, irgendwie,
mit großem Download-Button.
Kann sie nicht runterladen. Ich habe es ihr irgendwie als Zip Archive auf Nextcloud
hingeladen. Hat nicht funktioniert. Ich habe es ihr bereitgestellt.
Apple hat jetzt so eine Funktion, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt.
In der Zeit hattest du es dreimal deine Steuererklärung selber gemacht.
Ich habe ihr am Ende angeboten, sie auf dem USB-Stick vorbeizutragen.
Ja, weil die hier auch irgendwo in der Gegend ist so.
Das führt alles nicht zum Ziel. Und das Letzte, was ich von ihr gehört habe,
oh, jetzt ist es ganz, ganz schwierig. Sie hätten ihr Microsoft-System aktualisiert.
Seitdem könnt ihr jetzt leider überhaupt gar nichts mehr irgendwo runterladen.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe eine Steuerberaterin, die sehr neuerkompatibel ist
und gerade in der Berliner Szene so einige Nerd-Vereine, also so, weiß nicht, Ruby e.V.
und auch so alle Leute, die Konferenzen und so organisieren,
betreut, die also sehr in diesem Nerd-Modus selber auch drin ist und kompatibel
ist und mit der habe ich überhaupt gar keine Probleme, die macht alles super
und ich kriege immer mehr,
wieder, als ich ihr bezahlen muss und dann...
Das ist übrigens der alte Spruch gewesen, schon vor Jahrzehnten ein guter Steuerberater
kostet dich weniger, als das er dir bringt und insofern.
Aber die hat leider also es gab auch schon viele Leute, die gerne bei ihr auch
sozusagen ein Kunde werden wollten, aber sie ist ausgebucht mittlerweile und
es ist wohl auch schwer, habe ich gehört,
gute Steuerberaterinnen zu finden.
Und wenn ich jetzt deine Geschichte höre, Ralf, dann herzliches Beileid.
Ich hatte sowas auch schon mal und dachte, alle sind evil, aber.
Ralf, es würde dich freuen zu hören, dass du in Wieso 2025 auch einen Steuer-GPT
hast und da kannst du irgendwie das alles mit AI alle Fragen beantwortet bekommen, die du haben möchtest.
Wird alles gut. Ich lese übrigens gerade, das ist lustig, weil E-Mail funktioniert
für mich überhaupt nicht.
E-Mail ist für mich irgendwie ein totes Medium, weil einfach so die Signal-Noise-Ratio zu brutal ist.
Du hast gerade meine Mail von vorhin gelesen, wo ich dir schreibe,
du sollst mir vielleicht einen ordentlichen Hinweis geben, wann ich hier klingeln soll.
Genau, genau so nämlich. Hast du sie jetzt schon gelesen.
Ja.
Ich verstehe. Nee, sie hat am 27. November geschrieben, dass sie jetzt alles
hat. Mein Gott, Wunder geschehen. Hurra.
Ja, ach ja, naja, das ist...
Hilft also doch aufs neue Microsoft-System zu akualisieren.
Ich wollte mal kurz aufgreifen, was du gesagt hast, Max, weil ich sehe das halt
genauso. Und das ist ja auch etwas, was in unserer Gesellschaft keinen großen
Stellenwert hat. Das ist diese Selbstständigkeit.
Selbstständigkeit ist viel Arbeit, weil unser Rechtssystem so kontra-selbstständiger
ist. Also es ist eigentlich nur für Zahnärzte im Wesentlichen Geld zu sparen,
aber für alle anderen Berufe funktioniert das eher so eingeschränkt.
Und es funktioniert generell in den Berufen, wo man Zahnärzte jetzt stellvertretend
für gut verdienende Selbstständige.
FDP-Wähler.
Genau, FDP-Wähler. Aber wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal,
außerhalb dieses albernen Firmengepflichts dein Business treiben willst,
dann ist es halt schwierig,
weil du dann eben so viel übernehmen musst, weil du dich um so viel kümmern
musst und Krankenversicherung ist schwierig und überhaupt musst alles selber
rausfinden und kannst so viele Fehler machen, keiner nimmt dir das ab und so
und das führt dann eben dazu, dass Leute kapitulieren und sagen,
ach ist mir alles so anstrengend.
Und stell dir mal vor, du hast Leute im föderalen Deutschland,
die in einem anderen Bundesland leben.
die bei dir arbeiten.
Ja, oder außerhalb des Landes generell. Es macht die Sache sehr schwierig auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen ist immer alles so auf Firmenkultur. Und das ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade.
Und ich finde gerade so in unseren Hackern und Nerdkreisen haben wir ja ohnehin
eine ganze Menge Leute, die eigentlich immer so Individualisten sind im besseren Sinne.
Und da passt ja dann oft auch so ein selbstständiges Ding dazu.
Und dann muss man halt auch sich so ein bisschen die Fähigkeiten aufhelfen,
mit denen man dann da auch bestehen kann, trotz dieser Widrigkeiten.
Und dann gibt es aber noch die Möglichkeit, dass du gar nicht selbstständig
sein willst und du dann eine Einmalzahlung von einem Podcaster bekommst,
weil du in einem Podcast mit dabei warst und dann das Finanzamt sagt,
da müssen sie jetzt aber ein Gewerbe für anmelden.
dann sagst du ja okay, wenn ihr das so wollt dann melde ich da jetzt ein Gewerbe für an.
Gewerbe?
Oder eine Selbstständigkeit, irgendwie sowas.
Das ist aber nicht dasselbe, Rogi.
Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich das gemacht und habe das dann auch abgerechnet
und die Steuern bezahlt und alles ist gut.
Und das Jahr drauf fragt dann das Finanzamt, sagen Sie mal, für die Tätigkeit
haben Sie ja gar keine Einnahmen gehabt.
Und dann sage ich so, ja, es war eine Einmalzahlung, aber Sie wollten ja,
dass ich da was anmelde. Das ist einfach so.
Ja, da hatte ich irgendwie, glaube ich, Glück, ganz am Anfang,
als ich noch so mit Grafikdesign zu tun hatte, da brauchte ich dann auch eine
Steuernummer und dann gab es ja den Unterschied zwischen selbstständig und freiberuflich.
Und freiberuflich muss man irgendwie nicht doppelte Berufführung oder was auch immer machen.
Doppelte Berufführung musst du generell erst, wenn du über 250 kam bist.
Glaube ich. Irgendwie war es auf jeden Fall weniger Hässel, wenn man dieses
Fleck bekommen hat freiberuflich und das habe ich auch irgendwie nach wie vor
und da, das Finanzamt hat mich irgendwie bisher immer sehr entspannt in Ruhe gelassen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist… jetzt nach der Sendung ab.
Ja, nee, ich generiere einen Namen aktuell auf meiner freiberuflichen Steuernummer.
Insofern sind sie alle happy.
Aber das war zum Beispiel auch was, was mir keiner vorher gesagt hat, sondern das war so,
glaube ich, in der Uni hat mir das irgendjemand so mit auf den Weg gegeben,
als ich so auf dem Weg zum Finanzamt war, um meine Steuernummer irgendwie zu
beantragen, dass ich auch auf jeden Fall diese Fragen so und so beantworten
möge, damit ich ja dieses freiberuflichen Fleck kriege, damit ich dann weniger Hässe habe.
Ihr habt doch gerade von da drüber geschwärmt, dass es auf dem Camp so toll ist.
dass die Makerscene so viel selber macht, was früher nur die Industrie konnte.
Ich hätte jetzt gerne mal eine Abteilung auf dem Kongress oder auf dem Camp
oder sowas, die so Steuerberater für Nerds oder sowas.
Du hast doch da den Timsen.
Wir haben ISDN auf dem Kongress, jetzt kommt dann auch noch irgendwie Open Elster.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, und dann gibt es ja noch die Solaranlage.
Wenn du eine Solaranlage über einer bestimmten Größe vor einem bestimmten Datum
hast, musst du für diese Solaranlage tatsächlich auch ein Gewerbe anmelden.
Und dann gehört diese Solaranlage diesem Gewerbe. Und wenn du den Strom dann
selber verbrauchst, dann sagt das Finanzamt, ja, aber sie verkaufen sich selbst ja den Strom.
Und jetzt müssen sie natürlich dafür dann quasi Umsatzsteuer zahlen,
weil ja im Prinzip Geld geflossen ist.
Und solche Sachen. Also das ist halt so, du kommst aus der Scheiße einfach nicht raus.
Nun hatte ja Balletti das Thema ursprünglich eingebracht, als Pain-Point.
gar nicht so viel Freude bereitet beim Zuhören.
Wir stellen fest, eigentlich hat nur Ralf Kriegmigräne bei dem Thema.
Weil er es nicht selber macht.
Hat denn nicht noch jemand so ein richtig schönes Thema?
Schöner als Kalender ZFS und was steht da oben? Buchhalte?
Warum ist dein ZFS da jetzt nicht oben? Mach doch mal der ZFS da auch oben. Slash.
Hier, noch von ganz früher.
Was wir uns auch mal eine Zeit lang hatten, In verschiedenen Themen war das mit dem Elektroauto.
Das stimmt.
Da haben wir ganz schön viel rumgeeiert und dann habe ich mir irgendwann mal
so einen Tesla gekauft vor 8,5 Jahren. So lange ist das schon her.
Also Mobilität im Allgemeinen.
Elektromobilität. Der fährt noch. Der fährt super. Immer noch,
weil die Leute immer noch fangen, immer noch mit der ersten Batterie.
Hast du auch so einen Aufkleber hinten drauf jetzt?
Ich hatte mir mal geschworen, als ich ganz junger Mensch war,
mein erstes Auto hatte, dass ich nie meine Autos mit Aufklebern zuflaster.
Ich habe damals schon damit gehadert, mir diese D aufkleben zu müssen,
was man damals noch musste.
Aber es hat ja so noch keiner ein Hakenkreuz reingeritzt oder so.
Nee, aber dieser Aufkleber und damit jetzt alle wissen, wovon ich rede,
I bought it before Elon went nuts.
Sieht man hier wirklich.
Der wäre in der Tat mal angebracht. Nee, aber da oben, da oben Nordbrandenburg
oder McPom, da umarmen mich die Leute nix mit Hakenkreuze.
Das ist eher so.
Das ist so diese 40% Blaugegend da oben.
Die umarmen dich wegen des Autos?
Nein, nein. Wenn, dann würden sie keine Hakenkreuze schnitzen.
Ach so, du bist all right at home.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, zu viel Liebe für die.
Also umarmen, das ist schon...
Ja, das ist zu viel. Das geben die auch nicht. Doch, ne, geben die nicht.
Nein, aber ernsthaft, da haben wir auch lange mitgespielt. Und hin und her.
Und dann gab es Elektroroller hier auch mal.
Hattest du nicht so einen Elektroroller?
Ich wollte gerade mal sagen, also von den sieben anwesenden Personen sind hier
nur drei elektrisch unterwegs, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne?
Roddy war auch schon ganz am Anfang mit dabei.
Ja, ich bin schon beim vierten Elektroauto.
Ich möchte bitte anmerken, dass ich überhaupt nur Beinbetrieb in aller Form unterwegs bin.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, alles mit Bohnen angetrieben.
Mit Bohnen? Kaffeebohnen?
Black Beans.
Black Beans und geht nicht.
Ja, fiel mir jetzt nur noch dazu ein, dass irgendwie, da hat sich auch so ein
bisschen was getan abgesehen davon, dass Elon wirklich ein Nutz wurde.
Aber ich hab mit meinem Ding immer noch Freude, die Supercharger funktionieren
immer noch, und zwar immer noch umsonst für mich. Bam.
Ja, dafür reise ich nicht genug, das jetzt wirklich, aber geht immer noch.
Und es gibt immer noch diese Thema, das hatte ich glaube ich schon mal vor Jahren
schon in der Sendung, nämlich diese, die beschissenste Verkehrsschild,
was wir in Deutschland haben.
Erinnert ihr euch noch? Die gibt es immer noch.
Welches genau meinst du denn jetzt?
Das ist ein rundes Verkehrsschild in weiß mit so fünf grauen Streifen und einer Zahl da drunter.
Ist das dämlichste Verkehrsschild? Das haben wir oben in Meckpommen überall.
Dann fährst du eine Landstraße lang. Wenn eine Landstraße von der Seite was
kommt, dann gehen sie mit einem roten 70-Schild und hinter der Kreuzung steht
nicht etwa da nicht, was du fahren sollst, sondern keine 70.
Nach dem Motto, ja, die 70 gelten nicht mehr. Du solltest dich erinnern,
was hier noch gelten könnte.
Du kannst aber die Regeln durchgehen, haben wir hier zwei getrennte Fahrspuren
oder nicht oder so oder ist es heute Mittwoch oder so.
Wenn es keine Kraftfahrstraße ist, dann ist es 100, oder?
Ja, aber bringe es doch mal einem dämlichen amerikanischen Auto oder einem Ausländer bei.
Warum stellen sie nicht danach hinter wieder ein 100-Schild hin, sondern diese keine 70?
Das ist einfach Doch, das klappt bis heute nicht.
Als jemand, der in den USA gelebt hat, ist das schon ein dramatischer Unterschied,
wie viel Selbstlehren da das Ganze ist. Also es ist ja auch notwendig,
weil du gehst einmal hin zur Fahrprüfung, machst die, erklärst,
wo der Blinker ist und dann kriegst du deinen Führerschein in die Hand gedrückt.
Wenn du einen Termin kriegst.
Ja okay, das war damals nicht so problematisch, aber...
Dieses, wenn da irgendwo verboten ist, bei Rot abzubiegen, dann steht da ein
weißes Schild mit schwarzem Text drauf. No right turn on red.
Und das ist jetzt auch nicht geil, spätestens wenn man die Sprache nicht kann
und so weiter und so fort.
Aber es ist wenigstens selbsterklärend. Also man kommt mit wesentlich weniger
Vorwissen, kommt man im Straßenverkehr zurecht. Das ist sehr angenehm.
Also das ist ein sogenanntes Auflösungszeichen.
Ich weiß, warte, das war. Ich habe meinen Führerschein zurecht.
Das ist halt dieses freie Fahrt-für-freie-Bürger-Ding.
Aber danach darfst du trotzdem nur 100 fahren, wenn es eine Landstraße ist.
Ja, aber wenn da ein LKWs-dürfen-nicht-überholens-Schild auch noch gewesen wäre,
dann löst dieses Schild ja nur die Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung auf,
aber nicht das andere Verbrauch.
Ja, aber warum schreiben sie nicht einfach hin 100?
Genau. Warum schreiben sie nicht einfach den Titel.
Was ab da geht? Weil es eine Straße ist, wo du 100 fahren darfst.
Ja, eben. Dann schreiben sie daran 100.
Das hat gefälligst jeder zu wissen.
Also mein Auto kriegt das hin. eins der wenigen Dinge, die es hinkriegt. Aber gut.
Dann gibt es ja noch diese anderen Spielregeln mit, wenn da eine Straße von
unten reinkommt, dass dann entweder musst du,
sozusagen die Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung neu machen oder sie fällt automatisch
wieder auf den Default zurück. Das kriegt das Auto auch nicht gebacken.
Du hast eine Straße, da ist, kann ich aber sagen, gibt es ja auf der B96 den
schönen Ort Nassenheide, die haben wahrscheinlich jemanden, der da am Landtag
sitzt oder sowas, der hat mal durchgesetzt, dass da 30 gilt,
was auch schön ist, aber diese 30 hören einfach mitten in dem Ort auf.
Warum? Weil eine Straße einmündet von der Seite.
Da hätte man jetzt nicht mal wieder ein 50-Schild hinstellen können.
Nein, die hören dort einfach auf, weil eine Straße von der Seite einmündet und
kein neues 30-Schild da steht. What the fuck?
Die grundlegende Frage, die du dahinter gestellt hast, war ja so,
wo geht denn das jetzt mit dieser Elektromobilität eigentlich hin?
Ja, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung.
Stopp, Stopp, Stopp, Sorry.
Ich muss jetzt, nein, ich hab da zwei Dinge vermischt. Mit dem Tesla kam ja
damals auch, wir fahren jetzt mit dem Computer rum.
Das war ja damals auch so ein bisschen neu. Inzwischen macht ja jeder Hannes
und sein dummer Bruder da einen Computer rein, egal ob das Auto jetzt mit Strom oder Benzin fährt.
Und einer davon ist schlechter als der nächste. Es ist unglaublich,
diese Software, mit der die Leute da rumfahren, insbesondere von europäischen Herstellern.
Oh ja.
Aber hast du schon mal in einem Xiaomi gesessen?
Was, die machen Autos mittlerweile?
Schon länger. Und es gibt ja immer so diese Posts, wenn die irgendwann mal im
Westen verkaufen dürfen, dann sind die ganzen Autohersteller eh.
Nun, da gibt es auch jetzt so ein Video von Markus, der ein Xiaomi-Auto reviewt hat.
Und ja, also wenn man das so sieht, dann denkt man sich schon,
also VW, BMW und wie sie alle heißen.
Stellantis.
Ihr könnt da schon mal zusammenpacken dann. Und es soll ja wohl ab 2027 in der EU zugelassen werden.
Okay.
Ja, die bereiten sich wohl darauf vor, den hier zu verkaufen.
Von mir wird es jetzt kein gutes Wort zum Thema Software und VW geben.
Ich glaube, da kann man auch kein gutes Wort verhindern.
Da gibt es keine Worte.
Tausende von Leuten, die da arbeiten. Du sitzt vor diesem UI und denkst,
what the fuck, aus welcher Hölle?
Wenn man da aber mal, also ich hab da wohl mal kurzzeitig mit denen gearbeitet
und wenn du da gearbeitet hast, ist dir alles klar, warum das so aussieht, wie das da aussieht.
Ich hatte mal Kunden aus der Szene.
Ich kenne mehrere Leute, die da gearbeitet haben und ich kenne mehrere Leute,
die gerage quittet haben.
Durchaus auch in unsicheren Jobpositionen, die nicht so leicht was Neues finden,
die rausgerannt sind und Freiheit gebrüllt haben. Das ist unfassbar.
Aber ein Problem, was die da wohl haben, das war damals so, als ich da auch
an so einem Projekt zu tun hatte,
ist, dass halt irgendjemand weit bevor es dazu kam, das in ein Auto einzubauen,
schon beschlossen hat, welche Touchscreens.
Da zum Einsatz kommen. Und zwei, drei Jahre später kommt dann so ein Software-Development-Team
und soll jetzt das neue irgendwie geile Interface bauen und kriegen dann so Touchscreens,
die so eine Sekunde Latenz zwischen Touch und Reaktion haben,
die einfach total underpowered für den Job sind.
Also die schnellen.
Ja, und so eine Planwirtschaft,
so ein Waterfall-System gibt es da, da wird halt irgendwie von einer Abteilung
eingekauft, irgendwelche Hardware mit null Rücksprache oder weit voraussicht,
wie dann die eigentliche Implementation in dem Fahrzeug ist und dann kommt halt sowas dabei raus.
Bundesamt für Automobilbau, sagen doch auch manche.
Das ist ein Thing, der keeps on giving.
Also wirklich, die Abgründe, in die man dort fällt, und zwar rechts und links
und jedes Mal, wenn du aus einem rauskrabbelst, fällst du in den nächsten rein.
Das ist wirklich un-unsäglich. Und ich frage mich echt, das sind tausende von
Leuten, wie gesagt, BMW, VW, Stellantis, wie sie alle heißen,
und ich habe bisher nichts gesehen, was da einigermaßen funktioniert.
Ich bin Miles-Kunde, das ist hier so ein Carsharing-Anbieter und die haben ja
auch den ID.3 und den hatte ich neulich mal wieder ein und der wurde geladen
und ich bin hingegangen und ich kriegte den,
das Ladegerät, das Ladekabel nicht ab.
Und ich wusste noch den Trick, dahingehend Tür aufmachen, Zündung aus,
einmal zuschließen, einmal aufschließen von innen und dann kannst du,
wenn du das zweite Mal dann aufgeschlossen hast, dann kannst du das Kabel abziehen.
Ich wusste es noch auswendig.
Weil ich das oft genug gemacht habe.
Und mit der kleinen Kurve ganz nach oben.
Ich wollte eigentlich auf eine andere Frage hinaus, wo ich jetzt hier so viele
Expertinnen und Experten sitzend habe.
Ihr kennt, ich habe es auch gerade in den Chat reingepostet,
dieses Bild, diese Europakarte mit den Tempolimits,
wo alles rot ist und alle vernünftigen Länder dieser Welt irgendwo ein Tempolimit
haben und einzig und allein Deutschland ist freie Fahrt für freie Bürger.
Eigentlich müsste die Farbe andersrum sein, alle anderen Länder grün, nur wir rot.
Wer von euch verspricht mir, dass wir hier nicht zur 400,
zur 500 und zur 600 Freakshow sitzen und alle anderen Länder fröhlich auf Elektro
fahren und wir immer noch Diesel und Benzin verwenden, weil wir sind Deutschland hier.
Das wird nie passieren, dass wir hier. Das ist durch.
Ich meine, das Thema ist durch. Das sind jetzt die allerletzten Abwehrschlachten,
die da noch gefällt werden, aber wenn du die Märkte real anschaust, ist das Thema durch.
Also Tim, meinst du, das Thema ist durch mit Deutschland und wir gehen wieder
direkt zur Pferdekutsche zurück.
Weil dann gebe ich dir recht.
Es hat sich technologisch jetzt woanders schon so weit entschieden,
dass auch Deutschland an dieser Realität nicht dran vorbeikommt.
Und natürlich sind wir die Letzten, die durchs Tor gehen und am meisten draufzahlen müssen.
Warum?
Was macht dich da so sicher, dass wir nicht in zehn Jahren hier noch genauso
Benzin und Diesel fahren?
Kosten. Also die Kosten werden einfach so dermaßen durch die Decke gehen in den nächsten Jahren.
Also erstens ist das EU-weit ohnehin schon seit langem beschlossen,
dass die fossilen Treibstoffe im Preis weiter anziehen.
Außerdem werden die Kosten für die Elektroautos extrem, für alle Elektrofahrzeuge extrem sinken.
Hat das nicht Elon gerade verkündet, dass die EU aufgelöst wird?
Hat Elon beschlossen.
Die Frage ist nur eher, fahren wir hier deutsche Fahrzeuge oder fahren wir chinesische Fahrzeuge?
Und ich glaube, da trennt die eher in Richtung chinesische Fahrzeuge.
Und ich kenne auch so Leute, die beim Bosch schaffen und so.
Und das ist überall, wenn du so mit den Leuten sprichst, da ist eigentlich schon
der Abgesang läuft schon.
Das ist wirklich so diese Führungsetagen, wo irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
ob die das nur so Publicity-mäßig machen oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
sich da selber noch die Gehälter irgendwie und Boni absichern wollen.
Ich habe neulich die spannende Theorie gehört, in dem Moment,
in dem das mit dem Verbrenner vorbei ist, müssen die so viel Technologie und Patente und...
Zeug abschreiben, dass wer auch immer das zu verbuchen hat, in seiner Amtszeit
als CEO von dem Laden halt einen gigantischen Verlust auf dem Papier haben wird,
sodass die das alle noch so lange wie es geht rauszögern wollen,
dass halt immer noch diese Idee da ist.
Das ist ein interessanter buchhalterischer Aspekt. Wir wissen hier noch,
wie man eine Einspritzpumpe baut und das ist so und so viele Millionen wert
und darum braucht man die nicht aus dem Buch.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch einen anderen Aspekt, also zumindest bei Benz hat sich
ja Saudi-Arabien mit 20 Prozent oder so eingekauft.
Und die haben natürlich möglichen Interesse daran, weiter ihr Öl zu verkaufen.
Also die haben ja auch dafür gesorgt, dass obwohl das russische Öl vom Weltmarkt
weitestgehend verschwunden ist, der Ölpreis niedrig bleibt, damit die Leute
nicht merken, oh huch, es ist jetzt vielleicht wirklich mal Ende und wir sollten
mal alles elektrisch machen.
Also den Faktor würde ich nicht außer Blick lassen.
Aber es ist einfach in Deutschland.
Es ist wirklich schon so hart verkackt an der Basis, das wird einfach nichts mehr.
Wir haben das erfunden, da können wir das doch nicht einfach aufgeben.
Ja, aber unterhalte ich mal mit Leuten zum Beispiel bei Bosch und wie es da
gerade so aussieht mit genau diesen ganzen Zulieferaspekten und Abbau von Stellen
und Abteilungen und irgendwie, oh Gott, oh Gott, Abrissstimmung.
Ich glaube auch, das ist schon, der Weg ist schon quasi...
Ich glaube, die sind auch nicht doof. Also ganz ehrlich, aber sie werden halt
auch von der Politik immer wieder genastführt.
Also wenn jetzt, wenn jemand mal gesagt hätte, wir machen jetzt einen Verbrenner
aus und wir halten auch daran fest, dann hätten sie noch mal hier ein bisschen
geknurrt und da noch ein bisschen geknurrt und Abschreibung und blau und blub
und also Zeugs, aber da wären sie glaube ich okay mit gewesen.
Aber jetzt kommt der Merz wieder und seine Kumpanen da und sagen,
naja, Verbrennerverbot, es kippt mal wieder und hin und her.
Und klar, wenn Es ist vollkommen egal.
Was diese Fatzkes von der CDU erzählen. Sie werden es eh nicht verhindern können.
Das Ding ist, bis 2030 ist das Thema durch.
Damit sage ich jetzt nicht, es wird kein Verbrennerfahrzeug mehr verkauft oder so.
Also, aber es werden automatisch die Leute einfach fast keine mehr kaufen wollen,
weil es einfach zu teuer wird bis dahin, beziehungsweise weil in diesen nächsten
vier, fünf Jahren Elektrofahrzeuge viel, viel, viel billiger werden.
Ich meine, sie sind heute schon de facto billiger, das sehen die Leute bloß
nicht, weil sie nur über den Verkaufspreis denken und nicht über den Lifetime-Kost
mit Wartung und so weiter.
Ich meine, ich fahre jetzt seit drei Jahren dieses Motorrad jeden Tag quer durch die Stadt.
Ich bringe das regelmäßig zur Begutachtung.
Mein Tesla, achteinhalb Jahre.
Es ist einfach da nichts, was da groß kaputt gehen kann, es sei denn,
du fährst irgendwo gegen.
Die Verbrennertechnologie wird ja auch noch gebraucht und ich denke,
es wird einen Großteil davon einfach in die Militärindustrie wandern,
weil da werden wir sie noch langfristig benötigen,
gerade jetzt in den nächsten Jahren, wenn es dann halt mal richtig losgeht mit
dem Krieg, so wie wir das jetzt rauszögern, wird sich das ja wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr lange verhindern lassen und da brauchst du das dann halt.
Da geht der Diesel dann irgendwie hin.
Oder gerade nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich halte es für durchaus möglich, weil das ist ja auch mit
Versorgungslinien, ich bin kein Militärexperte.
Elektropanzer oder was?
Keine Ahnung, also dass du irgendwelche Sachen direkt vor Ort fährst.
Hybrid ja, weil du willst natürlich leise fahren in bestimmten Bedingungen.
Also keine Ahnung, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass selbst da,
aber ich finde es erstaunlich, dass die Leute,
die problemlos in der Lage sind, dir vorzurechnen, warum ein Diesel trotz höherem
Anschaffungspreis dann auf Dauer billiger wird und dir das bei einem E-Auto
nicht hinkriegen, genau die gleiche Denkleistung hinzubekommen. Aber ja.
Aber jeder, der halbwegs beisammen hat und die Zahlen sich anschaut,
versteht, dass das Thema durch ist.
Es ist halt nur in Deutschland auch eine totale Gaga-Diskussion im Laufen.
Die anderen Länder, die halten sich doch sowieso nur noch die Bäuche über uns.
Was kriegt denn dieses Land überhaupt noch auf die Kette? Nichts.
Ich meine, gibt es noch irgendwas, wo Deutschland führend ist? Mir fällt da nichts an.
Kapitelmarken.
Ich hatte die letzte Basis.
Ich hatte vor ein paar Wochen an der Ladesäule, hatte ich ein lustiges Gespräch.
Neulich an den Ladesäule.
Da war so ein Bauer, der hatte halt eine große Scheune und hat sich vor 20 Jahren
eine große Salaranlage auf diese große Scheune dengeln lassen.
Hat 20 Jahre Einspeisevergütung kassiert.
Er meinte auch, die Anlage hat sich nach 19 Jahren dann auch bezahlt gemacht
und der Rest war halt Geld, was reinkam. Aber nach 20 Jahren ist halt die,
Einspeiseverkühlung weg und jetzt müsste er Strom verbrauchen,
jetzt hat er sich ein Elektroauto gekauft, jetzt guckt er mal, wie das funktioniert.
Nach 20 Jahren.
Die beiden waren so großartig, er und seine Frau, die waren wirklich so,
ja, keine Ahnung, wir haben auch noch nicht geladen, wir machen das jetzt mal
so. Nö, funktioniert ja so halbwegs.
Ja, jetzt hätte noch, das ist doch wirklich, also diese Diskussion,
ich hatte das ja auch schon so in meinem Familienkreis, wurde wirklich so,
denkst, sag mal, habt ihr noch nie eine Batterie aufgeladen?
Also wirklich so wie die ersten Menschen, als ob die da so das erste Mal vor
irgendwie so Technik, ja, Elektro, kann das funktionieren?
Alter, ihr benutzt euer, euer ganzer Alltag ist Elektro, elektrisch.
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, weil die Leute sind es gewöhnt,
dass so ein Handy nach drei Jahren, vier Jahren der Akku halt durch ist und
die dann die Angst haben, dass es beim Elektroauto genauso wäre.
Obwohl es eine andere Akkutechnologie ist und andere Batterie-Management-Systeme
und so weiter und so weiter.
Das ist aber witzigerweise selten irgendwie in der Diskussion,
sondern das ist wirklich so ganz,
dumpfe, irgendwie keine fünf Sekunden selber drüber nachgedacht,
ob das nicht vielleicht doch besser sein könnte, sondern irgendwie dieses krampfhafte
Festhalten an dieser Verbrenner und selber schalten und irgendwie das ist doch nix.
Was mir da noch, was da eigentlich noch mehr weh tut, ich meine Elektroauto,
die haben wenigstens eine kürzere Reichweite und man muss sie länger laden.
Das ist wenigstens theoretisch ein Nachteil.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es... Aber wir haben die fucking Wärmepumpe zum Kulturkampfthema gemacht.
Haushaltstechnologie beschäftigt dieses Land bis zur Weißglut.
Ich finde die Diskussion ist einfach zu führen. Ich weise die Leute immer darauf
hin, dass sie ja schon seit mehreren Jahrzehnten eine Wärmepumpe in ihrem Haushalt betreiben.
Ja klar, Kühlschrank.
So muss man die Diskussion umdrehen.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich diese, immer wenn ich so irgendwelche Familien treffen
habe und dann solche Gespräche auch losgehen und das ist leider in meiner Familie
teilweise so der Fall, wo dann diese Argumente aus direkt so aus der...
Früher war es der Nazi-Onkel, jetzt ist es der Verbrenner-Onkel.
Ja, wirklich.
Wirklich.
Die Nazis haben auch schon verbrannt.
Ja, und die Wärmepumpe genau dasselbe und wirklich dann überlege ich mir immer
so, okay, hole ich jetzt die ganze Liste von Argumenten raus,
führe ich jetzt hier so ein einstündiges Gespräch und am Ende...
Oder fährt man einfach nur viel seltener hin.
Ja, fährt man seltener hin oder geht früher und fährt mit seinem Elektroauto schleichend davon.
Apropos das Schleichen davonfahren. Ich würde jetzt auch gleich mal schleichend
davonfahren, denn ich muss morgen früh wieder...
Der kleine Huckel muss nochmal lochen.
Der muss noch mal hoch. Schade.
Vorhin habe ich doch gehört, er ist draußen hier noch meine Kreise gezogen.
Habt ihr doch darüber gelästert, wie du musstest morgen zur Schule.
Der kleine Huckel muss morgen noch zur Schule und der Dennis muss mal hoch.
In der Vorweihnachtszeit kommen einfach alle aus ihren Ecken gekrümelt und wollen
noch mal irgendwas machen und noch mal irgendwie treffen und so weiter.
Wir wollen noch mal ein Bücher raushauen.
Wir podcasten am Mittwochmorgen.
Also wir podcasten gefühlt schon fast morgen.
Genau.
Und ja, morgen muss ich auch schon wieder
früh raus, wegen irgendwelchen Terminkollidierungen, deswegen ich muss.
Aber warst du denn bei deiner ersten Folge eigentlich wirklich noch in der Schule?
Das wurde sehr authentisch. In der Uni war ich da glaube ich noch.
In der Hacker-Schule war da noch der Echte Stimme der Jugend.
Ja, ich musste da auch um 9.10. schon auf der Matte stehen, ist ja klar. Äh, ne, ja.
Anyway, also das heißt, ich mach mal hier ein Headset frei für den nächsten Gast.
Ihr müsst ja nochmal euren Podcast featuren.
Ja, noch mehr. Ja,
Glitterbrains.
Einfach eingehen bei Podcast-Klienten ihrer Wahl. Wahrscheinlich nur bei Apple.
Ich glaube, ich habe es nur bei iTunes angemeldet.
Ja, den haben wir eigentlich nur gestartet ursprünglich, weil ganz viele Freakshow-Hörer
unsere Stimmen vermisst haben.
Nee, eigentlich haben wir den gestartet, weil wir in guter Stimmung uns lustige
Namen überlegt haben für Projekte.
Also in meiner Erinnerung war das anders, dass Leute gefragt haben und ich irgendwie
dachte, ja, wir brauchen erstmal einen Namen für den Podcast.
Und dann hatten wir da so einen leichten LSD-Trip und da ist Glitterbrains als
Wortfindung am Ende hängen geblieben und das war dann der Startschuss für den Podcast.
Aber am Ende des Tages, ja, kleiner lauschiger Podcast mit Letty und mir,
der unregelmäßigen Abständen erscheint.
Aber die neue Folge wird morgen, nee, Mittwoch früh aufgenommen, ja.
Wir nehmen meistens in aller Herrgottsfröhe auf.
Weil das irgendwie ganz gut passt. Aber ja, es ist auch so, themenlastig auf
jeden Fall, sehr selten Technik, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, dann klicke ich da mal drauf.
Aber wir schweifen leider sehr häufig auch, ich weiß nicht, leider,
aber zu Computerspielen ab.
Es scheint irgendwie auch mal wieder so ein niederkemmendes Theme zu sein.
Das sind im Prinzip alle die Themen, die Tim nie ausgiebig besprechen wollte.
Ja, aber das haben Roddy und ich jetzt hier aber im Griff. Also Computerspiele passieren jetzt hier.
Die Kapitelmarke sind hier PHP-Exploit,
minimales Podcast-Backend mit Podlove-Webplayer, GitHub-Alternative.
Da war der Alex zu Gast, da war er sehr viel technischer.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn nur Huckel und ich am Start sind, ist weniger Technik.
Aber Alex hat auf jeden Fall die Technikquote sehr weit nach oben getrieben bei uns.
Ja, nach dem Podlove-Exploit. Ich benutze ja Podlove auch für alles Mögliche.
Unter anderem habe ich meine Proberaumaufnahmen halt immer damit veröffentlicht,
weil dann die Bandmitglieder quasi einfach im Podcast-Client den Proberaummitschnitt
einfach reingefiedelt bekommen mit Kapitelmarken für,
weil wir nehmen ja dann halt natürlich drei, vier Stunden auf.
Ich mache da jetzt nicht irgendwie Marker während der Probe am Mixer rein.
Das mache ich dann hinterher, mache die Marker rein und lade es aber am en bloc
quasi hoch, damit man dann schön hin und her springen kann.
Und das war die einzige Potluff-Installation, die durch den Exploit so komplett
zerhackt und zerstückelt wurde, dass ich in den alten ZFS-Snapshot reingucken
musste, um das wieder halbwegs herzustellen.
Dann fehlte aber, weil ich natürlich
die nicht automatisch und regelmäßig gemacht habe, ein halbes Jahr.
Und deswegen hatte ich dann irgendwie gedacht, okay, für diesen Anwendungsfall,
was wäre der minimalste Ansatz, um jetzt so ein Podcast-Ding zu bauen.
Und das wurde in der letzten Folge besprochen, unter anderem mit dem Alex,
der mir teilweise dabei geholfen hat, den Podlove-Webplayer dann dafür auch einzubauen.
Und dann wurde es halt ein bisschen technisch. Und jetzt habe ich durch die
Hintertür noch schnell dieses kleine Podcast-Framework gefeatured,
falls ihr mal selber was hosten wollt und kein PHP-Wordpress.
Potlove Exploit? Potlove Exploit kam unter meinem Stein nicht vor da oben. Wieso?
War ich auch dabei beim Potlove Exploit.
Ja, das war krass. Weil irgendwie ich dachte auch so, das kam so auf meiner
Mastodon-Timer, nicht sofort irgendwie ran an die Tasten, alles updaten und
dann gesehen. War schon weg. Ah, kacke.
Wie ein WordPress-Hack über Potlove oder was?
Ja, und ich meine, der Erik, das ist halt PHP.
Ich würde auch ein Schlussplädoyer dafür setzen, dass wir jetzt PHP 2026 schaffen,
wir das jetzt auch endlich mal ab, weil es ist einfach, das hat seinen Dienst getan,
ja, war schön, hat viel, viel möglich gemacht, hat viel Freude,
viel Schmerzen bereitet, aber mittlerweile hat es den Status von Schockwelle
Blitz und muss jetzt halt weg als Technologie, finde ich, und abgeschafft werden,
weil es einfach so leicht ist mit dieser Sprache,
wenn du nicht irgendwie bei jedem Update die API genau verstehst,
und jedes Fleck irgendwie zweimal unter die Lupe nimmst.
Was ist die Konsequenz, wenn ich das jetzt nicht setze und dies und das?
Der Default ist halt einfach nach wie vor unsicher.
Und ja, man kann sich da einfach schnell in die Kacke reiten,
ohne böse Absichten. Deswegen weg damit jetzt.
Ja, raus.
Raus. Ja.
Ja.
Betretenes Schweigen.
Ja, das ist...
Ich hab dem wenig hinzuzufügen. Ich probier das auch schon seit längerem, aber es ist schwierig.
Die Orkwood-PAP Death Silence.
Ja, und bei dem Exploit, das war halt auch so, eigentlich so,
so wie ich das verstanden hab, jetzt nicht ein grobes, ein grober Fehler.
Das hätte einfach jedem passieren können und es wurde einfach sehr schnell automatisch,
wie das halt so ist mit den Exploits da draußen.
Wenn du dann nicht sofort, also ich weiß nicht, was so das Impact-Window gewesen
wäre, in der man eine Chance gehabt hätte, seinen WordPress und so weiter abzudaten,
um nicht betroffen zu sein.
Es ging halt sehr schnell dann auch.
Und es war, ich hab mir.
Nachdem ich betroffen war, hab ich mir diesen Exploit dann auch mal angeguckt,
ein bisschen ausführlicher.
Ich glaube, jetzt, ich sag jetzt nicht prinzipiell jetzt hier keine,
Schuldzuweisung, Nichts für PHP sagen, nichts Positives, aber ich glaube,
das war ein Bug, der hätte in jeder Sprache passieren können.
Also ich weiß nicht, welche der aktuellen Websprachen da jetzt besser wäre.
Es ist halt in PHP, finde ich, immer noch besonders einfach, weil du bist in so einem,
also das ganze Environment ist halt irgendwie schon so einfach voller Tretminen
und weiß nicht, man kann gar nicht genug aufpassen gefühlt.
Also das ist so wie, du hast ja jetzt in jedem OS-Update nach wie vor jedes
Mal Security-Patches für, was weiß ich, LibZip, LibXML, LibTIV,
LibJPEG und wie sie nicht alle heißen.
Und das kriegst du genauso wenig totgefühlt irgendwie.
Da müsste man auch mal hingehen und sagen, komm, mach das doch einmal in Rust
oder was auch immer und schmeiß das Zähgelumpe weg.
Endlich mal weg. Aber nee, das schreifen wir auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit immer weiter.
Todgesagte Leben länger.
Das Elend hat Persistenz.
Ja.
Der Sendungstitel. Sucht ihr immer noch Sendungstitel?
Das Elend hat Persistenz.
Das ist doch der Sendungstitel.
Ja, wirklich dieses ganze Open-Source-Thema, da könnte man stundenlang drüber reden.
Als der LibXML-Maintainer gesagt hat, er hat jetzt keinen Bock mehr,
Da ist auch so die ganze Open-Source-Welt, weil jeder hat LibXML gefühlt mit inkludiert.
Kurz nochmal aufgehorcht, Moment mal, wie das hat einer maintained und der geht
jetzt in Rente. Was machen wir denn da?
Da gibt es von Wild Wild Web auch eine schöne Folge. Die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
Geschichten aus dem Internet, Bayerischer Rundfunk. Generell finde ich es ein schöner Podcast.
Ich suche gerade mal raus, welche das ist.
Sagen wir, ihr arbeitet alle noch. Wann habt ihr denn Zeit, diese ganzen Podcasts zu hören?
Ich höre keine Podcasts.
Ah, ich auch nicht.
Also außer News-Podcast.
Ich arbeite nicht, ich bin selbstständig. Insofern habe ich Zeit.
Ja, verstehe.
Ah, ihr ist Beamter, jetzt wird mir einiges. Alles klar.
Gut, ich schleiche mich mal jetzt so langsam raus.
Wie lange machen wir denn jetzt noch?
Naja.
Du hast doch selber gesagt, das Elend hat Persistenz.
Ich sag mal Tschüss.
Tschüss, hey du. Tschüssi. Bis zur 4.
Oder vielleicht mal zwischendurch.
Vielen Dank.
Nicht schon Tim verraten.
Da ist die Folge das wichtigste Hobby der Welt vom 17.04.25.
Noch ganz frisch. Da geht es genau um diese Fragestellung, wie viel Infrastruktur
des Internet liegt eigentlich auf sehr wenigen Open-Source-Schultern.
Hucke, sah uns ein Fest. Vielen Dank. Tschüss.
Schön, euch wiederzusehen. Bis bald. Ciao.
Das ist natürlich so eine, weil wir vorhin mit den ganzen Makern,
die jetzt Firmen ersetzen können, in dem Moment, in dem das irgendwelche Open-Source-Maintainer
sind, wenn das dann in die reale Welt noch ein bisschen mehr übergeht,
dass dann irgendwie irgendwelche Firmen von irgendwelchen 3D-Modellen in irgendwelchen
3D-Druckern abhängig sind, die von irgendeiner Person in Malaysia gewartet werden,
die dann auch damit aufhört. Das wird noch ganz andere Dimensionen dann alles gehen.
Gibt es denn aus dem Chat noch Dinge, die ihr wissen wollt oder besprochen haben
möchtet, wo ihr jetzt die einmalige
Gelegenheit habt, hier noch so ein All-Star-Team versammelt zu haben?
Jetzt, wo Huckelwältet weg ist.
Ist ein All-Star-Team? Dann ist jetzt der Moment oder es wird für immer geschwiegen.
Jetzt willst du noch ein Q&A aufmachen.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall schon mal die Tierlist ausgefüllt jetzt hier.
Genau, da können wir mal gucken, wie verhalten wir uns dazu.
Da können wir nochmal die URL rumschicken.
Clubhouse auf einem Level mit Twitter.
Ja, das würde ich aber auch eher weiter...
Naja, du kannst das auch editieren.
Ich meine, Clubhouse war gefühlt zwei Wochen. Das war ein bisschen länger als Ping.
aber auf jeden Fall mal kürzer als Google Wave.
Das ist ja auch nur C.
Wo ist Google Wave?
Google Wave war hier nie ein Thema.
Was? Ich habe ja eine Folge, wo wir das live ausprobiert haben.
Da musst du da ein Logo reinladen.
Aber ist das nicht so zwischen zwei Folgen passiert und dann war es wieder weg?
Ja, ja. Und die eine Folge davon haben wir live gemacht. Als wir es alle bekommen haben.
Ja.
Ich bin müde.
Wir sind alt. Das können wir auch mal thematisieren. Entschuldigung.
Das war jetzt nicht charmant.
Das war auch meinerseits nicht charmant, aber ich weiß, das ist kurz erwähnt.
Du hast recht, aber wenn ich auch Tim da jetzt so sitzen sehe mit seinem Aschenbecher
am Gesicht, mit seinem Doppelaschenbecher.
Was?
Du hast schon einen ganz schönen Bucker auf deiner Brille.
Jetzt kommt die Beleidigung raus.
Nein, das ist keine Beleidigung. Es ist einfach nur, wir auch alle schön plauzen
und so. Also schon, ja, genau.
Ja, was ist dann?
Das ist schon ein Club alter weißer Männer, abgesehen von Letty.
Danke.
Auch weiß, tendenziell.
Weiß?
Ja, im Gesicht, in den Händen und so.
Achso, okay. Bei euch weiß schon.
Ich hab Tim gerade vor den Augen. Ja, aber guck mal, Ralf und Roddy färben noch.
Bei Max weiß man nicht, Berufsugendlicher zu sein ist ganz schön anstrengend.
Das frisst auch ein bisschen an einem.
Aber in der Birne muss man ja noch halbwegs dabei sein.
Muss man mehr tanzen, Alter.
Ja, das kann schon sein, aber nicht jetzt.
Vielleicht solltest du Tim mal mitnehmen zum Tanzen.
Ja, gerne.
Bin ja schon froh, wenn er mir innerhalb von drei Monaten auf meine Nachrichten antwortet. Ach komm.
Dazu muss ich die dann auch mal lesen. Es gibt jetzt einfach mal,
kann man auch mal sagen, die Nerds von gestern sind die Opas von heute und die
haben andere Dinge zu tun.
Ich gebe manchmal Wochen, da klappt mein Laptop nicht auf.
Kann nur reden. Ich bin froh, dass die Greifel Nachrichten noch rechtzeitig gelesen haben.
Naja, gut.
I mean it. Echt jetzt?
Okay.
So, ich würde sagen, wir machen den Sack zu.
Wir machen einfach mal Schluss.
Extro. Du wolltest die Moderation heute an mich reißen. Ich dachte,
ich übergebe das dann irgendwann.
Achso, ja. Du hast gesagt, ich habe nichts zu tun. Und das geht alles von alleine.
Und dann hast du hier nur geschwitzt und gestört.
Ja, ich meine, da siehst du jetzt mal, was bedeutet sich, auf so eine Sendung
vorzubereiten, das ist nämlich manchmal gar nicht so einfach.
Ich hatte kurzzeitig Bedenken runterzukommen, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil als ich Tim gehört habe, als Clemens reinkam und der seinen Nervenzusammenbruch
hatte, dachte ich, oh Gott, ich will nicht da wirklich klingeln.
Naja, nur wegen dieser technischen Herausforderung. Ich bin ja nicht gewarnt
worden. Ich wusste ja nicht, dass ich jetzt hier ein Setup für sieben bis acht Leute liefern muss.
Ich wollte sagen, Ralf, danke, dass du dich so gut ums Audioequipment gekümmert hast.
Danke, Ralf, dass du es überhaupt organisiert hast.
Dass du es angezettelt hast.
Der Chat war zwischenzeitlich doch ganz angetan.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet etwas Spaß mit dieser etwas speziellen Folge hier.
David, melde dich. Du hast hier hart gefehlt heute.
Ein Thema muss ich nochmal anbringen, weil es ist ja nur so nebenbei angeflogen,
aber diese Organisation hier, diese Meta-Ebene, die gibt es jetzt seit 20 Jahren.
Also es ist ja nicht nur 300 Freakshows, sondern es ist ja auch insgesamt 20 Jahre Podcasterei.
Also von mir sozusagen, also es ist 20 Jahre her, dass ich jetzt die erste Sendung
mal wirklich in einem RSS-Feed bereitgestellt habe und ja,
ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da noch groß zu sagen soll, vielleicht fällt euch da ja was zu ein.
Auf jeden Fall hat das jetzt gerade stattgefunden am 22.
November und ja, da ist ja einiges passiert in der ganzen Zeit und auch dieses
Studio existiert jetzt mittlerweile seit 16 Jahren.
Das ist auch ziemlich bemerkenswert, dass das sozusagen alles immer noch so existiert.
Ja, und dann möchte ich mich halt auch bedanken bei den Hörern. Ach so, ja genau.
Und falls ihr dann zum Jahresende auch noch ein bisschen gnädig seid,
was die finanzielle Unterstützung betrifft, Dann gibt es dann vielleicht auch
demnächst mal 10 Gigabit auf dem Server, damit das mit dem Download bei der
Freakshow nicht ganz so lange dauert.
Aber ich habe mich immer ein bisschen geziert, weil das immer so teuer ist,
diese Scheiß-Hosterei.
Die wollen dann gleich ganz viel Geld von einem haben.
Ich glaube, ein Drittel der Kommentare im Blog der letzten Folge bezog sich
nur auf die Download-Erfahrung.
Ja, und ich kann das ja auch ganz gut nachvollziehen. Das muss sich auch irgendwie
ändern. Aber es muss halt irgendwie auch alles finanziert werden und irgendwie
kommt echt einiges zusammen bei der ganzen Hosterei.
Ich hab auch noch was zu sagen zu deinen 20 Jahren. Applaus, Applaus, Applaus!
Danke, danke.
I mean it.
Ja, na gut, Leute. Das war's. Und wir machen Kongress.
Das ist sozusagen das nächste Ereignis. wenn ihr auf dem Kongress seid,
kommt ins Sendezentrum.
Das ist dann am zweiten Tag machen wir unseren kleinen Freakshow-Clubhaus.
Haben wir das schon festgelegt, welcher Tag das ist? Aber es spricht wahrscheinlich nichts dagegen.
Das Sendezentrum hat es festgelegt und zwar auf den zweiten Tag.
Warte mal, ich so nochmal. Ich glaube es sind, es war glaube ich 18 Uhr.
Wie ist da überhaupt die Adresse?
Kongress.
Der Raum ist glaube ich nicht so Session in drei Wochen wieder.
Also kommt Zeit. In weniger als drei Wochen.
Und bringt vor allem Themen mit.
Ihr erinnert euch, in der letzten Sendung hatten wir das ja ein bisschen.
Ich habe jetzt den Link gerade nicht parat, aber es ist irgendwie,
es war glaube ich am zweiten Tag war es um 18 Uhr oder so.
Und dann machen wir das so. Alright. Supi. Na dann, vielen Dank,
Clemens, Letty, fürs Kommen, Max und Roddy natürlich.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Vielen Dank. Den Mac-Jangle haben wir gar nicht abgespielt. Na egal,
das machen wir nächstes Mal.
Da haben wir vielleicht mal wieder was zu erzählen. Da reden wir mal wieder mehr über Max.
Wir müssen mal wieder mehr über Max reden. So, genau. Und jetzt hier das beste Outro der Welt.
Mit dir, Steve.
Genau, das ist Steve. Grüßt euch und gegrüßt euch auch. Das war's. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Bis dann.